[Music]
it is no surprise that business
analytics and business intelligence are
two of the fastest growing markets in
the world
organizations today are generating data
at a rapid rate there is a need to use
this business data and make smarter
decisions
companies are looking for methods and
tools to turn business data into
actionable insights this is where
business analytics and intelligence can
help play a critical role business
analytics is the process of collecting
analyzing and drawing valuable
conclusions from vast volumes of data
available it helps to improve business
performance through fact based decision
making on the other hand business
intelligence of bi is a technology that
enables data preparation data mining
data management and data visualization
it allows you to analyze data with
queries and create reports and
dashboards with the help of charts and
graphs to be used by business leaders
business analytics and business
intelligence together create
capabilities for companies to compete in
the market effectively
consider this example
suppose you sell homemade chocolates
through an online store business
intelligence provides meaningful
insights into the past and current state
of your business bi tells you that sales
of your milk chocolate have spiked up in
texas the past two weeks so you decide
to manufacture more milk chocolates to
keep up with demand business analytics
asks why did sales of milk chocolate
spike up in texas by scrutinizing your
website data you learned that most
traffic has come from a post by a food
blogger based in texas who like to make
chocolate
this insight helps you decide to send
complimentary chocolates to a few other
well-known food bloggers throughout the
united states
using cutting-edge business analytics
and intelligence tools such as microsoft
excel sql power bi and tableau can
enhance customer experience improve
efficiency conduct competitor analysis
and accelerate growth with this basic
knowledge of business analytics and
business intelligence let's look at the
topics we'll be covering in this video
we will start with learning the need for
business analytics and the
responsibilities of a business analyst
then we will look at the top business
analytics skills and learn about
business analytics and intelligence with
microsoft excel
after that we will see the basics of
business intelligence and get an idea
about agilent's chrome methodologies
next we will learn to create reports and
dashboards in microsoft excel and
understand in detail how to visualize
data with top business intelligence
tools such as power bi and tableau let's
get started we will understand the
importance of business analyst with a
sort and interesting story so meet rob
he runs a cafe in a small town far away
his cafe is one of the oldest and most
popular eateries in town rob's cafe was
hugely popular amongst customers and it
was doing very well until the onset of
the deadly coronavirus
due to kovite 19 like other eateries rob
was forced to shut down his cafe too
this took a heavy toll on his business
and subsequently he lost his customers
none of his customers visited his cafe
and this resulted in a huge loss for him
he knew he couldn't afford to close his
business forever as it would take time
for coronavirus to be eradicated
but he was lost this situation was new
to him and he didn't know how to reopen
his business amidst this pandemic after
a lot of brainstorming he recollected
reading about business analysts
he remembered that business analysts are
professionals who enable a change in an
organization he felt like a business
analyst could help him sort out his
current business problems hence without
wasting any time he set out to hire a
business analyst
he hired ted the business analyst to
help him with his ongoing business
problems
rob entrusted ted with reopening the
business
the first step ted took was to have a
discussion with rob and understand the
business problems and the objectives
that is ideally the first step a
business analyst would take
on discussion with rob ted learned that
the business objective was to reopen the
business and get at least 80 percent of
the customer base back in addition to
that rob also wanted ted to look for
sustainable ways to reopen and continue
the business in the long run amidst the
pandemic
ted studied the case and he came up with
a few suggestions that he thought was
fit for rob's business
his first suggestion was to develop an
exclusive home delivery app for rob's
cafe
this way ted knew that business will
improve as customers prefer home
delivery in the current scenario
next ted suggested that rob has work
from home meal boxes added to his menu
many professionals are working from home
currently and having work from home meal
boxes would be a good pick for such
professionals in the middle of a busy
day
ted's third suggestion was to bring down
the selling cost by providing discount
coupons that can be utilized by
customers
having a discount will enable more
customers to order from rob's cafe of
course it was not possible to get the
customer base back without any short of
price cuts in the current situation
finally ted suggested the drop staff
would facilitate home delivery orders
this way he didn't have to lay off his
staff and at the same time
get the home delivery running so these
were a few suggestions given by ted yes
depending on the situation business
analysts can take up different
approaches
so after the suggestions were accepted
by rob for the app ted began to make
sure that the development went well by
collaborating with the i.t team
that became the intermediary between the
iot team and rob he provided suggestions
to the team checked the app through user
interface testing and made sure that the
requirements met well the same applied
to the other business requirements and
changes as well ted held regular
meetings to gaze the progress and also
kept rob in the loop and updated him
with the status of the project
attending regular catch-ups helped rob
gain an insight into the progress and
gave his feedback from time to time
ted made sure that the entire case was
well documented by doing so he could
always refer to the documents in the
future with similar cases as well
ted
made presentations that showed rob the
business growth after implementing the
changes and ted always supported his
presentations with data
rob was very impressed with ted's
business approach
such an approach not only helped rob
reopen his business amidst the cove at
19 but also helped him get 80 percent of
his customer base back ted successfully
brought about a positive change in rob's
business which was highly beneficial
so that is how ted the business analyst
helped rob make a business sustainable
this was the importance of having a
business analyst in rob's organization
don't you think every organization
should have a business analyst
well yes depending on the business
domain and the situation the roles and
responsibilities may vary let's start
off and have a look at a day in the life
of a business analyst through a small
story so meet angela who is working as a
business analyst in an application
development firm
her firm builds applications for clients
depending on their requirements our next
character is rob he is a budding
entrepreneur with a vision of setting up
his own e-commerce app he plans on
selling several electronic gadgets like
phones laptops cameras etc on his app
so what is rob's first step well he
approaches angela's firm one day with
the vision of creating his e-commerce
app angela and rob start talking
business and angela promises to help rob
with his app creation she assures him
that she will look into his business
requirements and coordinate with him to
get the app running rob is happy about
it and increased to cooperate with
angela regarding all the business
requirements from his end angela as we
know is the business analyst she starts
planning rob's project and without any
delay she embarks on this project's
journey
she has a set of planned steps that will
help her fulfill rob's requirements
but what are the steps she takes is her
approach going to be effective and quick
let's find out the answers to these
questions now up next you can learn
about angela's approach that helps her
deliver robs projects smoothly and
without any hassles
these steps that we are going to look at
are the typical roles and
responsibilities of a business analyst
here we will understand these rules
better with respect to angela's and drop
story first and foremost angela
understands rob's business objectives
problems and requirements
without understanding this do you think
angela will be able to proceed no hence
a business analyst like angela
understands the problems related to
rob's business and comes up with the
right solution to achieve the goals of
the business she brainstorms around what
is best suited for an e-commerce app
focusing on electronic gadgets in the
next step angela gathers all the
necessary requirements
here she understands rob's requirements
and makes sure that they are on the same
page regarding the project and its goals
both of them together arrive at a
stipulator deadline for the project
completion
she gathers relevant information based
on security of the app the payment setup
ways to login cost of the products and
style to name a few
once angela has an in-depth
understanding of rob's project and
gathers all the necessary requirements
she starts allocating resources by
keeping in mind the budget of the
project
here she recognizes and allocates tasks
and resources to the development team
bas work closely with the development
team to design the solution for a
problem
angela ensures that the development team
doesn't spend their time understanding
rob's requirements
in this step along with the development
team she finalizes the software and
tools required to build the project
angela doesn't rest until the project is
delivered to rob she continuously
monitors the progress and constantly
provides her feedback to the development
team with respect to the app's layout
design and other features she gives them
suggestions in order to improve the
application
in the next step angela collects
feedback of the prototype version of the
app from the users
she notes down if the prototype is fine
or if it requires more work pas validate
if the project is running fine with the
help of use acceptance testing they
verify if the solution being worked on
is in line with the requirements and
ensure that the final product satisfies
the user expectations
bas also assess the functional and
non-functional requirements after
collecting feedback angela moves to one
of her most crucial duties and that is
building reports data visualization is a
key skill for any ba
in order to gauge the performance of the
app and get valuable insights from it
angela builds reports using various data
visualization tools like tableau power
bi and quick view reports can be general
reports such as detailed reports or it
can be dashboard reports such as
visualized reports with
multi-dimensional analysis based on
display of business indicators it is not
uncommon for issues to crop up amidst
this entire process
hence angela conducts regular meetings
with the development team and rob to
solve problems quickly
having these meetings will help rob
understand the status of the project and
it will also help the teams proceed in
the right path throughout this project
phase angela makes sure to maintain
transparency on completion of the
project angela documents and presents
the project findings to rob
generally business analysts present the
project outcomes to the stakeholders and
clients along with maintenance reports
angela notes on all the project
learnings and details in a concise
manner this will help her take better
decisions in the future and these
documents will save her time while
implementing the next project
now that she has completed all her
duties and responsibilities with respect
to rob's project she is ready to deliver
the final e-commerce application to rob
for use rob is rest assured that the
application developed by angela's firm
is apt for his business and just what he
wanted
angela's streamlined approach made it
easier for the project to be delivered
within the stipulated time period rob is
happy and i'm sure he will come back to
angela's firm for projects in the future
so those responsibilities that we saw
angela carry out are ideally the roles
and responsibilities for any business
analyst out there
yes some may vary depending on the
company you work for and the project
you're working on if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
skill up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
business analyst is a professional who
is responsible for bridging the gap
between i.t and business teams
they use analytics to evaluate processes
determine requirements deliver
data-driven solutions and generate
reports to executives and stakeholders
business analyst is an individual who is
a part of the business operation and
works closely with the technology team
to improve the quality of the services
being delivered they also help in
assisting in integration and testing of
new solutions
growing a career in a field with high
demand such as business analysis could
be a challenge and competition for
business analyst positions can be
intense
so you should have a clear understanding
of the roles and responsibilities of a
business analyst
a ba should successfully identify and
recognize the organization's business
objective they should understand the
business problems and think of a
lucrative business solution
they need to understand and collect the
business requirements from clients and
stakeholders allocate the right
resources and improve the existing
business
documentation of business findings is
another important key role of a business
analyst
bas interact with the development team
to design the solution for solving a
particular problem
they often need to spend a certain
amount of time in meetings in order to
save the development team from spending
their time and understanding the
stakeholders requirement
they often give feedback on the layout
of a software application as to what all
features need to be added and what
functionalities should the application
contain and also implement the newly
designed features that a business needs
while bas identify the needs define the
features right use cases uncover
business rules and manage issues they
should also gauge the functional and
non-functional requirements in a
business
business analysts run meeting with
stakeholders and other authorities hence
discussing issues with the client
face-to-face can do wonders and even
help in solving problems quickly they
engage with business leaders and users
to understand how data driven changes to
products services software and hardware
can improve efficiency and add value
they verify and validate if the project
is running well with the help of user
acceptance testing and the solutions are
in line with the client's requirements
they also ensure that the product
delivered satisfies the user
requirements
finally ba's write documentations and
build visualizations to explain all the
findings and draw business insights
they also deliver maintenance reports
they need to develop informative
coherent and usable documents for the
success of a project
business analyst skills are a
combination of technical as well as
non-technical skills often referred to
as soft skills
the skills for a business analyst are
not only acquired through training but
through experience and combined with the
ability to understand situations and the
motive behind the problem so let's have
a look at the top skills to become a
successful business analyst
the first skill we have is understanding
the business objective
for a business analyst it is important
to know the goals and objectives of the
business it is advised that business
analysts should have a good knowledge of
the business operations in his or her
organization
a business analyst should understand the
problems related to the business and
come up with the right solution business
analysts will resolve the problems that
have been identified and not avoid them
they work on individual actions and
tasks that will build towards the
achievement of the goals of the business
objectives of the business can be to
expand customer base in order to
increase sales scale up production so
that it is in line with the revenue
growth improve revenue streams through
increasing perceived product value or
increasing marketing budget according to
the revenue
business analysts should have the
natural curiosity and determination to
continue learning and figuring out how
things fit together
even as business analysts become
managers it is important to stay in
touch with the industry and its changes
the next important skill a business
analyst should have is analytical and
critical thinking
now there is a famous quote by thomas
elva edition which says
five percent of the people think
ten percent of the people think they
think and the other 85 percent would
rather die than think
business analysts are paid to think
a business analyst would be able to
analyze and interpret the clients
requirements clearly
business analysts required good focus in
order to collect and understand the
needs of the client
critical thinking involves evaluating
several options before arriving at the
desired solution
in certain situations a stakeholder may
give a requirement that's not
necessarily tied up to any business
value but rather to their own increased
convenience applying critical thinking
demands not taking all the statements of
the stakeholders for granted critical
thinking allows the business analyst to
distinguish between requirements that
add value to the business and those
that should be given a low priority a
business analyst must be creative in
order to reach stated goals where
resources are limited and the conditions
are non-ideal
the third important skill for a business
analyst is communication and
interpersonal skills
understanding and being properly
understood is key to any profession
if you are unable to clearly specify and
communicate requirements to any
stakeholder then you may not fully
understand the requirements yourself
being a business analyst is like being
multilingual you have to speak several
different languages while conveying the
same message
business analysts apply communication
skills at every point they use
communication and interpersonal skills
when the project is launched while
gathering requirements when
collaborating with stakeholders and also
while validating the final solution
listening reading and writing skills are
very critical for a business analyst
this would be capable of facilitating
meetings
business analysts use verbal and written
communication to convey ideas concepts
facts and opinions to a variety of
stakeholders
non-verbal communication skills enable
the effective sending and receiving of
messages but not limited to body
movement
posture facial expressions gestures and
eye contact
effective listening allows the business
analyst to accurately understand
information that has been communicated
verbally
fourth in our list of skills we have
negotiation and cost benefit analysis
being a successful business analyst
requires working with and interacting
with many people
these people include clients business
leaders project team members project
stakeholders vendors private sector
representatives industry leaders and so
forth
business analysts negotiate at every
turn during the course of a project
at the initial stage of a project
negotiation skills are used to determine
what should be included in the vision of
the project
as details emerge negotiation skills are
used by all parties involved to
determine which requests become
requirements and which requirements have
higher priority
as the project progresses negotiation
skills help to determine the functional
design which fulfill the requirements
technical decisions also require
negotiation skills
business analysts also perform cost
benefit analysis to conduct an
assessment of the benefits and costs
anticipated in a project when
organizations undertake new projects it
is advisable for business analysts that
they use cost benefit analysis to
establish whether such projects should
be embarked or not
business analysts should be able to
achieve a profitable outcome for your
company while finding a solution for the
client that makes them happy
this balancing act demands the ability
to influence a mutual solution and
maintain professional relationship
up next we have our fifth skill that is
decision making
the quality of decisions made by
business analyst is what matters a lot
because it has a direct impact on the
company's business
thus it is important for every business
analyst to think from all aspects before
presenting the decision or strategy
they must be having good problem solving
skills as well
business analysts should have a knack to
think out of the box and find a solution
to problems
majorly a business analyst follows five
major steps while making a decision
these steps are define the problem
find and define the alternative
approaches
evaluate the alternative approaches
make the decision based on these
approaches and test
and finally implement the solution
while some may argue that the technical
team is responsible for designing the
solution the business analyst still
remains instrumental in ensuring that
the design conforms to the requirements
that have been approved
now that we have reached half way
through the skills i would like to ask
all our viewers to please subscribe to
our channel and hit the bell icon to
never miss an update from simply learn
moving on
we have another really important
business analyst skill that is
idea about programming languages
business analysts would have a good
hands-on programming knowledge for
performing better and faster analysis of
data
knowledge of r and python is highly
beneficial
business analysts can help solve complex
problems by writing efficient codes
both r and python have a vast collection
of libraries and packages for data
manipulation data wrangling data
visualization and data analytics
some of these libraries are numpy pandas
deep flyer tidier gg plot and matplotlib
in addition to these it is good to
understand statistical software like sas
and spss
using these programming languages such
as python r and sas you can analyze and
visualize large data sets as well as
create machine learning models for
making future business predictions
the seventh skill in our list is
creation of reports and dashboards
a business analyst should be proficient
in using various business intelligence
tools for creating reports and
dashboards
reports created by business analysts can
be general reports such as detail report
grouped report cross tab report column
report query report data entry report
etc or it can be dashboard reports such
as visualized report with
multi-dimensional analysis based on
display of business indicators
dashboard reports are developed by
business analyst to solve business
decision making problems different from
the tabular interface of the general
report the dashboard report adopts the
canvas like operation interface
knowledge of tableau power bi and click
view are required to make different
types of reports depending on the
business requirements
now the eighth skill in our list of
skills is database and sql
business analysts often work with data
that is structured in nature hence to
store and process this data they should
have knowledge of relational databases
such as microsoft sql server oracle
database mysql database as well as nosql
databases
also having hands-on experience with sql
is a must for a business analyst to
access retrieve manipulate and analyze
data so they should be able to write
data definition and data manipulation
commands such as create update delete
and insert
microsoft excel is the ninth skill in
our list
excel is one of the oldest and most
popular and powerful analytics and
reporting tool used in the industries
for working with data
business analysts use excel to perform
various calculations budget analysis and
data analysis to derive meaningful
insights and take decisions
they sort filter and create pivot tables
to summarize the data
business analysts can also create
different charts and graphs using excel
to generate dynamic reports related to a
business problem
business analysts can use excel to
create revenue growth models for new
products based on new customer forecasts
when planning an editorial calendar for
a website business analysts can list out
dates and topics in a spreadsheet
when creating a budget for a small
product they can list expense categories
in a spreadsheet update it monthly and
create a chart to show how close the
product is to budget across each
category
business analyst can calculate customer
discounts based on monthly purchase
volume by product
they can even summarize customer revenue
by product to find areas where to build
strong customer relationships
and finally in the list of skills we
have documentation and presentation
you could have all the industry
experience in the world but if it's
paired with poor business analyst
practices you could be more of a risk to
the organization than a business analyst
with no industry experience at all
a business analyst must be able to
document their project learnings and
results in a concise and compact form
they should also be confident about
presenting the findings and conclusions
in front of the stakeholders and clients
organized documentation will help you
communicate technical concepts to
non-technical employees
it is important that a business analyst
notes down all the details that they
learn from their projects
this will help them take better
decisions in the future also if similar
problems arise at a later stage they can
implement the same solution thereby
saving a lot of time and unwanted
problems
while business analysts are generally
not responsible for making decisions
regarding project solutions
decision making skills are still
important for understanding gathering
and presenting relevant information to
assess decision makers with selecting
the optimal solution
with that we have covered our top skills
for a business analyst
if you have any questions related to the
skills that we covered then please put
it in the chat section our team will
help you solve your queries
now
let me tell you how simply learn can
help you grow your career in business
analytics and help you become a business
analyst
so let me search for simply learn here
this is the simply learn website
and
on the search bar let me look for
business
analyst
you can see
there are a few courses related to
business analyst so let me open these
two courses
so let's go to the first course
so this is the business analyst masters
program
now
this program is endorsed education
provider is iiba
now if you look on the right we have the
different courses that will be covered
as part of this master's program
so there is introduction to business
analysis
certified business analytics
professional you'll also learn about
agile and scrum
there's business analytics with excel
we'll also get training in sql plus
tableau training
and you'll also get to work on business
analyst caption projects
if i scroll down now here are the tools
that will be covered as part of this
course so there's microsoft excel zera
tableau power bi
postgresql
then this plan box target process
and others
here you can see the
program advisors
and if i scroll further
is the entire course content we have
these are the different courses
that you will be learning in this course
and
after you finish the course you will
receive a certificate which will look
similar to this
so please go ahead and enroll to this
course if you want to start your career
in business analytics now let me take
you to another program
we have post graduate program in
business analysis
now this is in
partnership with purdue university and
endorsed education provider is iipa
if i scroll down you can see here the
key features of this course
you'll get
purdue postgraduate program
certification alumni association
membership
master classes from purdue faculties
enrollment in simply learns job assist
there's 170 plus hours of blended
learning 11 plus hands-on projects
custom projects in three domains
if i scroll further
on the right you can see this is the
purdue certification that you will
receive after finishing the course
and you will also get
the certificate received by
international institute of business
analysis that is iiba
let's scroll down
you also have the advantage for
enrolling to simply learn job assist
program so you will get im jobs pro
membership for 6 months resume
assistance and career monitoring will
also have interview preparation and
career affairs
now here you can see the program details
so
you will learn about an introduction to
business analysis certified business
analysis professional
there's island scrum
business analytics with excel tablet
training business analyst capstone
project
and you also have the opportunity to
enroll for some electives so we have
purdue university business analysis
master class
you can also enroll to a power bi course
and there is agilent scrum foundation
if i scroll down
here you can see the skills that will be
covered as part of this program so
this business analysis
there's alicitation and collaboration
requirement analysis planning and
monitoring
let me click on view more you have
strategy analysis dashboarding
wireframing does data visualization
statistical analysis using excel sql
database
there's requirement lifecycle management
and lots more
so these are the tools that will be
covered in this course we have microsoft
excel zera
fog bus
plan box that's rally power bi pro sql
sql
that's version one target process and
others
and now this is the important part
though these are the industrially
related projects that you will get to
work on once you enroll to this course
so the first project is canteen ordering
system for unilever
we also have library management system
for stanford university
there's whatsapp pay and you can see the
description of these projects
mentioned below
and
you also have
hospital management system for myoclinic
there are our course advisors for this
course now they are directly related to
purdue university
scroll further this is the learner's
profile and how the industry trend has
been for business analysts
so please go ahead and enroll to this
program if you
really want to start your career or you
want to grow your career as a business
analyst
now here is a quick roadmap that depicts
what a fresher needs to possess to
become a business analyst
first they need to have a graduation
degree in a related field
then
knowledge of sql and relational database
is very important
thirdly a fresher should have good
hands-on experience with programming
languages and that's a prerequisite
and finally they need to have good
communication skills to nail the role of
a business analyst
up next we have the roadmap that depicts
what an experienced professional needs
to possess to become a business analyst
firstly they should have good knowledge
of the domain they are currently working
in
next they should know how to write sql
queries
an experienced professional should be
good with programming languages
in addition to that they need to have
good communication and negotiation
skills
finally they should be good at creating
interactive reports using business
intelligence tools
in addition to that having a
certification offered by international
institute of business analysis such as
certified business analysis professional
would be highly beneficial
let's now learn the business analysis
knowledge areas
first up we have business analysis
planning and monitoring
now this knowledge area describes the
tasks used to organize and coordinate
business analysis efforts
it involves planning business analysis
approach stakeholder engagement business
analysis governance as well as
information management
then we have illustration and
collaboration
now this knowledge area describes the
tasks used to prepare and conduct
elicitation activities and confirm the
results
it also includes communicating business
analysis information and stakeholder
engagement
the third knowledge area we have is
requirements lifecycle management
so this knowledge area describes the
tasks that we perform in order to manage
and maintain requirements throughout
their lifecycle
it covers the creation changes
privatization traceability and
governance processes
fourth in our list we have strategy
analysis
now this knowledge area describes the
tasks used to identify the business need
address that need and align the change
strategy within the enterprise
you need to analyze the current state
define the future state assess risks and
define change strategy
then we have requirements analysis and
design definition this knowledge area
describes the tasks used to organize
requirements specify and model
requirements it also validates and
verifies information and identifies
solution options the final knowledge
area we have is solution evaluation this
knowledge area measures the solution
performance analyzes performance
measures
assess solution limitations and
recommends actions to increase solution
value now let's discuss two of the most
widely used methodologies in any
business analysis process
these methods are popularly used in the
industries to ensure smooth running of
projects
the first methodology we are going to
talk about is the agile methodology
agile is an incremental and iterative
approach to project management and
software development it helps team
deliver value to their customers faster
and with fewer obstacles teams can
manage a project by breaking it up into
several stages and involving constant
collaboration with stakeholders along
with continuous improvement and
iteration at every stage
so the steps involved in an agile
project development includes
planning the project in terms of
business goals budget time duration for
completing the project and resource
needed
then we have designing the solution for
the problem at hand
the third step is developing the
solution this could be a software a
website an application etc
it's done by the development team
next we have testing the product in the
next step of the life cycle
deploying the developed product to check
if it's working fine and finally we have
reviewing the product and getting
feedback from customers clients
stakeholders etc now in agile
methodology the entire work is broken
down into several sprints
after each sprint
we get a shippable product and that
product is reviewed by the client or the
stakeholder
the suggestions are incorporated in the
next sprint
here you can see we have sprint 1 sprint
2 and sprint 3 and all of them have the
6 steps that we discussed in the agile
methodology process
now let's discuss this scrum methodology
scrum is a subset of the agile framework
it is one of the most widely used
lightweight process frameworks for agile
development you can easily collaborate
develop and deliver complex products of
the highest possible value
scrum empowers the development team and
supports working in small teams like 8
to 10 members
scrum significantly increases
productivity and reduces time
this process enables organizations to
adjust smoothly to rapidly changing
requirements and produce a product that
meets evolving business goals
okay so the concepts and practices in
scrum can be divided into three
categories
first we have three roles
a product owner owns the product backlog
and writes user stories and acceptance
criteria
they are responsible for privatizing the
product backlog and deciding the release
date and the content a product owner is
the one who is responsible for the
return on investment or roi of the
product a scrum master is a servant who
encourages and demands self-organization
from the development team they enable
close cooperation across all roles and
functions addresses resource issues and
disobedience of scrum practices a
development team comprises individuals
working together to develop and deliver
the requested and committed product
agreements the development team builds
the product and includes all the
expertise necessary to deliver the
potential shippable product each sprint
the second category comprises of three
artifacts the product backlog is an
ordered list of the features and
requirements needed to complete the
project the list can include bugs or
defects that need to be resolved
features that must be added another
technical or project work your team has
to complete before the project is over
the sprint backlog includes only what
needs to be completed during the current
sprint
it often has greater detail and more
complete user stories than the rest of
the product backlog
once created no one can add to the
sprint backlog except the development
team the product increment is the
version of the product that will be
delivered at the end of each sprint
while the sprint backlog outlines what
must be completed within a sprint the
product increment details the outcome of
all that work
the increment is a prototype or working
version of the final product expected by
the customer
the final category we have is sprint
ceremonies
there are four ceremonies in total
in sprint planning the team meets and
decides what they need to complete in
the coming sprint
sprint review is a type of meeting in
which the team demonstrates what they
shipped in the sprint
in the sprint retrospective the team
reviews their work identifying what they
did well and what didn't go as planned
so that they can make the next print
better
daily scrum is a stand-up meeting or a
very short like 15 to 20 minutes meeting
for the team to make sure that they are
all on the same page
now
let's talk about the average annual
salary of a business analyst
according to pay scale the average
annual salary of a business analyst in
the united states is 68
973
while in india a business analyst can
earn nearly 6 lakh rupees per annum now
talking about the companies hiring for
business analysts we have the indian
e-commerce payment system and financial
technology company paytm
american mnc cognigent and british dutch
multinational oil and gas company shell
we also have cisco the search engine
giant google and dell
finally in our list of companies we have
einstein young global limited american
multinational computer technology
cooperation oracle and british
multinational investment bank and
financial services company barclays
with that let's discuss the top business
analysis tools and software used by
business analysts
we have the widely used spreadsheet
application microsoft excel web-based
kanban style list making application
trello relational database management
systems such as mysql microsoft sql
server and postgresql
then we have bug tracking and agile
project management product zera and
tableau software for data visualization
okay so let's look at a demo on business
analyst training often times business
analysts work on structured data using
excel to prepare reports and dashboards
they do create pivot tables and pivot
charts to summarize and analyze data
find trends and insights to make
critical
decisions so in this demo we will work
on a sales data set from the united
states and analyze the total revenue
total profit the quantity sold for
different categories and subcategories
of products across various regions
segments cities etc now let me show you
the data set first
okay so here is my data set you can see
there are
nearly
9994 rows and we have
17 columns
you can see this is a sales data set and
the first column is of order date then
we have the shipment date we have the
shipment mode next we have the customer
name
that is the customer who purchased the
product we have the segment the country
name this is only united states then we
have the different cities from the u.s
we have the state names
and if i go to the right you can see the
categories of product
we also have the sub categories
next we have the product name
then we have our sales value
now you can assume this to be in dollars
then we have the quantity that was sold
for each product
then we have the discount column and
finally we have the profit column
so let's analyze this data set using
different charts and graphs
first let's create a pivot table to see
the sales by region and year so here we
want to see the sales of all the years
in different regions of the united
states
so for that
i'll click on any cell inside this data
set
go to the insert tab
and here i have the option to create a
pivot table
i'll click on this create pivot table
option
and you can see it has selected my
entire data
and here i'll choose new worksheet that
is the place where i want to place this
pivot table
and let's click on ok
so you can see it has created a new
sheet which is sheet2
and
let's drag our columns
onto the different sections in this
pivot table fields so since i want to
know
the region
and the year so let's drag the order
date first
and
let's
delete the quarter column so i'll click
on remove field
i don't want this field so i have my
ears first
and then
let's drag
region column
under columns
and
we want to know the sales for
all the years in different regions so
i'll drag
sales onto values
you can see here we have our pivot table
ready if you want you can go ahead and
rename this row labels and column labels
now
with this table ready let's create a
line chart
this will
help you analyze your data better
so what you can do is
go to the insert tab and here
under recommended charts
you can go for line chart you can see
the line chart preview here
and click on ok
there you go
how easily excel has created a pivot
chart for us based on
this pivot table
now if you notice the lines in this
graph you can see the different regions
and here is the legend
now
if you see the yellow line which is
actually for the west region
so the sales had declined from 2014
to 2015
and then it gradually started increasing
from 2015 to 2017 onwards
and if you see the orange line or the
red line it is for the east region the
sales have been continuously increasing
you can see the trend here
similarly
if you see the central region
the sales generated was steady from 2014
till 2015
then it increased in 2016 and after 2016
it became constant
similarly you can analyze the south
region as well
now let's say you want to know the sales
by each category of product and the
different segments so you can do that as
well
let's go to our sheet one where we have
our data set
let me click on any cell i'll go to
insert
and i'll choose pivot table
here
let it be new worksheet i'll click on ok
all right so since we want to know the
sales value again so let's drag sales
onto
values field
and now
i'll
choose category
under rows so
let's select category under rows
and then
we want to know
for each segment also
so what i can do is
i'll choose segment under columns
you can see i have my pivot table ready
so here you have
the furniture office supplies and
technology as the categories of products
and on the top you can see consumer
corporate home office as the different
segments
now let's create a
visual out of this pivot table so i'll
go to recommended charts
and
let's say this time i want to
create a bar chart now this is a
horizontal bar chart
let's click on ok
if i close this
and i bring it to here you can see this
is a nice bar chart
and below you can see the sales values
and on the y-axis you can see the
different categories of products and in
the legend we have the segments now if
you want you can edit this chart as well
so let's delete
or hide all field buttons on the chart
all right
similarly let's do this for
our line chart as well let's hide these
field buttons
okay
all right
now
let's suppose you want to know which
segment made the highest and the lowest
profits
so for that you can create a pivot table
as well
so i'll click on any cell
go to the insert tab
and choose pivot table i click on ok
all right now say
we want to know the profit by each
segment
so i'll first choose profit on to values
and
let's drag
the segment column
onto rows
so we have our pivot table ready
now here if you want to know which
segment made the highest or the lowest
profit you can sort this data so click
on any cell under sum of profit
right click and here you have the short
option
so let's do
sort smallest to largest which is in
ascending order
okay so here you can see consumer
segment made the highest amount of
profit while the home office segment
made the lowest amount of profit now
based on this pivot table you can create
a pie chart
let's do that
i'll go to insert
and here under recommended charts
i'll select pi
and let's click on ok
there you go
we have a nice pie chart ready
now the gray color pi represents your
consumer segment which made the highest
amount of profit you can also validate
it from the pivot table
while the blue segment which is actually
home office made the lowest amount of
profit
now let's remove this field from here
i'll right click and select
hide all field buttons on the chart now
one thing you can do is
you can edit the
chart title
here by default it has shown total we
can rename it to let's say
profit
by
segment and hit enter
okay
now you can adjust the size of this and
the color of the text if you want you
can do it from here
similarly
let's
add a title to our bar graph as well
so here if you see
there's an option to choose chart title
and
i'll say sales
by
segment
and
category
okay
similarly let's add a title to
our first line chart that we created
i'll click on the chart title
and here i'll
write sales by
year
and
region
okay
now let me go back to my
data sheet
now suppose let's say you want to know
the total units that were sold for each
sub category of products and the
shipment mode
so here we have the shipment mode
and you want to know the total units
that were sold which is basically
this column the quantity column
for each sub-categories of product you
can see we have different sub-categories
like bookcases this chairs labels the
stables furnishings art phones binders
etc
so let's create a pivot table for this
i'll go to the insert tab
click on pivot table
and click on ok
all right
now
since we want to know the total units
that were sold let's drag
the quantity column under values
and
i'll choose the ship mode field under
columns
and let's select
subcategory
under rows
so i have my pivot table ready
now based on this pivot table let's
create a line chart i'll go to the
insert tab
click on recommended charts
and let's go to line chart
all right
you can see the preview here and the
legends which show the
shipment mode let's click on ok
i close this
now
first let's remove these fields i'll
right click and i'll hide all field
buttons
now if you see this one
you can
add some styles to your chart
let's modify our chart a bit
let's see i'll select
yeah this one
you can see
it has given dots for each endpoints
which means
this is my first sub category as you can
see the second subcategory of the third
subcategory which is art
then we have binders
so it's really easy to read
and understand the chart well
okay
now
let's add a chart title
i'll write
quantity
sold
by
subcategory
and
ship mode
now you can reduce the size of the chart
title text let's keep it
10
okay
now you
also have the
feature to create
different kinds of maps in excel
so suppose
you want to see the states that made the
highest and the lowest sales in the
united states so you can create a field
map for that
so first of all let's go to our data
sheet
i'll click on any cell go to insert and
create a pivot table
and click on ok
alright
so since we want the
state and the country so let me first
drag country field under rows
and then i'll choose the state field
under rows
now let's
drag sales under values
okay
so we have our
pivot table ready now if i sort this
data you can easily know
that california state made the highest
amount of sales
now if i scroll down
below you can see
north dakota made the lowest amount of
sales
now
let's do one thing let's remove the
grand total so you can go to the design
tab
and
under grand totals you can select the
first option you can see the grand total
has gone
and in order to create a map we need to
adjust this pivot table so i'll click on
united states
i'll right click and
i'll go to field settings
here under
layout and print
i'll click on
show item labels in tabular format
and i'll also click on
repeat item labels you can see
it will populate united states for all
the rows if i click on ok you can see
the united states have been populated
for all the states
now let me
select this table
or before that let's remove the
subtotal from here
i'll close this
go to the design tab
under subtotals
i'll choose do not show subtotals okay
now let's
select the table
and
i'll actually paste it somewhere here
now with this data
i can go to the insert tab
and choose maps
let's select field map
there you go
you see
we have a nice field map of the united
states
and here you can see the color scale
so it goes from light gray all the way
up to dark blue so the states that are
in dark blue
let's say california made the highest
amount of sales you can also validate it
from the pivot table
similarly the lighter the color
the amount of sales were less for that
state
now let's give a chart title here
i'll
give a chart title
as
sales by
states
and let's remove this legend
now you can format this map so here you
can change colors and
let's see if i choose this one you can
see the color has changed
and you can see the california state
is shaded in dark which means it made
the highest amount of sales
you can also
add data labels you can see it will show
the
sales values for each of the states
and if you want you can keep the legend
as well i'll just remove these two
all right
now
similarly you can also create a field
map
to see the profits by each state so you
can analyze which states made the
highest amount of profit and the state
that made the lowest amount of profit so
let's do that
i'll go to my data sheet
i'll
click on insert and select pivot table
let's click on ok
now first and foremost let's drag
country under rows
and then i'll choose state under rows
next
let's drag
the profit column under values
so i have my
pivot table ready
let's go to the design tab and remove
the subtotals
i'll select do not show subtotals if i
scroll down
okay i have my grand total now so let's
go to the design tab under grand totals
we'll remove it okay
now let's just populate the united
states which is the country name for all
the rows
i'll right click on united states go to
field settings
click on layout and print
i'll choose select item labels in
tabular form and select repeat item
labels
let's click on ok
so i have my
country name populated throughout
let's
select the pivot table
i'll paste it somewhere here
and now let's go to the insert tab
i'll choose map let's select field map
there you go
now we have the profits
for each of the states
let's first delete this
and edit our chart title
which is
profit
by
states
okay
close this
let's say
we'll use this one
now okay
let's edit the color of the chart title
i'll make it as white
and let's say
we'll
choose the color
as
say this one okay
now let me go ahead and remove the
legend here
and just delete it all right
so we have our
field map ready which shows profit by
each state
now that we are done with our analysis
and creating our
different pivot tables and pivot charts
let's build the final dashboard
so let's create a new sheet here
okay
the first thing i need to do is i'll go
to the view tab and i'll remove the grid
lines
all right now let's go to the insert tab
and here we have
text
let me choose text box
let's create a text box here
okay
now you can reduce the size actually
let's reduce it
okay
and you can move it to the top
all right
let's pull this a little down
and this tool till right
let's fill the text box color with blue
color
and
let's
give the text as
sales
dashboard
and we'll
give a white color to the text
and i'll select my font
you can select any font you want
so i'll go with
let's say
britannic bold okay we have it here
and let's increase the size to
30
and we'll center align it all right
now
the next step is to
bring all our pivot charts
to this dashboard sheet
so i'll first copy my
pivot chart
and i'll paste it in sheet let's paste
it here
and we can reduce the size
okay
now similarly let's do it for the
other charts as well i'll copy this
and let's paste it somewhere here
okay
now let me just reduce the
size
and if you want you can reduce the
chart title font size as well let's make
it 11
okay
and let's
drag this a bit
all right
now let's
copy the
pie chart
and let me paste it here
let's reduce the size of this pie chart
okay
see we have our pie chart here
now
let me
take my line chart which shows the
quantity sold by
different subcategories of product i'll
copy it
and let me paste it
somewhere here
i'll close this
and we need to reduce the size so that
we can fit in our other charts as well
okay let me reduce a bit more
all right
now we are left with the two
maps that we created let's copy this and
let's paste it
here
i'll go to the right
let's reduce the size
similarly we'll do it for
sales by
profit map as well
let's copy this
and
paste it onto our dashboard
let's reduce the size first
and let's increase it
towards the bottom
so we have our
dashboard ready you can see the
different
pivot charts that we created
now let's add slicers and timelines to
this dashboard so that we can filter our
tables and the charts
so i'll
click on this
first chart which is our line chart i'll
go to the insert tab here you can see
under filters we have slicers and
timeline first let me click on timeline
and here i'll choose my order date
column
let me click on ok
all right
let's drag this a bit here on to the
right
and i'll show you how you can use this
let's
first choose
years instead of months
and let me reduce the size a bit
okay
now another thing to do here is let me
right click
and i'll go to report connections
here i'll select
all my pivot tables instead of just one
so that
any manipulation you do in the order
year it will reflect for all the
tables or the charts we have on the
dashboard i click on ok
now that we have seen how to add a
timeline
i'll reduce this a bit
let's now add a few slicers
let's click on any of the charts
i'll go to insert click on slicer
now let's add
a region slicer i'll click on ok
and let's take it to the right
will reduce the size of this region
slicer slicers are nothing but
filters which have
advanced filtering options
and
we can add
one more
filter
or a slicer let's say
we want to do this time on
the segment
so i'll go to slicer
i'll choose segment here and click on ok
so you can see i have my segment slicer
here
let me just reduce the size
and
let's drag it
here
at the bottom
all right
okay
now if you want to know the sales and
profit
for a particular year so you can choose
that particular year here on the
timeline
suppose i want to know
the sales only for 2014 and 2015
so the way to do is you can select one
of the years so i'll click on 2014
and now i'll drag this
to select 2015 as well
if i
go to left
the figures that you see only reflect
the sales and the profit for 2014 and
15.
similarly
if you mark here
or let me just bring it
to the middle
suppose say i want to
have 2016 year included as well i can
just drag it to the right
you can see the charts will change
i'll just
remove the filter and place it here
similarly if you want to
see the sales and profit for
a particular region
you can do that too
for example let me just bring this
region slicer here
and
let's say you want to know the sales and
profit only for the east region
you see here it shows only for the east
region
and suppose you want to see for east and
west region also
you can see it changes here
okay
we just cancel this
now
you might be wondering when we selected
the different regions only the pie chart
changed
but the rest of the charts were
the same now the reason was we did not
apply this slicer to all the pivot
tables so let me right click
and go to report connections
here i'll choose
the remaining pivot tables as well
i click on ok
all right
now let me just bring this to the middle
and let's say we want to know the
sales and the profits and the quantities
sold for let's say south region
if i select this you can see it shows
only for the south region
let's see you also want to know for the
central region
now we have selected both central and
south you can see the variations in the
graph
let me cancel this
similarly we have another slicer which
is the segment
i'll populate the slicer for
all the other pivot tables
let me choose all of them
and click on ok
i'll bring this
to the middle so that you can see the
variations in the graph let's say i want
to know the seals the unit sold and the
profit for
home office segment so i'll only select
home office
you can see the variations here
now the slicers actually don't work for
the maps so you can't see any change
here
now suppose you want to know for the
corporate segment you can select
corporate or if you want to select for
multiple segments you can do that as
well
just cancel this
and let me place it here
all right now we are done with our demo
so if you want to get a copy of the data
set and the demo file that we are using
here in this video you can put your
email ids in the comment section
our team will send you the files over
email we'll compare the two most popular
job roles in the field of information
technology that is business analyst
versus data analyst
business analyst is a professional who
bridges the gap between the it and the
business teams in an organization they
use data analytics and modern
technologies to assess processes and
deliver data-driven solutions
they understand and solve a business
problem and validate business
requirements
a business analyst generates reports for
executives and stakeholders
they are part of the business operation
and work closely with the technology
team to improve the quality of the
services being delivered they also
assist in the integration and testing of
new solutions
now let's talk about the job description
of a data analyst
with the rapid increase in data
generation today the term data analyst
has found its prominence
a data analyst collects processes and
performs analysis of large data sets
every business generates data in several
formats this data can be in the form of
customer information and feedback log
files transaction data marketing
research and so on it is the duty of a
data analyst to transform these business
data into valuable insights some of the
problems that can be addressed are how
to improve a business how to provide
good customer experience what would be
the ideal price for a new product how to
reduce transportation costs and so on
data analysts deal with data handling
data modeling and reporting with this
brief understanding of the job
description for a business analyst and a
data analyst let's now shift our focus
towards the various responsibilities of
a business analyst
a business analyst identifies the
business goals understands the problems
faced by an organization and comes up
with a cost-effective solution to tackle
the issues
they thoroughly understand the
requirements from the clients and assign
the right resources
bas communicate and work closely with
the development team to design the
solution for a problem they ensure that
the development team doesn't spend their
time understanding the stakeholders
requirements and often give iterative
feedback on the solution being developed
they check and validate if the project
is running fine with the help of user
acceptance testing they also verify if
the solution being worked on is in line
with the requirements and ensure that
the final product satisfies the user
expectations
bas assess the functional and
non-functional requirements
a business analyst documents the project
findings and results they present the
project conclusions to the stakeholders
and clients along with delivering
maintenance reports and building
visualizations to make decisions
now let's take a look at the
responsibilities of a data analyst
first and foremost a data analyst must
identify and understand the
organization's goal and requirements
this helps to plan and streamline the
analysis process
data analysts collect data from various
heterogeneous sources they assess the
available resources comprehend the
business problem and gather the right
data for analysis they work closely with
different team members like programmers
business analysts and data scientists
data filtering and data wrangling are
vital jobs of a data analyst the data
collected is often noisy and it contains
missing values hence it is crucial to
clean the collected data and remove
invalid values to make it ready for
analysis
they use a variety of analytical
statistical and business intelligence
tools to spot trends and patterns in
complex data sets discover hidden
insights and prepare summary reports for
the leadership team
they also use programming languages for
data mining and data manipulation
now it's time for us to understand the
difference between a business analyst
and a data analyst based on the skill
set they possess
first let's look at the skills that can
help you become a being
a business analyst should have a
graduation degree in any relevant field
such as business accounting information
systems human resources or engineering
you can apply for entry level business
analyst positions or with professional
experience
excel is a powerful analytics and
reporting tool for working with data
bas use excel to perform various
calculations data analysis plan and
editorial calendar and calculate
customer discounts to derive meaningful
insights and take decisions
bas use sql to retrieve manipulate and
analyze data stored in relational
databases
critical thinking skills are important
to understand customers business needs
it allows them to distinguish between
requirements that add value to the
business and those that should be given
a lower priority
bas should find different ways to
address each challenge
data visualization is a key skill for
bas to build interactive dashboards and
reports to convey the outcomes of a
project
knowledge of tableau power bi and
qlikview is required to make different
types of reports depending on the
business requirements
business analysts should have a good
hands-on programming experience to solve
complex tasks and perform faster
analysis of data
hence knowledge of programming languages
such as r and python is a prerequisite
finally they should have good
presentation skills they should also be
confident about their findings and
conclusions and communicate it in front
of the stakeholders and clients
let's now understand the skills that a
data analyst should possess
you must have a bachelor's degree in any
relevant field or be a graduate in
statistics economics or science you're
eligible to become a data analyst being
a fresher or as an experienced
professional you should have domain
knowledge in the field you are working
in once again knowledge of excel is
another basic requirement for a data
analyst
data analysts often work with structured
data so they should be proficient in
writing sql queries using data
manipulation and data definition
commands they should know how to create
stored procedures
another crucial skill for a data analyst
is to have hands-on experience with
programming languages such as python r
sas and javascript you can analyze and
visualize large data sets and create
predictive models for making business
decisions
data analysts create data visualizations
using libraries such as matplotlib
c-bond ggplot and plotly
this helps them to perform exploratory
data analysis
knowledge of tableau and power bi is
required to create different business
reports with the help of graphs and
charts
data analysts should have knowledge of
machine learning algorithms to build
sophisticated models and make future
predictions
so they should know about linear
regression logistic regression support
vector machines k-mean clustering and
other supervised and unsupervised
learning algorithms
finally data analysts should also
possess good communication and
presentation skills
now let's discuss a salary structure for
both of these job roles
according to pay scale a business
analyst in the united states earns an
average salary of 69 000
while in india you can earn nearly 6
lakh rupees per annum now talking about
the salary of a data analyst according
to pay scale in the us a data analyst
earns an average salary of sixty
thousand seven hundred and ten dollars
per annum and in india you can earn
around four lakhs twenty four thousand
rupees per annum let's now move on and
look at the different companies hiring
for business analyst roles
here we have oracle the search engine
giant google the american mnc cognizant
and e-commerce company amazon in
addition to that we have ernest and
young technology giant ibm dell and
cisco hiring business analysts
talking about the companies hiring for
data analysts we have twitter google the
social media leader facebook and amazon
we also have the american oil company
shell the electric vehicle company tesla
apple and the american credit reporting
agency equifax
now choosing the right field that is to
become a business analyst or a data
analyst could be a challenging task
the key points that you have to keep in
mind before making a decision is
first review your background and see
what qualifications you have check what
skills you possess and the domain
knowledge you have
then gauge your interest to see what
suits you best
and finally consider your long-term
goals and see the job roles that will
help you grow in your career in the long
run
now let me tell you how simply learn can
help you grow your career as a business
analyst and a data analyst
simply learn offers a post graduate
program in business analysis that is in
collaboration with purdue university the
endorsed education provider is iiba some
of the skills that will be covered in
this course are strategy analysis
wireframing solution evaluation
dashboarding data visualization agile
scrum methodology scrum artifacts
statistical analysis using excel and sql
database
some of the tools covered in this course
are microsoft excel tableau power bi
jira postgresql planbox and others
some of the key features of this
business analysis program are you will
receive purdue post graduate program
certification master classes from purdue
faculty you can enroll in simply learns
job assist where you will get im jobs
pro membership for 6 months and obtain
35 iiba pd cdus and 25 pmi pdus
you will get 170 plus hours of blended
learning along with capstone projects in
three domains
to become a data analyst you can enroll
in the postgraduate program in data
analytics offered by simply learn
this program is in collaboration with
purge university and ibm
the skills that will be covered as a
part of the course are statistical
analysis using excel data analysis in
python and our data visualization using
tableau and power bi linear and logistic
regression modules clustering using
k-means
supervised learning and others
the tools that you will learn are numpy
pandas scipy scikit-learn excel and
others
some of the key features of this course
are you will get purge your postgraduate
program certification industry
recognized ibm certificates enrollment
and simply learns job assist and
masterclasses from purdue faculty
you have 180 plus hours of blended
learning 14 plus hands-on projects on
integrated labs and capstone projects in
three domains
so please go ahead and enroll for these
programs if you want to grow your career
as a business analyst or a data analyst
business analyst interview questions
my name is richard kirschner with the
simply learn team
we'll go over some beginner intermediate
and advanced level questions to expect
in interviews when you're looking at
business
analytics
let's start with the differentiation
between a risk and an issue
and this should be a very fundamental
question uh dealing with business
because in business they want to make
money and we really want to understand
where the split is on a lot of these
things always ask yourself where is the
bottom dollar on this and what does this
mean
risk is your potential and an issue is
something that's actually happening
so risk is a potential problem that can
be predicted risk may or may not happen
in the future a proactive response plan
is formulated and kept ready to mitigate
risks
so these are things you plan for
and the issue refers to a risk that is
occurring or about to happen
there is no response plan in place to
solve an issue you can only respond
reactively to an issue what are the
various tools a business analyst works
on
this is very
company specific
and so when you start looking for work
you start going in for interviews
you should start really asking yourself
what are these companies looking for
that i'm interested in
clearly if you work with ibm you want to
have your tools that are central to ibm
and the ibm setup same thing with google
with you know just across the whole
field
some of the more basic ones
obviously an excel spreadsheet which
isn't on this list but your python your
sql you should really know your sql it's
going to come up in no matter what
format you're in
your tableau your xur your balsamic all
these are different platforms there's a
lot more out there but you should be
aware on which platforms your
proficiencies are on
and those also that you might not be
proficient on but you at least know what
they do and what their performance is so
you can answer questions and
a lot of companies will pay for you to
be certified if their platform isn't on
your list
what are the various stages of a
business project
and we look at project initiation
project planning project execution
project control and monitoring project
closure and it's really important to
understand
any one of these in a little bit more
detail than just knowing the list
what is feasibility study
a feasibility study is a method of
gauging the success rate of proposed
business solution it enables business
analysts to discover new business
opportunities
and uh really a lot of businesses when
they're looking at for a business
analyst this is really what they want to
know what's the feasibility that is a
very central question that comes up
in most business plans what's the
feasibility of doing something and
getting it done
what is business model analysis business
model analysis is a technique that helps
you analyze if a business is financially
economically and socially viable or not
i know a number of contractors that this
is their sole career is to go in and
analyze ski resorts in colorado to find
out whether it's going to make it this
year or not and what they need to do to
fix that
so it's a very high-end
job niche where you really need to know
your stuff and understand what it means
what do you understand by requirement
differentiate between requirements and
needs
we look at requirements requirement is a
targeted solution that is required to
achieve the set business objectives
business requirements are data used for
business processes
needs needs are the high level
representation of the terms and the
result
business needs include identifying and
comprehending the businesses goals and
articulating is strategic direction
and you can think of needs are what do
we need to succeed
requirements are well these are the
things we need to put into place this is
what's required to achieve a business
objective
suppose you have been given a list of
zip
pin codes
from different countries using those
codes find the city and the state names
using excel
and so if you're given a list of zip
codes pin codes of various cities from
the us and india here's how you can find
the city and the country names select
all the codes go to the data tab under
data types select geography
click on the insert data option choosing
city from the field list click on the
insert data option and select state from
the field list
really you do need to know your way
around excel no matter what other
packages you're working with
excel is such a base package in business
analysis uh so much people are giving
that back and forth still it's still
kind of a baseline
below our sales data that has
information on different items sold
across various regions and countries
what was the total revenue generated for
all the items in india
you can use the sum if function to find
the total revenue generated from india
you see here equals some f and then of
course b2 to b100 india l2 to l1001 and
that will give you
the sum you can also use a filter option
to filter the data only for india and
use subtotal by pressing alt plus equals
nice short hotkey to remember there
create a highlight table to visualize
the revenue generated from offline and
online cells for different items across
the region using tableau
now not all companies use tableau
but it is becoming a very highly used
tool because it's so easy to use
you drag the region onto columns drag
the cells channel and item type fields
onto rows select the total revenue
column and drag it on to
color and label cards select square as
the mark type
drag the total revenue field onto
columns drag the total profit column
onto rows place item type column on to
colors under the size card place the
total profit drag the region column into
the filters card and select asia
so
one of the things about tableau is it
looks real complicated but it's all drag
and drop and so you should know your way
around about doing some very simple drag
and drops for doing your query and
summation and below is the resulted plot
so let's look at some more questions but
let's jump to a little more intermediate
level
uh differentiate between software
development life cycle and project life
cycle
so a little bit more hierarchical
towards the top of the list software
development life cycle helps with the
development of software products it
consists of a single software across
multiple phases
here phases include requirement
gathering coding operations maintenance
and documentation
where the project life cycle this
enables you to develop a new product in
the business project lifecycle consists
of multiple software in one customer
scenario
phases here are idea generation
screening development testing and
analysis
how do you perform risk management
in your project
so again we're dealing with intermediate
not just how to pull tables across we
don't start analyzing things and the
risk management is a technique wherein
risks are identified avoided reduced
assessed and mitigated
having the appropriate risk management
plan decreases losses and optimizes
decision making to enhance the
organization's performance how does risk
mitigation differ from risk avoidance
risk mitigation risk mitigation is a
plan to be executed when a risk occurs
when a risk occurs there might be a
business impact and the cost incurred is
high
risk avoidance whereas risk avoidance is
carried out to avoid the risk from
occurring meanwhile the business impact
here is zero and the cost is fully
eliminated and you can think about a
brick and mortar store
and they have shoplifting
you want to mitigate as you want to
avoid as much shoplifting as you can
but you can only frisk people at the
door and have security so much before
you start losing customers and so when
you mitigate it you're going to have to
pay for your lost merchandise where you
avoid it you have your security cameras
and people watching to stop
people from
stealing things
risk in this case can mean loss of money
spent
badly spent on equipment certifications
there's all kinds of areas where you
want to mitigate and avoid risk
what are project deliverables project
deliverables represent a collection of
measurable services and goods that are
to be delivered to the end user in the
project completion stage
this is so important we start talking
about any of our
uh
when you sign a contract any of our
online contracts cloud computing all of
that make sure you're very clear what
the deliverables are who owns it who is
the responsibility of the service and
the security around it those are all
very important questions to know
differentiate between the agile and
waterfall model
two of our biggest or
most basic models used today
the agile model which is slowly taken
over especially in software
the agile model is adaptable to
requirement changes and has an
incremental approach
in the agile mile model testing can be
performed in every phase
with the waterfall model the waterfall
model is referred as a structured
software development methodology
changes and requirements are difficult
to implement meanwhile in the waterfall
model testing is performed only in the
final phase
and you can look at this as a lot of the
software today has to be ready to change
quickly when the waterfall
setup you're not looking for fast
changes you're looking for a very solid
it's going to work no matter what kind
of view this is something that we can
build it doesn't have to make major
changes but it better work correctly
describe the different analytical
techniques like moscow and
swat moscow analysis is a prioritization
technique that highlights a requirements
significance question like is it a
must-have or it should have
could the demand be made better would a
specific idea be useful in the future
are asked here
in the swot analysis it discovers the
strengths and weaknesses of a firm and
evaluates them as opportunities and
threats
swot analysis consists of strengths
weaknesses opportunities and threats
and you cannot kind of think of it as
like the swat team coming in
to you know be worried about threats
here so we're talking about policing or
in moscow really what is um what can we
get out of this you know is this do we
have to have it to succeed is it going
to be useful in the future so you're
looking more for a general value
attached to it list various components
of strategy analysis
for developing a strategic plan for an
organization the vital components are
vision
objectives
mission strategies
action plan
what is benchmarking
benchmarking is the process of
evaluating an organization's measures
like the quality of policies programs
etc against the standard criteria
it's so important to have that baseline
of what are you measuring against the
baseline might not even be a very good
one but you can't measure something
unless you have something to measure it
against
it helps with the measuring the
performance of the company you can
recognize the areas of improvement in a
company and analyze how other companies
achieve other objectives
what is the best approach to work with
difficult stakeholders
a business analyst interacts with many
professionals during his work few of the
best approaches to take into
consideration while working with
difficult stakeholders are before i even
jump into this i have a friend who is
working with some very high end
individuals who took their private plane
and he was supposed to meet him at the
end location
when he arrived they had been in a fist
fight while on their private plane the
stakeholders had so much difficulty with
some particular aspect going on
so difficulties are going to arise
hopefully not at that level but things
happen
and of course you want to just assume
work with anybody but you want to listen
patiently to the stakeholders point of
view
respond to them politely and
diplomatically
have a one-on-one discussion to make
things more precise
comprehend their worries and be
transparent
make sure to continuously engage such
difficult stakeholders
and i'm going to highlight the last one
because if you're working with somebody
who's difficult and you just try to
ignore them
one of the things is that whatever
problems are arising they're just going
to explode
so that is so important not to ignore
the ignore somebody who's being
difficult
but the rest of it is stay focused stay
focused on what you're trying to
accomplish
be goal driven this is a great time to
be goal driven
not driven by emotion or the problems
that arise or how the person
communicates
name the different types of agile
methodologies
scrum go get scrum certified important
thing to look into if you haven't
learn software development and extreme
programming xp
feature driven development fdd
crystal kanban dynamic systems
development method dsdm
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skillup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more
there is an agile just a ton of
different methodologies so knowing at
least a few of them inside and out and
having a kind of a general idea that the
other ones are out there is important to
at least know what we're talking about
when someone comes up and talks about
agile
describe the gap analysis gap analysis
refers to the analysis of differences
between the existing systems
functionalities and the targeted system
the gap indicates the amount of work
required to get the intended result
gap analysis is a comparison between the
current and proposed functionalities
and you can see here we put together an
action plan to go from the current state
to the desired state
how do you import text file data into ms
excel
and
remember excel is one of those things
that has been around forever and even
though it's like the bottom barrel of a
lot of
analysis that we do
most of our data starts in an excel
spreadsheet
or comma separated variable file that
you then end up with an excel
spreadsheet
given below is the employee text file it
has information about name agent company
and here's how you can import this data
into excel
go to the data tab click on get data
drop down under
from file select text csv select where
the text file is located in your system
and click on import
click on load data imported into excel
you've been given cells data that has
information on the cell of different
items across the world below is the data
create a pivot table to analyze the
profit of all the items in each region
now remember our pivot table is a table
of statistics that summarizes the data
of a more extensive table so it takes a
full data sheet and we're just going to
bring we're going to focus zoom in on
something that's what the pro the pivot
table means
if we want to go ahead and do this we do
is go ahead and select a cell in the
table go to insert and click on pivot
table
in the create pivot table box choose
existing worksheet to place your pivot
table
drag region and item type onto rows drag
total profit onto values sort the sum of
the total profit column
using the sales table find the
percentage contribution of cosmetics to
the total revenue and total profit
create a pivot table by dragging item
type onto rows select the revenue and
profit column under values
right click on the revenue value under
show value as select percentage of grand
total right click on a profit value
under show value as choose percentage of
grand total and you can see here when we
do that we end up with cosmetics made a
14.03 contributions to the total revenue
and an 18.94
contribution to the total profit how do
you create a dual axes chart in tableau
drag the order data onto columns and
convert it into continuous year drag
total revenue onto rows and total profit
to the right corner of the view until
you see the light green rectangle
synchronize the right axis by right
clicking on the profit axis
under the marks card change sum total
revenue to bar and sum total profit to
line and adjust the size and color
they're lots of fun to play with as you
start getting into these
using the sales data create a view to
show the total units sold and the profit
generated from each item which item sold
the police and has least profit
so we'll go ahead and load an excel file
data in tableau desktop
drag units sold onto columns and item
type column under rows place the total
profit column under color and choose the
desired color palette sort the unit's
sold axes in descending order
you can see here it produces a very
quick
bug figure shows the fruit sold and the
least and had the least amount of profit
create a map to show the units sold and
the profit generated from different
middle east and north africa items drag
country onto the detail card place a
total profit column under size drag
units sold under color
in the filters card drag the region
column and select middle east and north
africa
bahrain had the maximum number of units
sold at the same time iran made the full
amount of profit
create a visualization to analyze the
total revenue and the units sold for
clothes meat and baby food across
different regions in 2006 and 2017.
drag the units sold filled on the
columns drag the region and item type
fields onto rows
under the cooler card place a total
revenue column drag item type onto
filters and choose close meet and baby
food drag the ordered date column onto
filters and select 2016 and 2017.
meat had the highest units sold and made
the maximum profit now with any of these
tableau it's good if you have your own
hands on for this
so that's an important thing to note we
kind of zoomed in on tableau again
there's a lot of other companies out
there using a lot of other packages so
if you're not familiar with tableau but
you're able to do this in another
package
that's a good thing so at least you know
what we're talking about and you've had
that hands-on
let's go ahead and jump to some advanced
level questions
what is requirement prioritization name
the different techniques used for it
requirements prioritization focuses on
allocating requirements depending on the
business
urgencies this is essential for the
project to run well requirement
prioritization enables various teams to
understand what is important
and work in sync with the business needs
there are several techniques used for
requirement prioritization
we had moscow technique we mentioned
that earlier the requirements are
grouped based on must mandatory should
high priority could not necessary but
preferred and would suggested for the
future
ranking method here you give each
requirement a distinct numerical value
based on its importance
of course this is at 100
oh well here's kind of similar to
ranking is the 100 method multiple
stakeholders get a no
notional 100 to distribute among the
requirements
so the 100 method is pretty similar to
what the ranking method is
top 10 requirements and this approach
from a large set the stakeholders simply
picked their top 10 requirements
this is very popular
there's a lot of help books out there
about getting things done they say write
everything that you want to accomplish
put them on three by five cards and
narrow it down to five
do those five because once you've
conquered those five then you can move
on to the next ones
name the critical agile metrics that
should be considered by a business
analyst
sprint burned down
so the sprint burned down is the chart
we use when you're tracking usually it's
in scrum is where that usually comes
from the scrum uh setup
but it's a chart of the work to be
completed and what's still going on
uh you have your work category
allocation the velocity
the cumulative flow diagram defect
removal awareness
time coverage defect resolution time
explain
bpmn
bpmn business process model and notation
gateway controls the flow of interaction
and sequence of processes it is a
flowchart technique which models the
end-to-end business process step
the four essential elements of bpmn are
flow objects events activities gateways
connecting objects sequence messages
associations swim lanes pool or lane
artifacts data object group annotation
list the elicitation techniques the
elicitation process is about gathering
requirements from users and stakeholders
listed below are a few techniques that
are used to collaborate with users or
clients
interviews
during how many times i've been on the
phone calling
competition
potential clients to ask questions
so
one of the elicitation techniques is to
ask questions if you're going to call
clients to ask questions it can a lot of
terms also turn into additional sales
document analysis
focus group
prototyping
brainstorming my favorite brainstorming
all these are important i just kind of
highlight a few of them that i tend to
get stuck in
observations and workshops
again workshops are a great sales
technique also so as you're doing your
business analysis
and you're bringing people into a
workshop and do observations in the
workshop and working specifically with
these people they turn into potential
business growth
i tell you what if you're a shareholder
and someone's doing a business analysis
and they turn around
and generate a 30 000 sell for your
company
they're in you know you've already
earned your you've already earned your
pay and you're doing what you like which
is business analysis
interface analysis questionnaire and
survey uh questionnaire surveys my least
favorite but they are the most popular
because they're the easiest to pump out
list the documents needed by a business
analyst
initiation document
project vision document
use cases
system requirements
specifications document
business requirement document
requirements traceability matrix
functional requirement document
use case specifications document
gap analyst document describe how you
would approach a project
here's a basic project approach outline
which you can use with respect to
different situations
identifying the project goal formulating
the work plan defining the requirements
collaborating with other teams
tracking the project documenting the
progress
and really when you
start
designing your project approach
encompassing all the things listed in
here is so important with the
shareholders
if you i mean it's great if you can
identify your project goal that's
probably the most important thing
because if you don't have a goal you
might as well walk away
[Music]
but if you don't have the rest well how
are you formulating the work plan
defining the requirements
collaborating with other teams that is
such a big step
because we're going from everything
being on paper and trying to figure out
what you're going to do to actually
doing it and then tracking and finally
documenting very important for the
shareholders and what goes back to the
top
differentiate an alternate flow and
exception flow in a use case diagram
from a basic flow
basic flow represents the operation of
activities as required by the company
in a use case alternate flow as the name
suggests is an alternate solution used
in a system failure case different steps
are used to complete the goals of a use
cases
exception flow refers to the various
steps executed in case of errors this
does not lead to achieving the required
goal of a use case critical aspects of
creating analytical reporting analytical
reporting is a type of business
reporting which provides data analysis
information and recommendations it
enables people to use data to make
decisions to create analytical reporting
the following points should be kept in
mind
comprehend business analysis
display your analysis skills think
critically
and i'm going to throw in here the term
from big data map and reduce
really when we're doing a business
analysis
you don't want to give them a massive
amount of information you want to reduce
it down to something that they can see
in a single graph
a very simple set of notes
and you need to think critically you
need to really make it
what is it that the shareholders want
that's going to make them understand why
this is important to the business and
what does the business get out of it
what is kanban
kanban helps agile teams in visually
managing work through processes it works
as a scheduling system in agile just in
time production the kanban methodology
is all about real-time communication of
capacity and full transparency of work
the kanban board describes a current
development status
and of course when you're working with
kanban you got to be very careful about
[Music]
inspiring versus coaching versus
micromanaging
it really can end up in a micro
management setup where you want to you
want to watch out for that but you also
need to track everything
a basic kanban board has three step
workflow as the to do in progress and
done
however depending on a team size
structure and objectives the workflow
can be mapped to meet any particular
team's unique process
state the key differences between brd
and srs
brd business requirements documents is a
high level functional specification of
software
brd is a formal document to describe the
requirement provided by the client
business analysts create this post
through interaction with the clients
srs
system requirement specification is a
high level functional and technical
specification of software srs describes
the software's functions and
non-functional requirements that are
needed to be developed whereas srs is
created by the systems architects
what is pareto analysis the pareto
analysis helps in crucial decision
making it helps in prioritizing
decisions identifying the most relevant
and the least decision concerning the
overall goal
it is also known as the 80 20 rule
as per this rule 82 percent of the
project's benefit arises from 20 of the
work
vice versa 80 of the case problem can be
due to 20 of the causes
differentiate between the v model and
the fish model
we talk about the v model it is an sdlc
model where the execution of processes
happens sequentially in a v shape
at every stage the same person reviews
but other testers will do software
testing in the last step
v-model consumes less time and costs
the fish model is similar to the v model
but with more multiple verification
teams
every stage is tested by another team
for completeness and correctness
the fish model is comparatively very
costly and time consuming
which makes sense because if you have
multiple tests on each stage for
multiple teams they have to all be spun
up on it and so you're literally more
than doubling the work because you also
have to track all that
given the sales data create a chart to
show each region's country that made the
highest revenue
create a pivot table by dragging the
region and country onto rows place the
total revenue column under values
right click on the country value select
the filter options and choose top 10.
choose top one as shown above and click
on ok
and you can see here is the pivot table
that you will get
using the sales data find all the
countries where the total units of
fruits sold offline were less than three
thousand
you need to use an advanced filter
option in microsoft excel to solve this
problem
below is a critical based on the
question we have
go to the data tab select advanced
filter option choose copy to another
location give your criteria range and
the copy to location click on ok
here's the final result as we can see
below
let's create a pivot table to find which
countries from each region made the
lowest amount profit
create a pivot table by dragging the
region and the country into rows place
the profit column under values right
click on any country value select the
filter option and choose top 10 choose
bottom one and click on ok
let's create a filled map to analyze the
total revenue and profit generated from
beverages in north america using tableau
drag country under detail card place a
total revenue column under the text drag
total profit under kalur and the filters
card drag the region column and select
north america
in the filters card drag the item type
column and select beverages
and you can see from the below map you
can see that greenland and the maximum
revenue and profit generated from
beverages in north america
who knew
using tableau how will you display the
top five and bottom five items based on
profit
drag the item type filled under rows and
total profit onto columns right click on
the item type column to create a set
give a name to the set and select the
top tab to choose the top five items by
sum total profit
create a set for the bottom five items
by sum total profit select both the sets
right click to create a combined set
give a name to the set and choose all
members in both sets drag the new set on
the filters and the total profit onto
calor
the above graph depicts the cosmetics
made the highest profit while fruits
made the lowest and really when we're
talking about tools like tableau
or if you're targeting companies working
in r
or you're targeting companies working in
python
you should be able to quickly do these
kind of displays in any of those
packages that you're focused on
tableau is one of the biggest ones out
there right now because it is a paid for
service but it's also
very robust and easy to use and uses
less programming on the back end
so just a quick side note on there
really just leads up if you if this does
not look right to you you're not able to
get through some of these things make
sure you are if that's what you're
targeting in a company for an interview
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1 000 plus hours of
video content for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more before i start
off with our top 5 bi tools i'd like to
talk a bit about business intelligence
as you might be aware there are zillions
of companies across the world these
companies generate massive amounts of
data on a daily basis when i say data
here it simply refers to business
information both internal and external
customer feedback product innovations
and profit loss reports to name a few
companies use all of this information to
make crucial decisions that can either
hamper or boost their business
you might have heard of the term data as
the new oil well it definitely is if
organizations analyze all the available
data very well then this oil is
definitely valuable
and to help organizations with this we
have business intelligence which is more
often termed as bi
we can define bi as a technology driven
process which works on analyzing
unstructured data to derive meaningful
information from it basically it is a
set of architecture and processes that
convert raw data into useful information
that helps in achieving profit for a
business
so to achieve business intelligence
goals we use a set of tools these tools
are termed as bi tools they help
organizations acquire and analyze data
efficiently
some of the bi tools are seasonal but
some are evergreen we have a plethora of
these tools in the market which makes it
hard for businesses to select one single
tool
here we have a recommendation list of
the top 5 bi tools of 2020 after
extensive research and an in-depth
evaluation we have come up with this
list
in addition to the top 5 we also have a
few other tools which look promising for
the year 2020
so let us have a look at the top five bi
tools
at number five we have thoughtspot
thoughtspot is a us-based company that
provides its customers with business
intelligence software thoughtspot makes
analysis of data easy and it does so in
the matter of a few seconds
as you can see on your screens this is
how the interface looks like
let's now have a look at the features of
hotspot
thoughtspot is a search driven solution
that is the users can find insights
through an interface known to everyone
that is search
this makes the tool more accessible the
spot iq engine also uses artificial
intelligence in the form of algorithms
to identify and display insights like
trends and causal relationships
instead of going through a number of
different procedures to create a chart
thoughtspot's instant chart creation
ability lets users automatically view
data graphically with just a few mouse
clicks you can generate a visually
appealing story
when a business grows so will its data
requirements hence it is crucial that
you have a tool that can be scaled up
easily thoughtspot has this feature and
it also performs automatic load
balancing across all its servers
thoughtspot is also now available for
small and medium instance types on aws
microsoft azure and google cloud
thoughtspot has a user-friendly
interface even users with absolutely no
prior knowledge or training can operate
hotspot easily
so those were the features of
thoughtspot let us now have a look at
the companies using thoughtspot
as you can see on your screens we have
the american multinational retail
corporation walmart then we have the
royal bank of canada rbc followed by 711
and exxon mobil let us now move on to
our next tool
so at number four we have sas bi
the sas business intelligence tool looks
into the analysis data mining and
reporting with the help of powerful
visualizations and interactive
dashboards
in sas data is extracted and categorized
which helps in identifying and analyzing
data patterns
as you can see on your screens this is
how the interface looks like
moving on to the features of sas bi
first and foremost it is easy to use
irrespective of your skill level you
will be able to easily explore create
and share data there is no need for the
user to rely on the it team
better analysis of data is achieved by
using automatic code generation and sas
sql
the next feature of sas is that it
allows you to integrate with open source
software such as r
r helps you to connect to many databases
and data types
sas provides the best practices and
defines the guiding principles for a
secure product development lifecycle sas
br ensures that the products meet the
business and security needs of the
customers
let us now have a look at the companies
using sas bi we have companies like
axenshaw genpak iqvr and ibm to name a
few
that was all about sas bi let us now
move on to our next tool
so at number 3 we have click
the company was founded in sweden back
in the 90s the company's first product
was click view it is a powerful tool
which visualizes and analyzes the
relationships between data
qlik sense is a self-service data
discovery and analysis tool it provides
a modern user interface for data
management click is named a leader in
the 2020 gartner magic quadrant for
analytics and bi platforms
as you can see on your screens this is
how the interface looks like
moving on to the features of click
click view can do everything that an
olap based solution will do and much
faster you can take advantage of click's
powerful ai and machine learning to
accelerate discoveries boost data
literacy and derive insights
qlik sense works without data filters
but while working with qlikview data
filters are required
click allows flexible deployment
capabilities for seamless end-user
experiences and management capabilities
across multi-cloud environments
data storytelling is an important part
of bi qlik sense provides this feature
but it is not available with qlikview
with the click data integration platform
you can do powerful data integration and
perform modern analytics
as you can see on your screens these are
the companies using click we have
mercedes-benz cognizant accenture and
capgemini
so for all those who joined in now let
me just quickly repeat our list at
number five we have thoughtspot then at
number four we have sas bi and at number
three we have click
so far do you all agree with this list
let us know in the comment section below
let us now move on to our next tool at
number two we have tableau
tableau is one of the most popular and
fastest growing business intelligence
tools used in companies these days
tableau is a data visualization tool
that was founded in 2003 it manages the
vast volumes of data and its flow and
turns data into actionable information
it allows you to analyze and visualize
data faster and efficiently
the tableau product suite consists of
tableau desktop tableau public tableau
online tableau server and tableau reader
as you can see on your screens this is
how the interface looks like
moving on to the features of tableau
one of the most important features of
tableau is that it can connect to 40
different data sources and handle large
amounts of data easily
some of the data sources are local text
files microsoft excel pdfs json or
databases and servers like mysql server
microsoft sql server etc
tableau is an easy to use drag and drop
tool which allows its users to create
interactive visuals quickly
you can build different charts and
graphs dashboards and storylines with
just a few clicks
in tableau you can gain insights that
you never thought was possible you can
play with interactive visualizations and
explore various data that is available
and you don't need to have any specific
knowledge of the insight you're looking
for
knowledge of coding is not required to
work on tableau as tableau provides
in-built table calculations
so some of the companies that use
tableau are the american e-commerce
giant amazon the italian luxury sports
car manufacturer ferrari then we have
walmart followed by cab gemini and
linkedin
before we move on to the number one bi
tool in our list let's have a quick look
at a few bi tools which didn't make it
to our list but which seemed to be very
promising in the year 2020.
so here we have zoho analytics which is
a cloud-based self-service bi and data
analytics software that is used for data
visualization and for creating
dashboards
up next we have oracle bi it is an
oracle corporation set of bi tools used
for reporting and analyzing data built
around tables graphs dashboards etc
then we have pentaho which is a bi
software used for creating relational
and analytical reporting with the help
of pentaho we can transform complex data
into meaningful reports and draw
valuable insights out of them
and finally on the top of the hierarchy
we have power bi
power bi is a business intelligence tool
that provides users with features to
analyze visualize aggregate and share
insights from data to make business
decisions
it is provided by microsoft power bi has
several components such as power query
power pivot power view power map power
bi desktop and power qna each of these
components has its own features and
functionalities
as you can see on your screens this is
how the interface looks like
moving on to the features of power bi
firstly it provides easy drag and drop
functionality which makes data visually
appealing it allows you to copy all
formatting across similar visualizations
power bi transforms your enterprise data
into rich visuals and accurate reports
for enhanced decision making it can also
be used with azure using power bi with
azure allows you to analyze and share
large volumes of data it integrates
seamlessly with advanced cloud services
like azure and cortana to provide
results for the verbal data queries
with power bi you can fetch data from
factory sensors and social media sources
to get access to real-time analytics
it provides a unified user experience
with customized dashboard and reports
that meet your exact needs
power bi ensures secure report
publishing as it sets up automatic data
refresh and rapidly publishes reports
allowing all the users to avail the
latest information
the companies that use power bi on a
daily basis are nestle capgemini
accenture and entity data hi everyone
welcome to this tutorial on microsoft
excel so
we will learn about functions and
formulas we will learn about conditional
formatting data validation pivot chart
and pivot table
now let's look at the scenario here so
one day in a startup
one professional speaks that their
business is growing and they would need
an efficient way to work with the data
they would have to find a way to work
faster with storing and analyzing data
now to that another colleague responds
well we can make use of microsoft excel
to do this job the question is will
excel be able to cater to
their business needs
now
the colleague response well we can make
use of excel in several ways and it also
is a cost efficient
option
now in that case the colleague who posed
the question
says let's go ahead with excellent let's
train our employees in excel
and the suggestion is welcomed which
would make the job easier for them
and they would basically
decide on using excel so they decide on
taking a training right away and
basically starting to learn excel
now
before we move to excel one of the
question is why should we use excel
so let's look at some of the points here
so excel proves to be a great platform
to perform various mathematical
calculation on large data sets which is
one of the biggest requirements of
various organizations these days
various features in excel like searching
sorting filtering makes it easier for
you to play with the data
and excel also allows you to beautify
your data and present it
in the form of charts tables and data
bars
now when it comes to reporting reporting
accounting and analysis can be performed
with the help of excel
it can help you with your task lists
your calendars and goal planning
worksheets
excel also provides good security for
your data excel files have the feature
of password protection
this way your information can be safe
now when we talk about what is excel and
how it can be used
so excel or you might have heard a
spreadsheet can be basically used for
a lot of different tasks than just
storing the information in so called
tabular format
now microsoft excel is an application
that is used for recording analyzing and
visualizing data it is in the form of a
spreadsheet
let's have a look at few of the
functions and formulas used in excel and
before we do that we can also quickly
take a
small tour to understand how to work
with excel now to do that what we can do
is we can type in in our search say for
example excel and just select your excel
app which is installed and here you see
you have a lot of options which says
take a tour drop down list get started
with formulas make your pivot table
going forward with pie charts and much
more so we can click on this one which
says take a tour
and that basically pops up a window
which says welcome to excel and if you
have always wanted to be better at excel
you have this
which can help you so let's click on
create and that takes us to the store
window now that says instructions for
screen readers which basically talks
about 10 different steps in which we can
learn excel
and using the spreadsheet app
so there are more than 11 sheets which
we see here at the bottom end and each
one gives us a simple example which we
can work on
so for example if i click on add
now that takes me to this page which
says
how do we add numbers now you might be
provided data which we can
upload by loading a file from our
machine or getting data from a web
source or even connecting to a database
so there are various options which we
will see in some time
so here we have an option which is
called data you can click on this one
and this basically has
options where you can use existing
connections if you have created some you
can always click on from other sources
and you can get your data from sql
server from analysis services
from odata data feed you can get in from
xml from data connection wizard or also
from microsoft query you can be running
in different queries here which shows up
in the option which says new query there
are connections which you can use
and that basically will display all the
connections
for this particular workbook which we
did not have as of now but we can create
them but let's look at simple examples
now you can follow these instructions
here which says basically
adding up the numbers and that could be
easily done by just placing your cursor
here and what you could do is either you
can type in the formula that is from
which row to which row you would want to
add the data so for example i could just
do a sum here and that shows up all the
different functions which are available
then we can open up a parenthesis and we
can say i would be interested in
totaling the amount
from
column d and i would select for example
d4
so
i could be doing this and then i could
say d4
onwards till d7 so that's the data which
i'm interested in you can close your
parenthesis and hit enter and that gives
you the total
there is also a shortcut for this which
you can always do is we can first delete
this and you can just place your cursor
here and just
use your alt and equals that
automatically selects the numericals
which we can anytime
expand
or basically collapse so i will
basically select this which says this
function needs two numbers which is
number one and number two and then you
can hit on enter and that gives you the
total
so similarly we can be getting in the
data here by selecting all the fields
so here it also says that you can use a
shortcut now what we can also do is we
can add numbers over 50
by selecting the yellow cell here and
then giving a condition
such as so i can basically use something
like sum if
and then open a paranthesis i can select
i would be interested in this row and
then i can even drag and drop
till here so that tells me d11 to d15
you can then put in a comma here and you
can give your condition say for example
we would say i would be interested in
numbers only above 50 and we can select
this
close your quotes and then just close
your parenthesis and that's your formula
so you can do this and that basically
gives me the total is hundred now
similarly we could do that for the
amount here i could select this now
there is also an option i can click on
home and i can go for something like
auto sum so that's one more way of doing
it which anyway says
sum is alt plus equals so it
automatically adds up your values and i
can try doing a auto sum
that automatically selects my rows and
then i can get my total now as per this
activity here it says try adding another
sum if formula here but add amounts that
are less than 100 and the result should
be
160. so what we can do is we can
basically
select all the numbers which are lesser
than 100 so the way we did earlier here
there can be always a shortcut so you
can always for example if you would want
to avoid typing in the formula you can
always copy it from here
and then
just hit on enter so you are back into
this cell and then i can basically go
here and paste
the number and then as per the
requirement we are required to select
anything which is lesser than 100 so
what i could do is i could select here i
could say let's say g and then i can
change this value to g15 and that's one
more way now we see our selected rows
have been changed so i can hit on enter
and
i can check what is the result so we
would be interested in
looking for numbers which are lesser
than 100 so i will have to also change
this one to
a lesser sign and that basically gives
me the total which is 160
so that's how you can simply add numbers
you can use autosum you can type in the
formula you can select the fields or you
can just place your cursor where you
would be looking for a sum and then you
can just do a alt equals and that
basically populates the sum
now let's look at
some easy options of filling your cells
or automatically populating the values
in your
cells within your excel sheet
now here we have an option which says
100 now we can click on this and that
basically says it is making a sum of
column c4 to d4
so if i click on this one i can check
that this is
row number four
which shows up here and i also know this
is column c i also have d so this equals
is basically giving me a sum of c4 to d4
now what we can do is we can always
place our cursor here at the right
corner and then we can just drag and
drop and this basically gives me a total
of all the numbers for all different
rows
so this is one shortcut which we can do
to get the total excel will
automatically give the totals which we
call as filling down
now what we can do is in the same way if
we would want to get the totals here we
can first check what is this 200 and
this tells me it is c11 to c14 total so
it is totaling the rows from c11 so
column c and 11th row till 14th row and
that's the sum now what i can also do is
i can similarly like above we can do a
filling right which basically means
bringing your cursor here and then just
dragging and dropping it all the way
where you would need the totals and this
basically gives me the total there is
one more quick way to check if this is
right
so the easiest option would be
to select this cell now what i can also
do is i can just select all of these
fields by just highlighting and
selecting all the fields once it is
selected
press on control r
and that gives you the total now if we
would be doing this stop down then i
could select all these
rows
for this particular column and then i
could do a control d so that's your
filling down and this one was filling
right so this is an easier option of
doing a fill
when you would want to have the formula
applied to every row as it occurs in the
first row or the last row we could test
this by for example selecting these
fields i could delete them and i have
here which says 130 i could just place
my cursor here and i could drag it all
the way up and that should also do the
same magic which we were seeing from top
down so this is a simple way wherein you
can fill up your cells and you can also
automatically
propagate
or move your computation to all the
cells
let's
look at the split option which basically
helps us in splitting the data when we
have some kind of pattern or when we
have some kind of delimiters in our data
in say one particular column and we
would want to derive the values out of
it so we can always use the splitting
option now the easiest option would be
so for example we have our email column
which has the email ids and which we can
clearly see has a first name dot last
name now i see that there is a last name
smith filled up here first name is empty
so what i can also do is i can just type
in say
nancy here
now that's the first name i can again
start typing the second name and as soon
as you do that you would see a faded
list of numbers and that's your clue to
hit enter and once you do that you would
see all the first names have been filled
in here if you would want to maintain
the case sensitiveness you can just go
ahead and delete these and let's type in
as it occurs so let's say nancy as the
first name go down to the next cell and
just type in andy and there is your
grade list so just hit on enter and that
basically fills up your first name
what we can also do is
we can just select this particular field
and either we can type in control e
which basically fills up all the options
now i can just do a undo by typing in or
clicking control z
and that's basically gone what i can
also do is i can select a particular
field and then i can go into home option
and under home
you should have an option here which
says fill so you can select this and
then you can do a flash fill which is
what we are doing here so click on flash
fill and that automatically fills up the
values so in this way you can work
within your spreadsheet and you can be
filling up the values where a delimiter
by default is understood and we can
split the data now however sometimes you
might have some data which has a
different kind of delimiter and there is
again a smarter way of splitting your
data so you can always scroll down here
and that says splitting a column based
on delimiters so we have some values in
the data column and
these values in each row are separated
by comma so select this
your data is already selected text to
columns delimited
comma is selected
and now click on next so it basically
says
what is the destination let's select
this one
and i can choose
what would you want to have so that
shows me this would be my data preview
now i can basically select this one
i can say finish and say okay
and now if you see our data has been
placed in
in the columns appropriately so this is
how you can split your data based on a
delimiter and then organize your data in
a better way now there are some advanced
options which we can learn later but
this basically tells about using a
formula so this is something if say if
we have some name in one cell and if you
would want to split it into first name
your helper column
your middle name last name so that can
also be done using formulas and this
basically tells how would you extract
characters from your left cell and how
would you place them in your right cell
so you can try this activity which is a
little more of advanced option the
benefit is that
you can always use this
wherein
if you
do some kind of transformation using
your formulas if your original data gets
updated then the split data will also
get updated and that's the benefit of
using formulas where you can place
values from one cell into multiple cells
based on execution of your details in
the formulas
how about using the transpose option now
you might have heard of situations where
you would want to
switch or turn your rows into columns
and your columns into rows and that's
where transposing comes into picture it
might be useful when you have your data
in your x and y axis or as i would say
in rows and columns and you would want
to switch your rows to become the
columns and columns to become
your rows so what we can do is the
simplest way is you can
select all your
values so here we basically have six
columns and i would say two rows now i
can select all of these and then i can
select an empty field for example the
one which is highlighted here well you
can always do a control alt v that's a
shortcut what you can also do is
once you have selected all your fields
you can just copy them so just do a
control c
and then click on an empty cell and then
what you can do is you can do a special
paste or paste special so under your
home
you have the paste option and here you
can go for paste special
and once you do that you need to select
the transpose option over here and click
on ok
and now you will see that the columns
and the rows have been transposed so
your row name was item and that has
become the column heading you had row
name as amount and that has become the
column heading and all your values have
been transposed
in
this particular format now there is
another way of doing that and again
that's using your formulas so what you
can do is you can transpose with a
formula also and that basically
works
when you have similar kind of data so
this has six columns
and basically two rows so you can
basically do this so you can
select this and earlier we were doing a
copy but now what we would want to do is
we would want to just look at the row
numbers which tells me it is c 33 c 34
and it starts with c and ends in with
your h column so what we can do is we
know that we have six columns and two
rows so transposing that would actually
give me two columns and six rows so what
we can do is we can select
two columns
and six rows in our excel sheet i can
then basically start typing in the
message or i can just go to the address
bar and here i can say
transpose
let's go for c33 h34 it basically
selects my data
and now i can just do a
control shift and enter and now if you
see all the values have been populated
now you can just place your cursor in
one of the cells but if you see the
address bar the formula remains the same
this is because this is an array formula
so we can read more about an array
formula here it's basically something
which performs calculations and on more
than one cell in an array and in the
example here the array is the original
data that is c33 to h34 so your
transpose is just changing
the horizontal orientation to the
vertical orientation so this is a very
simple way in which you can basically
use the
excel's capability to transpose your
data and convert your rows into columns
and columns into rows apart from
working on
additions subtractions filling up your
data
sorting
the data or basically splitting your
data
transposing your data one of the other
requirements is
sorting and filtering your data now that
can be very handy when you're working on
huge data and you would want to sort it
in a particular order say ascending or
descending or might be based on a
particular field or if that field was or
if the cell was highlighted with a
particular color sorting the data so
let's look at how excel can be used for
sorting and filtering examples are
pretty simple here so
let's check that so if we're going to
sort and filter and say this is the data
i have say for example i would want to
sort the values in the department column
alphabetically so what i can do is i can
select department column and i'm already
in the home tab i can straight away go
here which says sort and filter
i can then say sort a to z and that's
basically alphabetically sorting your
department column
and once once i do this you would see
the data has been sorted but it's not
just this data we can just do a ctrl z
and check what are the values we have so
here we have meat which is beef and
ninety thousand
hundred ten thousand the values
then you have bakery which should
ideally be the first
row if we sort it in alphabetical order
which goes with bakery as desserts you
have the values so we can check this
again so select department and then just
do a sort and filter and let's say sort
a to z and if you see the data has
changed but it's not just in changing
your first column but then it has taken
care of all the data however the data
has been sorted based on the department
column so you have bakery which aligns
with deserts which has the values and
now we have all the data which has been
filtered now what we can also do is we
can sort december's amounts from largest
to smallest so what we can do is we can
basically click any cell in the december
column let's say 20 000
and then what i can do is i can go into
sort
filter and then i can say sort largest
to smallest so if you see bakery breads
is the row which has the smallest data
or might be you have delhi sandwiches so
that one looks also smaller so let's do
a
larger to smallest and if i do this you
would see the values have been shifted
now so it is no more based on the
department column
because now the data is being sorted
based on the values in the december
column and you see bakery which was
alphabetically the first one has become
second last
so either you can sort the data based on
a department column which goes
based on the values these are all string
values or words so it sorts
alphabetically if you have numbers might
be you can give some values and you can
sort the data
you could anytime do a custom sort and
you could basically select
if you would want to select the data so
i could do a custom sort and then i
could choose
which is the column which we would want
to use for sorting what is the sorting
needs to be done is it cell values is
itself color font color conditional
formatting and then you can also choose
the order so that's one more way to do
that
now if you scroll down that also shows
how you can sort by date or a color so
for example if you would want to sort
based on the expense date so there are
different options so what i can do is i
can select this date field i can just do
a right click i can go into sort and
then i can choose i would want to sort
oldest to newest so since i selected the
date field
it basically has sorted all the data
and it has taken the expense date into
consideration now there are these
filters which you see on the row
headings we could have also used those
so i could have selected this and that
basically says or mentions which are the
dates i would be interested in looking
at
i also have sort by color here i can do
a sort oldest to newest or newest to
oldest so i could also use these filters
which have been applied here now we have
the data which is in color so if i would
want to basically select
the color columns or color cells i could
select this i can basically do a right
click here and when i go into sort i
could choose
put selected color or cell color on the
top
and that basically will make sure that
my data is sorted and it has also sorted
that in a descending order so in this
way you can sort or basically filter
your data
what we can also do is we can add
filters so sometimes we can go for
formulas which we would want to use what
we can also do is we can basically
select the filter which has been applied
here now how does the filter come in
there so if i would select a particular
row
i could select a particular row and then
i could decide if i would want to just
add a filter to this one and that's how
the filter has come in so we have the
filter what we can do is we can
basically click on this drop down
and then you have something like number
filters so we can always go here we can
basically choose one of these so we can
basically choose above average so i
could select this and then basically it
shows me the values we could also delete
the filter by clicking on this one and
we could say well i'm not interested in
this filter anymore so i could clear the
filter and that shows me all the values
or i could say
that let's click on some other field for
example food i can go in here i can go
into number filters and then i could say
well i'm interested in
values which are below average above
average might be greater than and then i
can choose what is the value so for
example if we say i'm interested in food
which is
greater than 25 dollars i could give a
value here i could say ok
and now i have applied the filter
similarly you can select this and then
you can just clear your filter and your
data is back
so remember
no data is lost
it is just hidden or basically based on
the filter not shown
so that's good enough for us and in this
way you can sort and filter the data so
for more details obviously in all the
sheets you have the links which point to
more information on the web and you can
always refer to these so this is simple
way in which you can sort and filter any
amount of data which has been stored
within your excel within a particular
sheet now that we have learned about add
fill split transpose sorting and
filtering it will also be good to learn
how to work with tables or basically
converting your data into a tabular
format and then doing some easy
computations
so click on this tables option here now
here we see there is some data which is
in
five columns and n number of rows so i
can basically select this data
and then what i can do is i can insert
choose the table option
and then it says my table as headers and
we'll be okay with that i'll say okay
and now if you see this is the table
created it basically has different
filters which we have learnt earlier how
to use and this is basically my table
which is a collection of cells which has
some special features
so we can easily add rows to this table
we can add columns to this table and we
can even do some calculations so for
example here i can click on this one i
can
basically enter some field and then i
can hit on enter and we see that this
row has been inserted wherein we can
easily fill in values for example i
would say chocolates
i could give some value here size 25 000
might be 35 000
and then
basically i can given some values here
now what you can also do is you can
continue adding rows in this way
and say for example you would want more
columns so you can select this
option here in the top bottom right
corner you can just drag it towards the
right and that basically has
automatically created
columns for my next month
wherein i can feed in the data so this
is a simpler way wherein you can keep
adding more rows and columns to your
data if that has been converted in a
tabular format now let me just do a ctrl
z that basically deletes the columns
again ctrl z deletes the last row which
we added and i can stop here or i can
even remove my values by doing multiple
control z
and removing my rows so this is how
i converted my data into a table and
then i can easily work on this what i
can also do is i can do some
calculations so what we can do
we have a table here we have a total
field and what we can do is we can just
select one cell here now as we have
learned earlier we can do a alt and then
equals
and that basically says what
is this doing so it says it is
calculating the sum of
the last three months and if that's what
you would want to do just hit on enter
and it has automatically calculated
the totals for
all your rows for these three columns
so the sum formula is getting filled up
now i can select any particular cell and
i can look in my address bar so it has
already given me the formula where it
has started
calculating the sum from the october
column till the december column and has
given me the calculated values of the
columns what we can also do is we can
get total rows in the table now that's a
simpler option so what we can do is we
can select any cell in this particular
table
and then we see that there is a table
tools design option showing up here now
i can select this and then it says well
let's get a total row so let's select
this and it automatically populates the
total here
and if you would want the average then
we could select this and from the drop
down i can select what i'm interested in
so for example i would want the average
values and not the total i could just
select this and that gives me the
average of these values
so we can always do simpler computations
here
by converting our data into table format
let's learn about one more efficient way
of working with the data and that's
using your drop downs so let's see how
drop downs work here
now
say for example you have this data which
has the values in the food column and
department is empty and say for example
you would want to
enter the values in department however
you would want to select the department
should either have
produce or meat and bakery and these are
the only three options which should be
available for any user to fill in the
values how do we do that so we can
basically
create a table by pressing ctrl d so
what i can do is under my department
here i can select one of the cells
and then i can do a control t that
basically converts this into a table i
can say okay and my table is created now
what i can do is once this part is done
we can select all the blank fields here
where we would want this drop down to be
applicable
now under your data tab you can go in
and select data validation and this has
an option called data validation click
on this
which basically says allow any value so
here i will select i would want to give
a list of values and then i can type in
my values here which i can say produce
say for example meet and then say
bakery now these are the values
so we can click on ok
and once we have done that we basically
have a drop down here next to apples
which will only show us the values which
we can feed in under the department
column so i can go into every cell and
then i can basically choose
what is the department which handles
this
and then basically i can select one of
these from the drop down so this is an
easier option of creating your drop down
and then feeding in the values from the
set of values which you have defined
here on the right
so this is a simple example of using
your drop downs
working with your tables working with
your sort and filter transpose split
filling up your data adding in some data
here and similarly you can use excel for
more than
one use case using its inbuilt features
to easily work with your data
let's see how we can import data or
bring in data into our excel from
your local machine or from an external
web source
so what we can do is we can open up a
blank excel sheet and say for example
you have been provided
a text file or a csv file and you would
want to import that data into your excel
sheet that can be easily done
so right now i've opened an
excel sheet now i can click on data and
here i have an option which says
existing connections from other data
sources
so or you can click on connections if
you have already created some so we can
click on from other sources
so this is one option where you can
connect to your different data sources
and you can get the data
from
one of these
what we can also do is i can click on
connections now it says there is none
i can click on add it says
well show the connections where
connection files on network
connection files on this computer so i
can say let's get some files from this
computer
now if that does not show up something
so say browse for more
and that basically shows you different
options so let's basically select a
folder where i have
some data sets i'll click in here
and this is basically a folder where i
have some data sets
now let me select this particular file
and i know it is a csv file
so let's click on
open now if you would want to verify
this you could have gone and looked into
the properties of the file and it says
it is a dot csv file which is what we
are interested in so i will take this
file i'll say open now this basically
shows me
the text import wizard option which says
is the file delimited i'll say yes
click on next so i will select comma as
my delimiter i can say text qualifier is
none
now this is my data so my data preview
is already showing me the data is
what is the data in the csv file you can
click on next and then you have an
option which says data format is general
you can go for date format you can go
for advanced options so i'll just say
finish
and basically now this has been created
here so we basically have this and now i
can click on
close now once you have done that you
can click on existing connections it
shows me the data
which we have here the connection which
we have created say open
and then it says do you want to
import this data or bring this data into
existing worksheet
you can also say add this to a data
model if you are doing some data
modeling so click on ok
and now this data is automatically
inserted in my excel file i can
basically save it
into
this particular sheet now what we can
also do is we can also start a new sheet
and that does not have a data and we can
get some other data from web so what i
can do is i can go into my github
and let's say i would be interested in
this csv file
so i can select this
and this is my github path a path on web
so i can click on draw and that
basically gives me
the raw path where this particular file
is now you can select this
copy this particular path
and here you can come back to your excel
sheet we would be interested in getting
the data from web might be from a text
file where we will have to specify the
delimiters or let's go to web
and here i can given the web path from
where i would be interested in getting
the file let's give the github path
which is publicly available and then
click on import now once you click on
import it tells me there are two fields
data and value
these are
within double quotes separated by comma
so first let's click on import
now once we do this
it will basically get the data from web
and put in here it says existing
worksheet so we had already created a
new worksheet so let's click on ok
and now you have the data coming in but
then this basically shows me in one
particular field so what we can also do
is we can just do a control a that
selects all my columns here
and that's my data so we can then
basically
filter this out so we can say text to
columns
it's a delimited file click on next
we can select comma and
let the text qualifier be quotes
it shows me data
preview click on next
so you have the general format it shows
the destination that's the column click
on finish and now your data has been
split and you have the data which you
have imported from web so this is the
data which is coming in from web
this is the data which came in from my
local machine and similarly we can even
create connection with an existing
database so i can basically click on
connections if i would want to do that
so i have an option called connection
here
and it says where the selected
connections are used
i can basically click on add
i can basically choose
if i would want to get the files from
network or from computer like we did
earlier
i can click on browse for more which
should
show me
different other options to create
connections say you would want to create
a new sql server connection you can
connect to a new data source coming in
from different place you could basically
choose what kind of connection you would
you want so these are all the different
options which we can go for
and we can basically connect to a
database for example
if i have some database
and say for example access database
i can see if there are some files with
that particular database and i can
import it
so similarly we can also
uh click in here which says new query
and that also gives you an option of
getting the data from your files from
all these folders from databases so you
can basically click here and then you
can import data from a mysql database
provided that is set up on your local
machine or on a particular server you
can go from cloud you can get it from
online services you can get it from
other sources which says from web
from your hadoop file system from active
directory from a blank query and you can
even combine queries wherein you can run
a power query editor you can get the
data from different sources and then you
can bring it into your excel so in this
way you can get your data from different
sources into your excel into your
spreadsheet and then you can continue
working on those data sets
we have
already learned some basic operations
which you can do in excel and let's
implement our knowledge by working on
this particular data which is coming in
from housing data set now here if we see
some fields we have agent
date listed area list price and this is
basically the data which has been
sorted in newest to oldest order of date
listed so how do we
arrive at this
so what i can do is i can just click on
data listed
and then i can either
go in here i can select sort
i can get into custom sort
and then i can choose the column
based on which i would want to sort the
data so i would look for the newest data
to the oldest data that means that would
be in a descending order of dates or you
could say the oldest date or the
earliest month will be towards the lower
side of your sheet so here we can select
date listed now i can say let it sort
based on cell values and the order what
we have here so we have newest to oldest
so let's select this
i can say okay and now if you see the
date has been sorted so we have your
10 18 2007 on the top so that seems to
be the latest date and as we go down we
will see
an earlier month hour
and
earlier month than that in this date
listed so we have sorted our data
into
newest to oldest order and that's based
on your
date column so the result shows up here
now what we can also do is we can have
different questions which we would want
to answer so for example i would want to
sort the data in ascending order of area
and descending order of agent name how
do we do that so let's look into this so
this is here i already have the result
here and how did i get this so i'm
looking for ascending order of area in
descending order of agent name so we can
start with any particular column that
does not matter so for example if i look
into this excel sheet i have my agent
name select this which we want in a
descending order so we could either do a
sort and then go for descending sort z
to a we could also use
the filter option here on the top right
and we could do it or i could just say
sort z to a and then it
has arranged the data
based on the agent column being in
descending order now i can go into area
and then i can again do a sort and i
wanted my area column
to be used for sorting the data
ascending to descending
and that basically not only changes the
order of this particular column but for
my complete data so let's do that and
now if you see we have the
data which has been sorted so
we can see how many values we have here
and the area values which we see and
this is how you get your result so i'll
just do a ctrl z
and
again and i'm back to my original data
and this is the sorted result which we
are seeing at
similarly we can answer other questions
for example sort the data according to
the following order
of area
that is we are saying county
central
and then your county so we can basically
choose
in which particular way we would want to
do it so it is county central and then
again county
so if i look into my sheet 3 so here i
basically have my data which is
having some south county then you have
your central and then you have your
north county so we would want to
sort the data to solve our problem which
is
according to the following order so
first we go for area then we go for
south county central and north county so
what we can do is we can basically
have area field selected
and
i would want to sort this particular
data so i have south county central and
north county
so i can basically go for custom sort
and then i can choose which is the value
or column which i'm interested in let's
go for area
we will go for something like cell
values well you can also try to explore
conditional formatting icon
if this is what you would want to use
or we can basically go for just cell
values
and here we can say
if i would be interested in first
getting my values for
south county so
for example i can say custom list
and then
i can basically given the new list here
so i can say s
dot county
and then i would want central
and then i would want north county
so let's select this
as it exists
we can
basically say add
and that's basically the order which we
want to say okay
and then say okay here
and now what we would want is we would
want our data so we can compare that
with the values which we see here it
starts with kelly
you have in the 12th row something like
lang and that's what we are doing so we
can basically arrange the data in a
particular order by choosing a custom
list and then sorting your data
so that's one more simpler task of what
we have done where we have sorted the
data
in the order where
under our area column we first wanted
south county
then we wanted central data and then we
wanted north county so this is how you
can do it
now
let's look into one more problem so it
says find all the houses in the central
area
and we would want to basically apply a
regular filter let's let's see how do we
do that so we can click on this and here
we have the data so the problem
statement is we would want to find all
the houses in central area now how do we
do that we can do a sorting but
we would want to use the filter which
you see here
is implemented so how do you do it so
you can select this area
and say for example i would want to
apply filter i can just go in here and i
can say let's get a filter on my first
row and now i have filters applied so we
are interested in looking into the
central area houses let's go in here it
says
all these fields are selected that means
it shows everything
wherein your area has all these values
let's unselect this and then i will only
be interested in the central so let's
say okay
and then say okay so now you see that
the area
filter has been applied and we are
looking at the central column so what we
have done is we have applied a symbol
filter and we are looking at our data at
any point of time if you do not
want
the filter
then
what i can do is i can select this and i
can say well i'm interested in all the
data
so i could do this or you can clear the
filters from area
and you get your data back
so
that's in one way you can filter out
your data so let's look at an example of
sort and filter where we might have to
filter the data based on two columns
or multiple columns with different kind
of values where it could be and and or
condition now say for example this is
the data i have and this is the question
which we need to answer such as find the
list of all houses
in the central region with pool
and south county without pool now if it
was a simple filter based on one cell i
could have
just selected my
header
row
i could have then applied the filter
and once i have the filter i can look in
area where i have three regions so i am
only interested in central and south
county so i can get rid of north county
and that's fine but then
we have two different conditions here so
we need
the
data in central region to have
the value for pool being true
and for south county the value has to be
without pool now how do we
do that so what we can do is we can
first create a copy of these headers
here so let me do that now the area has
to be
south county so basically i can
either just select this and i can choose
this
value and then i can select this and
then i can choose central so that's the
criteria which i have
and the pool value has to be
so
central region should be with pool so
then this one
basically has to be true
and
this one has to be basically false so
south county is without pool so let's
select one of the values here and this
is my criteria now
to get my result
we can always place your cursor here and
you can check this is m column and
eighth row
okay so we would want the result here so
let's go ahead and now click on data
and then in filter you have an option
called advanced and here what i can do
is i can say i would want to filter the
list in the place but that's not what i
would want to do so i'll say copy to
another location and here if you see the
list range will tell me that this is the
data so a1 to j126 so a to j column
selected and all the rows
criteria range
is basically based on what i have given
here so that is m
from 1
to v
which is 3 so i'm selecting these
columns and then i'm saying all the way
whatever criteria i've given and copy to
i'm saying m8
to v8 so that basically will give me my
filtered result so you could basically
just say okay
and now i have my data which has been
filtered
and i have my area which is south county
that is without pool central with pool
again south county without pool and then
if you look at your central value that's
pool so this is an advanced filter which
we have applied where simply we have
filtered the data based on two columns
and then we have our result so in this
way you can have your customized filter
applied on two different columns and get
your data which can be either
replacing the existing content or
in the same sheet in different set of
columns and rows you can have your
result let's look at one more example of
filtering where you are trying to filter
the data based on an and condition
condition being met in two different
columns and then you would want to
filter out
the data for only specific columns so
the situation is the agents with a house
in north county that should be county
area having two
and a single type family so we are
talking about two bedrooms
and
we would basically have a single type
family and here the criteria is that we
would want to
only populate these columns which is
agent area bedroom and type now what you
can do is as i explained earlier that
you can get your result in
the same sheet in a different location
so here i have created these headers
which says agent area bedrooms and type
now this is basically a copy of all the
columns what we have here agent data
listed area list price bedrooms bath
square feet and so on so you can
basically create a copy of the headers
here and this is where we will give our
advanced criteria to filter the data
so the conditions which need to be met
is we need to look at north county
so for example here in area i can
basically go ahead and select one of the
values north county
now the criteria is having two bedrooms
only so let's say bedrooms and let's say
the value should be two
and then basically i'm saying a single
type family so when you would want the
single type family so here under type i
can give the criteria
single type
so
this is my and condition so we are
saying north county area having two
bedrooms and the type is single family
now this is the criteria which basically
means if i select this this one tells me
that this is m
one row onwards till v
2
so this is what we have
and we would want to filter based on
this so let's go ahead and then go for
data filter advanced
and here in advanced it says filter the
list in place now that's not what we
would want to do so i'll say copy to
another location
this basically selects the list range so
which is telling me
a 1
2 j 126 so that's the
columns and rows selected criteria range
is based on m1 v2 which we have given
here and copy 2 i would say for example
from
m7
to
p7 now this is the area where i would
this is the place where i want the
result let's say okay and now i get my
data which is
based on the question which has been
asked that you would want the agents
with a house in north county area having
two bedrooms and single type family so
in this way you can basically do
advanced filtering
get your data and get it stored in the
sheet anywhere at a different location
well i could have also done filtering in
place and that would have replaced the
data
which we have but that's not what we
want we would want the filtered result
in a different place so this is how you
can do some advanced filtering we can
also use excel to filter out the data in
one particular column which might be
conditional or say using some numerical
filters now here say for example the
problem statement is that you would want
to display all the houses whose list
price is between
45 000
six hundred thousand
or say for example we would want to
filter out the data to something else
say for example let's say i have
i would want to filter out the data
between 300 000 and four hundred
thousand so we can basically
update this
say for example i am saying i am
interested in three hundred
thousand
two
400
000 and that's the criteria to filter
out the data now there are two different
ways or there are two easier ways to do
it one is
i would want to
look at the list price so i can select
this
i can go ahead and do a filter here
and in the list price now this is where
we would want to do the filtering so
it's pretty easy you can click on this
one and then you can go into number
filters and you can choose between now
that's one easier way of doing it so i
could basically select this i could say
i'm looking for value which is greater
than or equal to 300 000
and then is less than or equal to 400
000
so if i just do this
i have applied my filter and i have my
data which is filtered based on my
criteria right so that's one easier way
of doing it or let me do a control
z
now
let the filter be there which you can
anyways use but what we can also do is
as we have seen earlier methods so get a
set or get your column headers here
and then
you are giving two columns here now the
only difference between
my
this set of columns which i have 1 2 3 4
and then you have 7 and 10 columns and
if you see here we have 4
5
6 7 8 9 10 11 right so whenever you want
a and condition you will basically
add the columns where i can give add
condition if it is the same column if it
was a different column then it would be
same number of columns but and
conditions will lie in the same line and
all condition would lie in a different
line now here i can give this value so i
am looking for listed price being
between 300 000 so i am saying it should
be greater than or equal to
300 000 and then i can say less than or
equal to
four hundred thousand now that's my
criteria
and then i need my result here which is
in m
seven
so what i can do is once i have given my
criteria which i'll be using
to filter i can get into data i can go
into advanced
and then i can say copy to another
location so it is selecting my a1 to
j126
criteria range is based on m1 to w2
and then i would want my result from
this particular column
so let's say okay and now you have your
data filtered out in a different
location in the sheet
which has been filtered based on your
and condition so you can filter out the
data in this way or you could just apply
a filter on a column and give the
conditions
now let's solve one more interesting
problem and here we would want to use
excel where we would have an and and
an or condition so say for example this
is the data given to you and the
question is that you would want to find
all the houses in north county again
that's a spelling mistake but then the
north county area with a list price
greater than 300 000
and having three or four bedrooms so the
bedroom
has conditional so it has r three and
four
and then basically you have
list price which is greater than three
hundred thousand now i could have
obviously
selected the columns and then basically
gone for a filter
so i can just do a filtering here
and then i'm looking for list price
being greater than 300 000 so which we
can always give a number filter and i
can say greater than
and then i can say
greater than or equal so i can say
greater than and then i can give three
thousand thirty three hundred thousand
and that's basically the filter which we
would want and
here i would want to select the bedrooms
which should be
just either three or four
so if for example here i go in here and
i unselect this and then i say 3 and 4
right so i am getting my data which is
greater than 300 000 and it should have
the bettering values which will be
either 3 or 4 selected now that's one
way of doing it let's do a ctrl z and
get it back
to as we were or you can even just say
clear filter so you get your data back
as it was so what we can do is we can
hear
give the criteria
so for example i have my
list price now this is what i would want
as a condition
so let's say greater than
300 thousand
three hundred thousand and bedrooms
should be three
and then i can say greater than three
hundred thousand
and then i can say 4
so this one basically gives me
a situation where your list price has to
be greater than 300 000 and bedroom
should be either 3 or 4 so we have given
our filtering criteria
now to get the result what we can do is
we can go into data we can go into
advanced
and we can say copy to another location
so our list range is selected which is
columns a to j
row number 1 to 126
your criteria range is given in m1 to v3
where we have specified and we are
saying the result would be in m7 to v7
so if i do this now i have got the same
data which we were seeing earlier and
here the bedroom values are three or
four
and basically the list price is greater
than 300 000. so this is a simpler way
in which you can create your filters and
all this advanced filtering what we are
seeing it will be saved with your sheet
you can always go back and change this
value or
you could do filtering where one person
has to look into the filter to see what
values have been selected
now that we have looked into
some operations which we can perform in
excel using filter or sorting the data
creating your tables let's also
quickly look at functions and formulas
which can be used
for
doing some easy calculations or
computations now excel can be used in
different kind of data analysis so for
example you have different inbuilt
functions which can be used
and we can always check for a particular
function so for example if i had
if i wanted to look at a particular
function i could just
type in here
something for example is and then it
shows me all the possible functions and
you can always have a look at the detail
of the function for example you have is
even which will return true if the
number is even
if we would say is logical
so i could search for
is logical and that tells me whether a
value is logical value true or false and
returns your value true and false
now we can obviously
say subtotal so you can search for any
of these useful functions and that tells
me what this function can be used for so
returns a subtotal in a list or a
database
you have many other such functions such
as integer sum
average
you may be interested in working on
truncating
some data getting the absolute value
getting the square root
basically getting a count or getting a
max value you can look for any
particular functions within your excel
sheet
now you also have other functions such
as now
or time for example let's look at now
function
so i can search for
now
and here it is
so this is returns the current date and
time formatted as a date and time so
this is the function which we would want
to use
and if i just give the function it tells
me what is the current time
let's first look at the description of
time here so say for example i would
want time it says converts hours minutes
and seconds given as numbers to an excel
serial number formatted with the time
format so for example if i would say
2 hours
and then
30 minutes
and 30 seconds and if i do this it has
basically converted this into your time
format so you can always use different
inbuilt functions for your work now we
will also look at some advanced
functions like sum f or sum ifs
you have count f and countifs
and you can be working on various
functionalities
of excel to
easily help you in doing some
calculations computations working with
your data working with your different
cell values so let's look at some
example of using functions like sum or
sum if
so for that
let's go to this sheet and here we have
some data now i have already applied a
filter which can allow me to filter out
the data so it says find the total units
that were sold in the east region now we
know
that in region we have east
and
i have multiple regions i could
basically be
saying
unselect all and select only east
and say okay and that basically gives me
the units which were sold and if i place
my cursor here
and then if i did a auto sum
so it would basically give me
the function which is being used so
something like subtotal and it is
basically working on
your
rows which is e2 to e44
and here
we can just do this so that gives me the
total but this is
this is
fine you could do that but
it would be good if we know how do we
use a function like sum if to do that so
here i am seeing this is the subtotal
where i am looking at the values and
basically what i have done is i have
filtered out the region
and
then basically i am getting a count but
this does not give me clearly how
a sum was calculated from all the values
which were listed what we can also do is
let's do a control z and let's get it
back
so now we have our data and we would
want to get the total units that were
sold in the east region so what i can do
is i can start typing in my formula
and for that i'll use an inbuilt
function so for example i would be
interested in going for sum if now it
says sum if adds the cells specified by
a given condition or criteria when you
talk about some ifs this is when you
could give set of conditions or multiple
criteria so let's look at some if
let's do this now obviously this gives
me an error because the formula
is not right so we have to basically
come in here and let's start with sum
if now when i say sum if it shows me
there is a function with
sumif which we would want to use
and here
once i open up the bracket it tells me
okay what is the range of data which you
are interested in so i am interested in
all the units that were sold in the east
region so we are interested in the
region
which is here
so
i can basically be
selecting this
and this tells me
you are interested in the data here so
let's not take the header value so let's
say b2
and then we can
go all the way to the end
so we can basically select this way
that's the data we have select this and
hit
enter
so
now here
it has selected b2 to b4 but we need to
basically now give the criteria so the
criteria is either a value or you can
point it to a cell which has that
particular value so as per our problem
statement we are looking for the units
which are sold in east region so i can
select the value east here
and then
my sum if needs the range on which you
want
to calculate a sum so
let's select this and now we are
interested in finding out the sum of
units so that's basically this column e
column so i can basically type in
instead of selecting
so i can say e
and i'm interested in e2 2
e
44 so that basically selects the area
or all the values and now let's do this
so that basically gives me the sum is
691 right now this is the criteria where
i have pointed it to a cell and whatever
value that cell has well i could have
done
something like this so i could have
selected east
giving the value
and then doing it it still does the same
thing and in this way you have more
clarity that you are using some if you
are filtering the data so you have given
the rows
you are given the criteria and then you
have given the range
on which you would want to sum up the
values
now similarly if the question was what
was the total revenue generated from
binder
now
we would want to find out what is the
total revenue generated from binders
that means
my filtering criteria will be binder
and then i want to find out the total
revenue generated so we have the revenue
generated field also here
and we have we don't have any region to
be filtered we are just looking for
binder so let's again start doing the
same thing so we can go for some if we
can open the bracket now it needs the
range so we are interested in
revenue generated now that's the
summation we want and we would want to
get the range of data so here
we can basically select
so that's the data selected now i would
want to give the filtering criteria so
let's say binder
and then we need to give the range on
which the sum needs to be calculated so
that's my
revenue column so that's g
so i can say g
2
to g
44
and that basically selects the column
and then you get your sum so it tells me
what is the total revenue generated from
binder
now i could be doing this for other
things also so say for example if you
would want to filter out something else
you could basically just drag and drop
here and then i could come here and
change this to say
instead of binder i would be interested
in say
pencil
if that's the criteria you're interested
in
remember to change this so that you take
all the values
and here we will change
it to select the relevant rows and then
this is the data i'm getting so i know
that this is
the revenue generated
from pencil this is the revenue
generated from binder now this is a
simple use case where we are using some
if
what if we would want to use some ifs
so some ifs
let's have a look at how we get to some
ifs
so some f says where you would want to
work on
doing some calculation but then
you would want
multiple criterias to be met so let's
see how we get this
so
here what i can do is
let's work on this problem statement
which says what is the total revenue
generated from central
region
where the item is a pencil
so
that's
something which i would want to check
now when we are answering this question
we can also look at the order in which
things have been asked in the question
so it says what is the total revenue
generated from central region so we need
the total revenue generated we know
there is a revenue column
we are interested in getting the total
revenue generated
we are saying
the filtering criteria is central region
and we say in that we would be
interested only in the item if it is
pencil how do i do it so i can use
sumifs where you can pass in multiple
criteria so let's start with
some ifs
and when i start with some ifs let's
open up the bracket so it says sum range
it says criteria range
then it gives one criteria and you can
given any number of criterias so for
example we are interested in total
revenue generated now that's my g column
so let's follow in the same order so
let's say g
2
so that's my first value and then i know
there are 44 rows here so i can say g
44
and you can obviously check
if that has selected all the rows
now
that's my total revenue generated so i
would want the total revenue generated
so i'm saying setting this sum range
then
i need to give the criteria range so it
says from central region so central
region
comes into column 2 that's b
so let's say b
2 to b 44
so that's my criteria range
then you have to give
your criteria but
we need to filter out the region being
central so let's select this now either
i could point to a value in the cell or
i can just
give the exact value here
we can also give a
wildcard or matching pattern so that
also works now this one is fine
we are now also interested in finding
the total revenue generated when the
region is central and the item is pencil
how do we do that so for
item we know the columns the column is
d2
so let's select d2
2
d
44 so that basically selects
all the rows in the d column and we need
to give the
filtering criteria so let's do a comma
and then
just given our value so let's say pencil
and then let's close your bracket and
that basically gives you the result
so
we need to just follow the order of our
question which says
what is the total revenue generated so
we are looking at the revenue column we
are selecting all the rows
then it says
from the central region so we need to
select the region column and give the
filtering criteria as central or point
to a cell which contains that value
and then it says
we would be interested only in item
being pencil so then you select the
column which has all the items
and provide your filtering criteria that
is pencil
so that's your easy calculation of using
sum if which we compare with
sum if here so sum if here was
just
having
your criteria
so basically you are selecting your rows
giving your filtering criteria and then
your sum range in some ifs we are giving
multiple condition now same thing can be
done here it says how many units were
sold by sales representative john's
or jones
where the cost of each item was greater
than four
so how many units were sold
by
sales representative
so when we talk about how many units
that's your e column
so let's start with that so let's say
some ifs
i would be interested in e
column
then let's give the range
so it says sum range so those are the
number of units on which we would want
to find
the sum
then it says you need to give the
criteria range so we say sales
representative where the name is
jones
so sales representative is in sales rep
column c so let's say c2
to c44
now
then we need to give our filtering
criteria so let's say jones
is the sales representative where we are
interested
about whom we are interested in
and then we
the question says where the cost of each
item
so cost of each item is what we are
interested in
you have unit cost
so that's what we are interested in so
that would be f
and then say f2 to f44
and then you need to give
your cost
so it says where each item
is greater than
4
so let's select this
and let's
do this so this tells me three zero one
now
similarly let's answer our third
question which says how many units did
jones sell excluding
pencil item so we would want to find out
what was the total number of unique
units that were sold
and
that
units or that should not include the
pencil item how do we start doing this
so let's start with sum ifs
now we know that you start with some ifs
you need to give the sum range so we are
interested in the number of units
so let's basically go in and select our
number of units which were sold so
that's your column e
so i can say e2 to e44 that's where i
would want to perform this sum
now i'm saying
how many units that were sold where
we are talking about sales rep being
jones so let's see
let's select the columns
c
and then give
the range
after that we need to give our giving
filtering criteria which is jones and
then we are interested in
the items but
excluding pencil so items is in column d
so let's say d
to d 44
and then
we have to give
our
criteria so we can say
well that should exclude
pencil
so i can basically say
pencil
and let's close this
and let's check so that's my formula
which says
that these are the number of units which
the sales representative whose name is
jones had
sold and that does not include pencil as
an item let's also look at an example of
using countif or countifs now both of
these can be very useful when you would
want to calculate certain values
so for example if i would want to work
on count if let's try solving this
problem
now remember you can answer these
questions using filters and that can be
an easier way but then sometimes you may
want to
get the formulas so that you can make
your spreadsheet and your calculation
more
dynamic in nature and that will
basically depend on the values in the
columns or rows so for example if i have
find the total number of times gil has
made a sale now if i look at my data
here it tells me that for every sales
representative there is some value
in the sale and it says sales has
greater than three so for example jones
you have sales greater than three
or
you have jardine which is sales greater
than three and so on so what we are
interested in
is
doing a quick count in finding out the
total number of times gil has made a
sale how do we do that so we can use
this count if function and if i go into
count f it says counts the number of
cells within a range that meet the given
condition now what's our condition our
condition is kill and we would want to
find out how many times the name say
gill appears or kill has made a sale now
i could just say count if and then open
up a bracket i need to give a range so
let's say we are interested in looking
at the range
so let's say
we will choose
sales rep so i can say c
and then i can say c2 to
c44
now
that's my
range
let's not give that in quotes
so you have to give a range so let's do
a count if that selects the data and
then we need to give the condition so
for example let's here give the name
which is gill
and then
close this so that basically tells me it
is five times kill appears here we can
check this so i can go in here i can
add a filter
and then might be i would be interested
interested in looking at only gil
and that basically gives me five
right so we can always do that and we
can be using formulas like this now what
about this question so which basically
says which sales representative made a
sale more than three times now we it
might be looking a little confusing when
i say for example let me clear out this
filter
now we have sales greater than three and
we would want to find out which sales
representative made a sale more than
three times
now i could basically check for every
sales representative here if they have
made a sale more than three times and
what i can do is i can just say equals i
can start with count if
then i need my
filtering criteria so that's your range
so first thing is we will choose for
example let's choose c2
to c
44 and then we need to
give and criteria what is the criteria
we need basically a sales representative
so i can choose the value here
in c2
and then
i can close this and then i can say the
sale has to be greater than 3
and let's check so it tells me the
boolean value that yes
this guy has made sales more than three
times and what we can do is we can just
drag and drop which basically gives me
the value for other sales rep you can
always check the value is automatically
changing to this value in cell
and for example let's go in here so this
is obviously two so it says me false
right and you can basically get the
values for all your values
so that basically tells me which
sales representative has made a sale
more than three times
now like some ifs we also have countifs
where you can give multiple criterias so
for example the question is how many
orders were placed from the east region
after this particular date so we have
a date criteria we also have the region
criteria and we need to basically
get the count of number of orders which
were placed now i can in this case use
count
ifs
and this basically says that you can
start within criteria so it says how
many orders were placed from east region
after
particular date
so date is in my
first column so for example
i could say a
start with 2
and say for example let's go a 44
that should have selected all the rows
and then i need to
once i've given the criteria range i
need to give the criteria so we are
saying
the date has to be greater than
10th feb
so let's give it
2
10
2019
and then you need to say
how many orders were placed so you need
to give the criteria second criteria
range
so we are looking at the number of
orders which were placed
from the east region
so when i would want to look at the
region that's your column b
so i can basically say b2 to b 44
and here
i would basically
give my criteria so the criteria is east
let's give that
and once you have done this you would
want to find out the total number of
orders so let's select this
and if i do this it tells me 13.
now is that right so we are looking for
your date
your region being east and then getting
the total number of orders so here
i can just do a count if
i am saying a2
to a44
wherein i have given the date criteria
that it should be greater than
10th feb because i do not want to count
10 feb it says after 10 february and
then you are saying the region has to be
east
so we would want to find out the total
number of orders so
my region is east and that gives me the
result
now similarly you can also find out how
many times gill
sold pencils so
here we will have to give the range so
let's start with count
ifs now here i would want
that item is pencils so we can as well
select column
d2
d44
then you have to give your criteria so
that's your
pencil
and then we are looking for sales rep
which is kill so
that is my column c
so let's say c 2
2 c
44
and the value should be
just kill
so it tells me
it's twice where gil has sold pencils so
we can obviously check this by
going in here
choosing my filter
and then let's search for rep being just
gill
okay and now we are interested only in
the item being pencil so i can say well
let's get to pencil only and that tells
me twice
so you can obviously re-verify using
filters but using functions or using
formulas
it is always good to calculate and that
can be
making your computation and calculation
more dynamic
let's look at one more interesting
feature of excel and that's your
conditional formatting now as you see on
the screen
conditional formatting has different
rules which can be applied on your data
and that allows you to basically
differentiate or easily identify data
values which
are
based on certain criterias or rules so
when you talk about conditional
formatting you have different options
such as you can highlight cell rules you
can get top and bottom values
you can
apply different rules apply different
color scales and you
you can easily manage these rules
so conditional formatting is very useful
for people who would want to work on
huge amount of data and easily perform
some data analysis
it's easy to use as it is shown here and
with your conditional formatting
you can format cells based on a preset
condition
you can perform conditional formatting
to identify cells
you can highlight a few significant
cells and you can easily perform
conditional formatting
as shown
on the left side
now how do we work with conditional
formatting let's have a quick look
so say for example we have our excel
sheet and if you see here
i am highlighting
the sales person who have generated
revenue greater than 10 000.
so
we can be looking at the values where
the revenue generated by a particular
sales person is greater than 10 000 it
has a particular
color
and how do we get here so for example
let's select
this data
and what i could do is i could go into
conditional formatting now i could
basically highlight cell rules and we
could just say greater than that's an
easier way
i could also go ahead and create a new
rule but then i can use one of this
option i can say greater than
and let's give some value might be we
would be interested in looking at
any value greater than twelve thousand
so let's choose twelve
thousand
and here it says what color would you
want to select so for example
i would say
something like
yellow filled with dark yellow text
and let's say okay
so right now what i'm doing is
i have all the values where the revenue
generator was greater than 10 000
but then i have also selected all the
sales
people who have made or who have
generated revenue greater than twelve
thousand
so i can just wait ctrl z to see the
previous result now here
i had the values which were greater than
ten thousand
and the one which we did just now
basically
highlighted the values which are greater
than twelve thousand so this is one
simple example now we can look at some
other examples
say for example you want to format cells
using three color scale so if you look
at the values here i have a three color
scale mainly in green yellow and red
and how do you do this so for example i
can go in here
and i can go to conditional formatting
so i would want to
go for color scales and here
you can create different rules so
we can set up a two color scale so we
can say format
only values that are above and below
average i can format only cells that
contain something
i can get the top and bottom values so
these are different ways in which
i can
have a three color based scale now what
i will do is i will select this
and let me show you the rule which i
have so for example
i can go into manage rules and if you
see here there are certain rules which
have been specified now what does that
mean so you would want to specify a
three grade scale
so for example if i would want to look
at my first rule
it tells me that i am choosing three
color scale i can choose lowest value
percentile and highest value and that
basically will
select the cells based on their values
so what we could have done is i can
basically
use one of these values i can delete
these rules which i have created
so for example
i have all these rules
but you should always carefully remember
that the rules will be applied in the
order shown so for example if i just
delete these rules
and then say apply and say okay my data
is back now
it does not have any highlighting now i
can go in here
i can say condition sorry conditional
formatting
i could go for color scale so i could
basically
go into
new rule
so i would want
the
cells to be using three color scale so
let's
choose three color scale now when you
say three color scale it says what will
be the color of lowest value
and we could choose might be any one of
this let's choose red
i can say midpoint is percentile 50 and
then the highest value is green and if
that looks good let's say okay and now
if you see the lowest values have been
highlighted as red
you have mid values and then you have
the positive value so this is the three
color scale and that
easily helps me in identifying the data
based on the cell values
now in conditional formatting what you
can also do is you can basically color
the cells based on their value so what
we are seeing here
is if the revenue
generated
is greater than average then that shows
in green and if the revenue generated is
lesser than average that's shows in
orange now how do we do that so we can
basically again manage some rules so i
can basically create a new rule now here
i can select one of the options which
says format only values that are above
or below average and that's the option i
would want to select now i can select
this and it says format values that are
above average
so
in our case we had it in green so for
example i'll say above average and then
here i can go for
a particular color
so
you can go for a particular size
so
let's go and look into
the formatting
so for example let's choose yellow
say okay now i'm saying
wherever
the cell values are above average it
would be yellow instead of green
and let's go in here
let's go and look into manage rules so
this is
basically the rule which we are applying
now we can also add a new rule
and
i need to
select the values so for example i will
say
here so we had gone for above now we'll
go for below
we'll go for format we will choose red
we'll say okay we'll say
now
these are
basically
the rules which we have created and here
it says applies to your data so right
now
it has not been applied so for example
if i select this and then
i could basically
choose my area just hit on enter
and similarly you can go in here
and then select your area
hit on enter and say apply say okay and
now if you see
i have really chosen bright colors but
then i have said wherever my revenue
generated is
above average
it should be in yellow and
below average should be in red so we
wanted above
average to be in green
and below average to be in orange so
that's what we have here right so you
can always
color code your cell values based on
some rules which you are setting up now
similarly you can also
find the top 10 and bottom 10 values and
that's pretty easy so you can just
select this
and then you can go into conditional
formatting you can go for top and bottom
values top 10 items bottom 10 items
or you can go in for more rules so you
can say format only top or bottom ranked
values so you have top 10
now you can choose the color
and for example i'll go for
blue
and
i'll say okay
so now if you see my top 10 values are
blue now similarly i can add one more
rule so i can say new rule and i can say
let's go for top or bottom
let's go for bottom let's go for format
let's say orange
say okay
say okay and that's it so now you have
your values which are top or bottom 10
values
so you are using conditional formatting
where you are
basically highlighting your cell values
based on different colors
and here
easy conditional formatting based on
different rules helps us to do that now
similarly you can also
have the values
which is basically
showing you how the values are
increasing
so what
we can do is we can select our
columns
either you could apply this to all the
columns now here i have applied this
only to jan and april now i could apply
this for june so let's say june so you
can go for gradient fill you can go for
solid fill
you can obviously just select the color
and that takes care of the things
you can say for example select this and
now this is selected but i would want to
might be format this so i can go in here
i can go into manage rules now that will
tell me
what rule has been applied
in the order so i can just do a edit
rule and that basically says this is a
solid fill which is color you have no
border this is basically color as black
now i can go for something like gradient
fill
and i can say okay and now if i say
apply and okay
so this basically is like your first
column so you can use conditional
formatting for various use cases and you
can highlight the values
so anyone who would look at the value
would automatically notice which are the
higher values which are lower values
might be
here the revenue is getting generated or
was getting generated but did not grow
beyond a particular value
and so on
now similarly you can also go in for
different options
say for example here we would want to
see if the revenue was dropping
or if the revenue was
if the revenue decreased
or say for example if the revenue was
going up for this particular salesperson
so here we are looking at carol
so in jan the revenue generation by
sales was very high
then in feb it was falling down
in march it was
kind of stable
then in april it went way below so we
can obviously work
on this wherein we can grade our cell
values so what we can do is we can
go in for
highlighting the cell values now
you can go for color scales you can go
for icon sets and this is where you can
choose your different shapes
so you could choose one of these shapes
so for example
i would be interested in looking at the
indicators like directional i could go
using this three arrows i can go in for
this color i can choose directional and
then
my values are
automatically
using directional now what we can also
do is we can then go into manage rules
and that basically tells me
what rules have been applied
so for example the latest one is the
icon set which i have chosen
it shows the selected columns i can
obviously do a edit rule and then i can
choose so i'm saying the format style is
icon sets
i'm not using a data bar i'm not using
color scale
now here
i have chosen the style of icons
and then here you can basically give
some values so you have icon which is
green
when the value is greater than or equal
to 67 percentage
when i say
hyphen or minus it is less than 67
it's way below 33 percentage
then you give this value so you can
obviously edit and easily
highlight your cell values based on this
icon set so i can apply this and that's
how i use conditional formatting so
conditional formatting can be very
useful
if you would want to use icon set if you
want to use your data bars if you would
want to
highlight particular values
if you would want to color code based on
some calculation
if you would want to
use a three color or a two color scale
or if you would want to just find out
values based on some simple calculation
so conditional formatting is used
extensively by data analysts
or people who are working business
intelligence teams or people who would
want to use excel to easily identify the
data
easily identify the cells which contain
particular value
or finding out less significant or more
significant cells
to then pull out values and carry out
your computations calculations
or analysis
so let's continue learning on using
excel for various things now we have
learnt on conditional formatting and
seen how that can be very helpful
let's learn one more feature of excel
and that's basically your data
validation now this can be very useful
when you would want to work on
validating the data which is being fed
in the cells so you could limit it to
basically a number between a particular
value you could also add some messages
to it
if you would want
or
you could even
circle invalid data or clear validation
circles so data validation really helps
us in validating the data which is being
fed in to particular fields
now it's a feature in excel which is
mainly used to control what a user can
fill in a cell you can decide what type
of values must be entered
you can also
restrict user to enter only valid data
and if any invalid data is entered an
error message will be displayed
now that's where you can use your data
validations so let's see how that can be
done so for data validation let's see
some exercises here so for example you
have a name column and you would want to
restrict
that the name should accept only 15
characters now how do you do that so you
can basically select the cells
or
you can just select a particular cell
and then we can later drag
the property to other fields now here
once the cell is selected so for example
let's try this out and let's see if that
works so for example i will say peter
johnson
okay
and that is basically 5 and 9
and 12 characters so let's say
junior
and if i do this it says
input length is greater than 15 do you
want to continue if i say yes
right so basically
it is allowing me to add the value here
but then it has
basically violated the rule
now this is giving a message to the user
that the user name should be entered
less than 15 characters now how do we do
that
so for this we can basically
select the column and then we can search
for data tab and get into data
validation
so this is where you can create or
select different kind of rules so for
example i can go into data validation i
can go into settings and i can say the
text length
and that should be less than 15 now this
is the maximum i'm giving and it says
apply these changes to all other cells
within the same settings
so i can do this or i can just drag and
drop so i can basically
apply this formula and now you can in
fact randomly check in any particular
cell is the rule applied so it says text
length less than 15. so we can basically
control data validation in this
particular column and that will allow
only 15 characters
it will pop up a message if the user
really wants to go beyond the particular
limit
now you also have similarly date of
birth so the restriction is date of
birth should be between 10 jan 1990 to
30 december 1998.
so this is what we want to restrict how
do we do that so we can select the field
we can click on data validation and if
you see here i have selected date and
then date is between and then obviously
you can give a range
that is 10 jan date
1990
12 30 1998 so that's the start and the
end filter which has been applied
and once this is done you can also check
your input messages which says
when cell is selected show this input
message enter a valid date
so if you see here on the left there is
a pop-up which is coming up which says
enter a valid date now i can also say
when user enters invalid data show this
error alert so i can say stop
i can say invalid entered
and this is how i have set a rule so for
example if i just do
something like this
and that says invalidate entered i can
do a retry it will take me back here but
unless and until
i did not
give the right format the date will not
be accepted and again the same thing
applies to all the cells
similarly email so we are saying the
email should have at the rate present in
the value provided now for this we can
use a formula and we can select well i
would want to apply this rule to
all these rows starting from c2 to c14
so let's get into data validation
let's look in settings and here we are
choosing custom
now within custom i am choosing what is
the formula so i am saying is number
and then i am saying find
at the rate for
the rows c2 to c14 so the only thing we
are concerned about here
is the value should have an email
icon
you can input a particular message you
can say what has to be done for
error alert so for example we can
basically go in here and we can say
invalid email
that's the title i'm giving and we can
say
email
should contain
at the rate
so if i do this and if i say okay now
you can test it so you can say abcd
and that says email should contain at
the rate and basically that will not
allow me to add the values so now you
have the field called salary it says
salary should be greater than 50 000 now
we can limit the values by
choosing
a whole number so for example for salary
i can go into data validation
i can go into settings so here i can say
something like
decimal or i can go for whole number so
both of the things are fine it depends
on what kind of values get into this
particular field so if i say whole
number and if i say it has to be greater
than 50 000
so i'm saying the minimum is 50 000
or i could have given a decimal and then
i can say greater than less than equal
or anything or even between
so i can select it then and then i can
just say okay
now for rank the rule is rank should be
between 100 and 200 so again we can use
a whole number so ranks will generally
not be decimal so this would be whole
number salary
is
can be a whole number or it could be
decimals so we have chosen decimal here
and in rank if you click on data
validation i have chosen whole number
i have set data between 100 and 200
input message nothing error alert
nothing but that depends i can give this
so this is how you can just do a simple
data validation and control the values
which land in the cell okay so now let's
also understand how we can
restrict the values in a particular cell
which might be based on a list of items
now for example here if you see i have
two columns
so one column basically has the values
of city
names and then you have places within
that particular city so if i would want
to
implement a data validation based on
this so for example if you see here city
and that basically shows me
only the four values which can be
entered and if i go to place then it
tells me for maharashtra i can only
enter pune mumbai nasik now how do i do
this
so say for example you take an empty
field and you want to restrict the
values of city names so i could
select data validation i could basically
select list
and then it tells me you need to enter
the list values that is the source so
you click here and then i can just
select these fields now if i do this and
if i say okay
it has implemented a data validation but
if you look into this
it will show me
the same thing but then it shows me some
empty cells
which did not have any value so this is
fine but it would be better if we do it
in a different way so i can select this
and i have already given my city names
here so i can just do a data validation
and here in the source let me get rid of
this
now
i can just
have my cursor here
i can select these values and then if i
say ok so now if you see my city names
have been restricted to these values
and that's how you can implement your
data validation so i have
this data validation here but i will get
rid of this one by just doing a control
z
now i'll come here and say for example i
would want to implement the same data
validation now the easiest way would be
in
doing this for all my four cities now if
you see here i have
data validation i could choose bangalore
and if you come and check here there is
no data validation but we have
implemented data validation here now how
is that done so i could select this or
for example i can go in here i can
select data validation
i can select list
and then here in the source
i will say for bangalore the value
should be these
and then
if i basically say okay
now
if we see these are the values which are
fed into bangalore
so we could do this or like what we have
done here so if you can check the data
validation rule
i have used list and then i have said
indirect
f2 so basically i am giving in a formula
which relates to the value which is in
for the city maharashtra so we could do
this or in a simpler way we could do
this and then just drag and drop here
so we could check for maharashtra what
are the values
let's choose a different city so for
example kolkata and here i will choose
now since we did a drag and drop it has
basically taken the values of bank load
so that's not right so we select this we
go into data validation and here i can
either
feed in the values that is such as
bangalore i could basically say
something like this kolkata
and i could say okay so now if you see
it shows me the places in kolkata
now here
we have let's choose a different city so
for example let's go for delhi and here
i can go to data validation and i can
just say delhi
so this is an easier way of doing it or
if you remember the formula
then what you can do is
you can just give in
indirect
and then basically
give the
value of the cell
for which you would want to
keep in the values so this is how you
can do list validation so you can
provide a list of values and then you
can restrict the values in a cell
which should be
belonging to a particular list so this
is how you do a simple data validation
by restricting the
data in the form of a list
now let's learn about pivot charts and
tables which is one more very useful
feature of excel and which allows you to
work with your data or perform data
analysis
now pivot table is a summary of your
data
it is used in cases where there are
numerous rows and columns in your data
set
and it allows you to group your data in
several ways so that you can derive
meaningful information from it now the
visual representation of a pivot table
is termed as a pivot chart now how do we
do that so let's see an example now here
is some data here you see we have some
row labels which basically gives me some
category of
items here
it also tells me the sum of sales
and basically it gives me per
item what is the total sum of sales
which were made now how do i get this
here
so for example if i would want to delete
this and i would be interested in
getting the
total sales under each category of items
now we know that we have
different data here and it's huge for
example on the
row end if i just do a control and right
arrow it tells me what's my right last
column
and if i just do a control and down
arrow it tells me there are
9994 rows
now i can use this and what i can do is
i can basically work on
insert and go to pivot table now this
basically tells you need to choose the
range now since i have chosen my first
row and first column it basically has
selected the data and that's fine now do
you want the result in a new worksheet
i'll say existing worksheet and i can
choose a location now that basically
needs me to select a field might be we
can just select this field
and that
should be good enough
so
for example if i close this or if i say
okay
so
this is basically an indication that my
pivot table
will be created now what are the fields
we are interested in so as per the
problem we need to find out what the
total sales for each category so let's
go in here and let's select the field
category now as soon as you do that it
shows that the rows
which are
being selected are for this column
category and now we are interested in
getting the sales
so we would want the sales per category
so let's select this so you see sum of
sales is selected now close this and
that's it that's that's your data so it
shows you row labels
it tells you what are the different
categories
and it also gives you
sum of sales which is per category now
this is
one easy example where we have solved
the problem where we have tried to find
what were the total sales under each
category of items so for example let's
have
another data set so
again you can just check how many rows
we have and it is basically the same
9994
and if i look in columns it basically
shows me profit is the last column
and
here
we would want to find out
which category
so for example let me get rid this with
subcategory of items sold the maximum
under each category so
we have some categories here which says
furniture and it shows some sub
categories and then it shows me office
supplies and then some sub categories
and same thing with technology now we
know how we got this data but this is
different than what we were seeing here
so here we were just getting the
categories but but we did not have any
breakdown
of sub categories within this particular
category and here you see there is a
breakdown and then basically you can
also apply a filter which basically says
what is the data you want and if you are
interested in finding out a particular
value now how do we do this so for
example let me get rid of this
now we know how we can find out the
category of items but we would want to
find out which subcategory of items sold
the maximum under each category so here
we are not looking at sales but we are
looking at the quantity
okay so what we can do is we can go to
the first row and first column
click on insert click on pivot table
data is already selected let's choose
existing worksheet let's choose a
location in our worksheet where we would
want to have this so might be i can
select this particular field and then
just close this
so it says this is the existing
worksheet say ok
and now you need to select your columns
so for example
if
i would want the data for categories so
i can select this now i know that within
category these are the options which we
have and then there is a sub category so
let's select that and if you see here
now we have the data which will be
filtered
so based on your category and sub
category and then we will choose
quantity so it automatically understands
that this is something on which
summation can be done so let's select
this and close on this now if you see
here we have got our items
where we can see
the sub categories within a particular
category now i can basically close this
and that just shows me
high level categories here so here
i can again
select a particular
row and column i can go for
either a new pivot table so we could
basically select this the row is already
selected
existing worksheet is what i want so now
i will select
this particular place
say okay now we do the same thing like
what we did earlier
so we will select category sub category
and quantity so the data has already
come in
just select this and now you already
have all your data but this is not what
we want we want to
basically apply a filter
to this now how do we do that so we can
go for
slicer so i can go for insert slicer and
then it tells
what are
the subcategories which you are
interested in
so for example
if i go for something like
subcategory and say okay
so this tells me
what are the categories you are
interested in so for example we know
that furniture has furnishings with the
highest value
so i can select say furnishings
and then
i was interested in office supplies
so within office supply i can basically
search for
here
binder so i can just do a control and
select binder
and then i can also know for technology
i can select phones so i'll say control
and select phones
and now if you see the filter has been
applied
and we have these sub categories which
are selected so we have our data here
now we don't need really this so i can
just delete this and i have my data
which shows me
furniture being the main category and
that has only furnishings office supply
having binders and technology having
phones and that basically
is a filter applied on the result of
your pivot so this is how we are seeing
which sub category of items
were sold
maximum for each category
so this is how you can easily use pivot
tables and you can do some analysis
let's look at some more examples
now
let's see if you have to answer this
question which says which were the top
three states for each region
that made the highest average profit
now how do we calculate that
so for example this is the data we have
and as i have instructed earlier you can
select the first row and first column
you can click on insert go into pivot
table
and that basically selects all your data
we will choose the result should be in
this existing worksheet so select this
click here
and then basically
let's select
this cell
and
i will say okay so now my pivot table
will be here so we are interested in
finding out top three states within each
region which have made the highest
profit or which have made the highest
average profit so for that first we will
select
region so when we select region it shows
here region and within region you will
then select state
so
within every region you have multiple
states so that's what we are selecting
and then we are interested in looking at
the profit so let's select profit and
that automatically shows up here
so we can now say close this
so basically we have all the data but we
are looking at the sum of profit but
that's not what we want
we are looking for
top three states
from each region that made the highest
average profit
now how do we change that so here we
have sum of profit so i can do a right
click and basically i can say summarize
values by average so now i'm getting the
average here and that basically tells
per region
i have the average profit
but first is let's sort this data so
let's go into sort more options and here
i have average of profit
or for example as i said you can select
region say okay
and now it is basically having the
regions
and then you have your state value so
again we can do a sorting here and i can
say
let's go for more sort options i'll say
descending
the state values should be based on
average profit
so let's say okay and now if you see
in particular region we have the data
which has been
sorted
wherein you have the highest average
profit on the top
now what we can also do is we can
basically
then go for filtering we can say top 10
but i am not interested in top 10 so i
could reduce this to top three
and this is the items average of profit
say okay and now you see per region
you have
the data which is
showing me top three states what are the
average
and then you are also looking at the
subtotal so which basically says average
profit for your west now if you would
want to arrange this
your west and south and east and central
in a particular alphabetical order if
you would want to sort it you can always
do a sorting and you can choose sort z
to a
if that's what you would want to do or
you can go for
sorting
more sort options
and you want to
sort the region which is as of now based
on descending z to a let's make it
ascending say okay and now you see the
data has been filtered so it says per
region
now you can always select this and you
can say what is this so this is
basically your average of profit
now
we are looking at
each region and the states the top three
states as we wanted
within the region and what is the
average
now we have one more question what is
the percentage contribution of each sub
category of products under each category
to the total sales so we know there are
different products
there are different categories and
all the categories contribute to the
total sales so we would want to find out
what is the percentage contribution of
each sub category
of products under each category so we
not only want the
category percentage but we would also
want what is the contribution of each
sub category
to
each category to the total sales how do
we do that so for that we need to again
just place
our cursor here or select the first row
and first column
click on your insert click on your pivot
table and now the data is already
selected existing worksheet
place your cursor here
and then let's select this
cell say okay
now your pivot table fields are here so
we are interested in category
so let's select category
and then within a category we will have
sub categories and we are interested in
the sales data
wherein it is already going to give us
the sum of sales but we would want this
in the form of percentage rather than
just the sum now we can click here value
field settings and it says if you would
want to summarize this it says show
value as and
what are the values you would want so
you can straight away go ahead here and
say percentage of grand total so we
could do that because we know
we will get a sum of sales and grand
total now i could basically say in the
percentage of grand total say okay
and then
just close this
so once you have closed this you see
already the data is in
percentage
so now we have our data with sub
categories but we also want the data to
be sorted might be in a descending order
which tells which sub category is
contributing more than others we can
select how many sub categories we are
interested in so we can basically select
one of the sub category cells right
click now you have option
filter
and you have sorting so we can say more
sort options
now here i will say descending and
you want the descending to be sum of
sales which is already showing as
percentage
click on ok and now you see for each
category
it shows the percentage contribution
towards the sales
it shows the sub categories contribution
to a particular category and also to
total sales
so technically speaking if you look at
all these values which are sub
categories and if you would total them
that would be your total grand total so
this is how we can solve a simple
problem like this what is the percentage
contribution of each subcategory of
products under
each category to the total sales
the next question is which customer made
the lowest profit in the home office
segment in each state now here we know
that we are looking for
home office segment
we are looking for customer which made
the lowest profit
we are also looking for the state
as the main
criteria so
in each state
we would look for home office segment
and within that we would look for
customer which has made the lowest
profit that means
the lowest value of the profit so how do
we do this so let's say let's get into
selecting our row and column we will go
into insert i'll say pivot table
i'll say existing worksheet and let me
get my result here so let's say okay now
that gives me the pivot table so the
first thing is we are looking at
per
state
and
i would be interested in
home office segment or i could first
start with segment
now here we have segment
and in segment i can basically select
home office so i can just do a uncheck
and select home office only
and now i can select
state
so that will be my
sub category within segment
and then within state
we would want to find out the customer
so let's get the customer name
and we are interested in finding out the
lowest profit so let's select profit
and here we have sum of profits so the
fields are selected close this
and now you have your data
which basically shows me
the names of customers which made the
profit but it's
it's not sorted so we can sort this
and we have state entries also so that's
fine so what i can do is here
i can basically say sorting go to more
sort options i can say i want to do it
descending or i want to do an ascending
and ascending based on
sum of profit so let's do that now you
see
the topmost value is the lowest value
per state
within home office segment now what we
also want is we just want one value per
state
so how do we do that so we can just
go for filtering go for top 10 values
i'm interested in bottom value and in
that also
i'm looking for only the
lowest value so let's select one
say okay and now you see we have data
for home office segment
per state
customer who has made the lowest profit
so we have easily answered this question
using our pivot table
now say for example we have a question
which says find the sales made in each
quarter of 2016 for all the regions
so the data has to be divided quarterly
and use order year as a slicer we can do
that by selecting what data we would
want to slice and then we would want to
create a pivot chart also so for example
how do we do that
so for example
i will get rid of this
i will get rid of
this my pivot chart which we can
recreate
so find the sales made in each quarter
of 2016 for all the regions
so this is what we want now how do we do
this
so for example let's select this
we will do a insert pivot table we will
basically say existing worksheet
and then i can select this particular
cell i'll say okay
and now
i'm interested in data quarterly so
first let's select
our field here so we should basically
have
if all our fields are selected say for
example if i say order date
now
you see we have quarters and years which
are selected now we could be selecting
these fields which says
quarters years
and if i would want data to be filtered
based on years i could do that or i
could get rid of here so i have quarters
i have order date
so
that's being already selected now what
else we need we need to find out
for every region so let's select the
region
and we can also add region as a column
here so that will basically give me all
the regions
as different columns and then finally we
want the sales so let's select this
and now let's look what we have
so if you see here
we have our data
which is
for each quarter
it gives me the total data but what we
would be interested in is not looking at
the total data but we are only
interested in quarter of
2016. now how do we do that so what we
do here is we have row labels
so let's click on this so we have date
filters
and then in date filters we can go for
between and then we will say
2016
and the value has to be 1
and then let's select this
and let's change this to 2016
and
this is 12th month
and then we can say 31
so we are saying the date has to be 2016
and it basically says not a valid date
so let's select
let's select a particular date and see
so the month has to be here
so let's see in this
and let's make it date
and say okay
and now we have our data which is
for
2016.
so for example i could basically select
this
and here i could be
looking at
what are the filters we have so it says
clear filter from order data so we have
applied the filter on order date
and
these are your date filters which is
basically
date
16 oh this is wrong so this one has to
be changed to 2016.
so select this and now we have our data
for
2016.
so we have found the sales made in each
quarter of 2016 for all the regions the
grand total
for a particular quarter if we are
looking at the value
or for individual months in a particular
quarter
and we have sliced the data now we could
have also
introduced a slicer by
selecting
which field we would want to implement
so for example if i would select a
particular field and then i could click
on slicer
i could choose i would want to slice the
date based on order date and then could
have done it or we have just given the
date for 2016. now we just need to plot
a graph for this and that's very easy so
you just need to select
the complete pivot data and here you
have the chart options so let's go for
line chart
and that basically shows me the line
chart so we can select this
we can just drag and drop it here
and then
we can basically check if that is
showing us the data so if you see here
this is line chart where it has divided
the regions in different colors
so we have all the regions we could
filter out in pivot chart a particular
region
we have
the quarterly
time here in order data the filter is
applied it says it is 2016.
in quarters it tells me it is 16. so we
have our data we have created a pivot
chart and basically we have sliced the
data for
2016.
let's answer one more question and
that's finding the profit made in each
year
for all the categories of products
in east and west regions only and then
we would want to create a histogram
for the same pivot table so histogram
usually gives us the frequencies so
let's look at how do we calculate the
profit made in each year for all the
categories so what i can do is
i can basically
select my
row id here and now i'll do a pivot
table
so the data is already selected i'll
choose existing worksheet let's select
this particular cell say okay
now what are we interested in now if you
look at the fields we don't see any
years or quarters and so on so for
example here i can just choose order
date
and then basically
i can choose say for example
years or quarters
the data which is coming out from my
order date so here i will just select
years
now
then i have my order date
so
we are interested in the years orders
and
we are interested in
let's look at our column or the question
what we had here
so we have years
find the profit made in each year so
let's select
profit so that basically says sum of
profit but then
i'm also interested in
for all the categories of products so
what i can do is here
i have my field which is category and
that i'll add to the columns so that
shows me what are the different
categories
and this looks fine now i'm also
interested in east and west regions so
that is basically in the region so
either we could add a slicer or we could
do a filtering here by adding the
filters so first is i'll click on region
and here it says select all i'm only
interested in east and west
so let's select this
take this
put it here
let's say okay and now we have the data
which has been filtered
based on the region so here we have
region so you can always look at the
filter it is east and west
and we have
our year data
per year we have
different categories you can always look
at what are these column labels so this
is my different categories
and this is the profit per category
and then you have your grand total so we
have already our data now let's say
close this
so we have our data for all these years
different categories the profits made
per year
and if i would want i could go into an
ear and i could look into different
months so that also
is showing up and now we would want to
basically plot a histogram with this
data so i can just
place my cursor here i can select this
and then i can go into insert and here i
have different options so we can go for
bar chart
we can go for insert hierarchy chart
we can go into waterfall funnel stock
surface or radar chart so there are
different options what you have here and
we will go for a simple histogram which
is two dimensional
let's select this
and here you see you can obviously
select different regions
you have your years which shows up
you have your order date
and then you have your categories which
can be chosen for your histogram or for
your bar chart and that basically is how
you use your pivot table you use some
calculations and then you can plot your
needed graph to visualize the data and
understand it in a better way so what is
excel power query
power query is an advanced feature of
microsoft excel that allows you to
prepare your data for analysis
you can perform numerous text
computations and numerical analysis to
make your data more powerful and
informative
excel power query is a data preparation
and transformation engine
it allows you to carry out the extract
transform and load operations on the
data sets from multiple sources
now
let's look at the challenges solved by
power query
earlier in excel there was difficulty in
data connections
now using power query you can connect to
a broad range of data sources such as
relational databases web files text csv
json files and even fetch data in the
cloud
volume variety and velocity are the
characteristics that define big data it
was a major problem to handle such data
now power query enables you to transform
your data to an appropriate size it also
allows you to work on any shape of data
from any source
earlier updating your data and
refreshing it in real time was an issue
using power query a repeatable process
query is adopted to update the data in
real time and in the future
in excel
it was not so easy to reshape transform
and manipulate data
but using power query provides a highly
interactive experience and sophisticated
tools to prepare your data now
from excel 2016 onwards power query on
windows has been fully integrated into
excel
but in excel 2010 and 2013 for windows
power query is a free add-in
you can go ahead and download the link
once installed the power query tab will
be visible in the excel ribbon now
coming to the
features of power query so excel power
query allows you to clean transform
manipulate and process your data for
analysis it helps you to automate
repetitive tasks that you want to do it
over and over again you can search for
data sources and make connections as and
when you want power query helps you to
prepare and shape the data in the right
format for performing analysis
and finally
once your data is ready you can share
your findings or use your query to
create interactive reports and
dashboards
now let's have a glance at the demo that
we are going to work on in this video
so we look at how to load data from
different sources
you will understand how to extract
tables from web files so we'll extract
tables present on wikipedia pages
then you learn how to sort and filter
data
up next you'll see how to group your
data how to split a column into multiple
columns
and then pivot and unpivot your
table
then you are going to work on date
columns and make some transformations
understand how to append tables and
merge tables vertically and horizontally
now let's open ms excel and start with
importing a simple text file so you can
see here i have my excel file opened
and in the middle you can see i have my
employ txt file
now this is a comma separated file
meaning that the values are separated by
commas as you can see it here
the columns have been separated by
commas and all the values have a comma
between them
now
this
text file has information about
the name age company and the city to
which the employee belongs to
let's see how easily you can import this
emp text file into ms excel
here
i am using
excel 365 or office 365 where power
query on windows has been fully
integrated into this version of excel
so what i'll do is first
let's go to the data tab
and
you have this section called get and
transform data so i'll click on get data
under get data i'll go to from file
and select
from text slash csv
once i click on it it will ask me to
give the location where the file is
there
so my file is on desktop i'll click on
power query files and here you can see i
have my employee txt file
you can see the type here it says text
document
click on emp
and hit import
now this will take some time to import
the file onto excel
it's establishing a connection you can
see
there you go
so here you can see the filename emp.txt
you can see the file origin
as i said the delimiter is comma and we
have the data type detection
and here you can see
we have our text file
so excel power query feature has
automatically detected the column names
so we have name
age company and city as our columns and
these are the values
now let's hit load
so this will load all the rows and the
columns onto excel
there you go it was really quick
excel has automatically loaded our text
file
now you can see here we have another tab
called queries and connections so we
have made one query and have loaded
the employee data
it gives a preview also you can see it
here
and if needed later you can go to edit
and change some values that we'll see
later
now you can use this data to create
simple visualizations
so let me show you how to do it
so let's first select the data and
we'll go to the insert tab
under insert tab i'll click on
recommended charts
let's say
i want to know how many employees belong
to a particular city
so i'll click on the second chart which
says the count of name by city and i'll
click on ok
here you can see
we have a nice clustered bar chart
and you can see
in bangalore there were
five employees in hyderabad we had two
and in nasik we had one
you can see the count here this is a
pivot table
if we go back to our actual data here
you can see
in bangalore we had vidya
[Music]
and there were
two more people from hyderabad and one
from nasik
so you can use the excel power query
feature to import data onto excel and
make some visualizations
now
if you want to fetch some data that is
present on the web or on the internet
excel power query features and
functionalities can help you import
those data as well
we will now see how to import data
specifically a table that is present on
the web
here i'll be using a wikipedia article
on the list of european cup and ufo
champions league finals let me show you
the page first
so this is my wikipedia page on the list
of european cup and ufo champions league
finals
if i scroll down you can see all the
details here
and i would like to import
this table
which has the list of
all the finals so we have columns like
season
winners score line runner sub venue and
attendance
let's import this table on to excel
so i'll copy this url first
now let me open a new sheet i'll go to
sheet1
and then on the data tab
under the get data section
i'll go to from other sources and here i
have from web which allows me to import
data from the web either you can follow
this path or
if you see here
there's an option to get data from the
web if i click on
this it is asking me to enter the url so
i'll paste the url of the wikipedia page
here
and let's click on ok
now it's navigating and
okay
you can see
power query feature in excel has given
us a list of tables which you can see
here
we have something called as document
there's a key table and here you can see
there's one table which is extracted
from the wikipedia page
and the table which i am interested in
is this table which has the list of
european cup
finals
you can see it here
excel power query feature has
automatically detected
these rows and it has given a
list of columns as well you can see
these are the columns
now we'll explore the transform data tab
present in the power query
now if i click on transform data it will
take me to the power query editor
let me just
click on refresh
now this is the most important section
using the power query editor
you can clean your data filter your data
manipulate your data
and make it ready for analysis
now let's explore a few tabs available
here so we have a home tab that has
a query section
you can see you can reduce rows manage
columns sort the data transform the data
combine different tables
now there's another tab called transform
which allows you to select your data
type transpose your rows and columns
pivot and unpivot your columns
and here you can see
you can find out some summary statistics
and you can manage your date values as
well
now if you want to add some new columns
to your data you can do that as well and
you also have a view tab
now here
if you see the first two rows
the values are the same you can see
season season these are all repeated
which we actually don't need
and these are pretty similar to our
column names
similarly if i scroll down
you see there are some
rows
which have null values
so actually these
rows do not add up any value or do not
add any value to our data so we'll clean
this data first
so let's see how to do it
now if you want to remove certain rows
in the table
what you can do is
go to the home tab
and under reduce rows click on remove
rows
and then choose
remove top rows
if i select remove top rows it will ask
me how many rows do you want to remove
from the top you can see it here
i'll give i want to remove the top two
rows
now let's click on ok
you will see
that
the excel power query editor has removed
the first two rows and on the right you
can see the steps that were applied
you can see it here
previously we had these two
rows which were redundant
and once we applied the step
it has removed the first two rows
similarly
let's go down and remove the last
one two three four five so we are going
to remove the last
seven rows from the table
so again
i'll go to reduce rows and click on
remove rows now this time i'll select
remove bottom rows
and here i'll choose
i want to delete seven rows from the
table
from the bottom
i click on ok
if you see
the last seven rows have been deleted
now let me show you the last row which
is this one
so the last season of
ufo champions league was held in 2020
which is this year
and bayern munich won the champions
league against
a french team that was paris
saint-germain's by a score of 1-0
now if you see the last value that is
the attendance
you can see the value is zero which
means there were no spectators in the
stadium it was because of the covet
conditions
now let's do some more manipulation to
our data
suppose this time i want to add a new
column let's say a stadium name by
extracting values from the venue column
so let me just show you the venue column
so this is our venue column
so the first value
is the stadium name
then we have the city in which the
stadium is there
and finally we have
the country name
so i want to extract only the stadium
name so you can see we have some
stadiums like santiago bernabeu
there's wembley san siro
and other stadiums so i want to extract
only the stadium names
so let's see how to do that
i'll click on the venue column and go to
add column tab
under add column here you can see we
have
extract
if i click on this drop down there is an
option to select
text before delimiter
so if i choose text before delimiter
here
i'll give my delimiter as
comma
so everything before the first comma
will be considered as the stadium name
now let me click on ok
now here you can see under applied steps
it says inserted
text before delimiter if i scroll to the
right you can see the last column
has a stadium names
let me double click on this and change
this to
stadium name column
and hit enter even this step is applied
here you can see renamed columns
similarly
let's explore a few more features
now i want to add a new column called
stadium city
so
if you consider this venue column
whatever is there between the two commas
is the stadium city
so for example santiago bernabau is in
madrid similarly
wembley stadium is in london
san siro is in milan
so these middle values i want to extract
into a new column called as stadium city
so let's see how to do it
so i'll click on the venue column
and go to extract
and again
i'll select
the extract tab
and here now i'll choose
text between delimiters
and my first delimiter i'll give is a
comma
and a space you can see here
all the values
have a comma and a space
and my end delimiter will be another
comma
then i'll click on ok
this will add a new column
to the extreme right of the table you
can see here we have text between
delimiters
and it has extracted the stadium city
let me go ahead and
rename this
column as stadium
city
and hit enter
you can see the applied step here
now
i want to split the score column into
two columns so here we have the score
column
and
the left value presents the number of
goals that were scored by the winning
team
and the right value
presents the number of
goals that were scored by the losing
team
so here i'll split the column into two
columns as winner score and loser score
so what i'll do is
select this column and go to the home
tab
under the home tab we have
split column
i'll select split column
and then choose
by delimiter
so automatically excel power query
detects that this dash is my delimiter
and i'll split at each occurrence of the
delimiter
let's click on ok
now you can see
the score column has been split into two
it has renamed the column as score dot
one and score dot two
what i'll do is i'll go ahead and
we'll rename this column as winner score
and this will
rename it to
loser score
i'll hit enter
and i have renamed it successfully
next
let's change the winners team and the
runner sub team values to uppercase
so suppose
i want to change all the values or the
club names of the winners team to upper
case so what i can do is
i'll select this column and go to the
transform tab
under transform tab i have this option
called
format
so here i'll click on format and then
you can see
i can change the case to lowercase
uppercase capitalize each word
so here i want to make all the winner
teams as uppercase i'll select upper
case
there you go
we have successfully converted all the
winner team names to upper case
similarly let's do it for the runner sub
team as well
so here i have my runnersup team
i'll go to the transform tab
click on format
and select uppercase
now we saw
how to do some simple
manipulation of our data so we created a
few columns split a few columns
now to save all this i have to go to the
home tab and then click on
close and load
this will take some time and load our
data onto this excel sheet
you can see here it's loading the data
this will take a bit of time
there you go
excel power query feature has
successfully
perform some manipulations on our data
some calculations on our data and then
it has
saved the final version
and loaded it on to excel now using this
clean data
we can do some analysis
let's say i want to find the seasons in
which the winners team scored more than
three goals so we have a problem
statement at hand we want to find the
seasons in which
the winner team had more than three
goals scored
so what you can do is select any
cell in this data and go to the insert
tab
and click on
pivot table
here i'll click on existing worksheet
and then
i'll give my location
i'll place my pivot table somewhere here
and click on ok
all right
now
since i want to know the seasons i'll
drag season on to row
and i'll also drag
the winners team
column onto rows
then i'll choose my winner score under
values
here you can see we have the pivot table
ready
now we need to filter this table to see
all the winning teams that scored more
than three goals so what i'll do is
i'll select this winner score column and
place it under filters
and here you can see i have my filter
let me click on this drop down
and i'll select multiple items
from this multiple items i'll choose
4 5 and 7 because these values are
greater than 3
and click on ok here you can see i have
filtered my pivot table and
to the left you can see the season
and the winner team
that had scored more than three goals in
the finals
all right similarly
you can perform some more analysis
suppose
i want to know how many times real
madrid won the championship so let's see
i'll click on one cell in the data set
go to the insert tab and click on pivot
table
i'll choose existing worksheet and give
my location here
let's say i want to place my port table
here
i'll click on ok
all right so the question we have is how
many times have real madrid won the
championship
so i'll choose
the winner steam column and place it
under
rows
and
let's say
we'll select the winner score as well
and let's convert this winner score from
sum
to let's say count and click on ok
and
since i want to check only for
real madrid
so what i'll do is i'll go to
the insert tab
and i'll insert a slicer
here i'll choose
winner teams as my slicer and click on
ok
and out of this
i want to choose only
real madrid so i'll select real madrid
you can see it here
real madrid have won the championship 13
times
ok
let's say you want to compress your data
and remove unnecessary columns without
losing any information you can do that
using a feature in the power query
editor called unpivot to perform this
task we'll use a census data of india
from wikipedia so let me first show you
the wikipedia page
so this is my wikipedia article which
says list of states in india by past
population
and if i scroll down
you can see it here there's a table
which says by past population from 1947
to 2011.
so there are a few columns like rank
this state or union territory and we
have population starting from 1951
till 2011 which was our last census
here you can see if i scroll further
there are
nearly 29 states and we have
seven union territories so we will
extract this table and load into excel
first
okay so let me click on a new sheet
and we'll follow the same drill i'll go
to my data tab
and click on get data
under get data i'll go to from other
sources and click on from web
here it will ask me to provide the url
link of the wikipedia page so i'll paste
the url here
and click on ok
now once i have done that
it will load a few tables
onto excel you can see there are a few
tables here i'll click on the first one
so we have
our table here
now let's do some transformation to this
data
this opens in the power query editor
okay i'll click on refresh first
this will take some time to refresh the
entire data okay we are done now if you
see this data
clearly
the first
row in this table is not necessary at
all because these are our column names
so we also have our column headers
already present
so let's go ahead and delete the first
row so we'll go to the home tab under
remove rows i'll click on remove top
rows
now i'll give my
number of rows as one so we want to
remove the first row only i'll click on
ok
you can see the first row has been
deleted
if i scroll further
i actually don't need the last row as
well which is the total
so what we can do is we can also remove
the last row from the bottom
so i'll
select one click on ok
you can see the step has been applied
and
you don't see the last row that was the
total row anymore
so the task that i want to do here is
i want to compress
all these columns which are basically
the population columns
so i'll
select my
state or union territory column
and
go to the transform tab and here i have
the option to unpivot columns so i'll
click on this drop down and select
unpivot other columns
you can see here the step has been
applied
and
all the population column from 1951 till
2011 have been unpivoted
if you want you can go ahead and
rename these columns let's see i'll
write it as population column
and
let's say this is
i'll rename it to total population value
all right
now we are done with our
preparation of data let's go to the home
tab and click on close and load
now this will take some time to load the
data onto excel
all right so we have
our census data here so first you can
see
rank one is uttar pradesh and we have
the population starting from 1951 till
2011
then we have for maharashtra
if i scroll down you can see the other
states we have tamil nadu rajasthan this
karnataka if i scroll further
we have odisha this telangana kerala now
if you see here
the population values from 1951 till
2011 for the telangana state are all n a
which means there was no data available
now this is because telangana was only
formed in 2014 so there was no senses
for this state
let's continue with our demo and let's
explore a few more
features and functionalities of our
query editor
now the next table we are going to use
is an adventure works customer table now
this data set is provided by microsoft
for practitioners who want to learn
power bi excel or similar technologies
and want to do some manipulation some
calculation some data analysis stuff
so let me go to a new sheet and let's
import
the adventure works customer data set
it's a csv file onto excel first
so i'll go to my data tab
and click on get data from here i'll go
to
from file and choose
from text slash csv
you can see it here in my power query
files folder i have my
adventure works customer table
i'll select this and click on import
this will take some time to load the
data set
you can see the preview of the data set
here so we have
columns like the customer key we have
the prefix of the customer name the
first name the last name of the customer
date of birth
marital status
if i go to the right we have annual
income total children education level
occupation and homeowner column as well
so let's click on transform data
here we'll learn a few more
features of power query
okay we have our data on our power query
editor
so first what i'll show you is
let's change the prefix column the first
name column and the last name column to
proper case
so you can see it here the prefix first
name and last name columns are all
in upper case
now if you want to change the values to
proper case
just
hit control and select the three columns
and
go to the transform tab
under transform tab you have format
so click on format here you can see we
have lowercase uppercase now proper case
is to capitalize each word so i'll click
on capitalize each word
you can see it here now
we have converted the prefix first name
and last name column
into prop case
the next step i'm going to show you is
let's merge all the three columns the
prefix column the first name column and
the last name column into one full name
column
so
what i'll do is i'll select the three
columns
and then let's go to add column and
under add column we have this option
called
merge columns
let's hit merge columns
ok
now it's asking you to give the
separator i'll select my separator as a
space
and click on ok
ok so before click on ok i want to
change my
new column name from merged to let's say
full name
and now let's click on ok
you can see here it says inserted merged
column and if i go to my
right
you can see it here we have a full name
column now if you want
to shift the location of the full name
column you can do that as well
just
hold this and
keep on dragging to the left
this will move the entire
table to the right and you can place it
wherever you want so i want to place it
let's say here
okay
now actually i don't want all these
columns so let's delete it
so click on this and
i'll right click
and click on remove
you can see we have removed the prefix
column similarly let's remove the
other two columns you can either right
click and do or go to the home tab
and then select remove columns
all right
now
let's say we want to add a domain name
column from aws customers by extracting
the characters between at the rate and
dot com
so actually i am talking about the email
address
from this email address we want to
create a new column called as domain
name for that we'll extract characters
that are present between at the rate and
dot com
so let's see how to do it
i'll select the email address column
and then i'll go to add column
under add column i'll click on extract
and this time we want to extract
between two delimiters and so i'll
select
text between delimiters and i'll give my
starting delimiter as
add the rate
and
my end delimiter would be dot com
now let's click on ok
so this will
insert a new column to the extreme right
you can see we have our domain name
let's go ahead and
change the column name to domain name
and hit enter
all right
you can see the step has been applied
now we are done with
our preparation of customers table let's
just go to the home tab and click on
close and load
so all the transformation that we did in
the power query editor
will reflect here so you can see we have
our full name column
and if you see
we have our domain name as well
okay
now using the power query editor you can
perform some
statistical analysis
now let's explore those statistical
features
for this we'll be using another data set
called adventure box product data set
again this data set is also provided by
microsoft
so let's go to the new sheet and here
i'll go to the data tab
click on get data
under from files i click on text slash
csv
here you can see we have
adventure works products i click on
import
let's click on transform data
so we have our data
loaded onto the power query editor
the data is mostly clean so let's not
alter this data let's straight away go
ahead and explore some of the
statistical features that we have here
now let's say
if you want to find the total number of
product names in the product table
we have this product name column and say
if you want to find the total number of
product names in the table
how to do it
so what you can do is click on this
product name column then go to the
transform tab
now in the transform tab you have an
option called statistics
click on this drop down and select count
values
now this will open another window
that will return the total number of
products in the table you can see the
value here it says 293
now to move back to the query editor we
have to cancel this step here so let's
just click cancel or close
we are back again
all right
now let's say you want to calculate the
average product price from the product
table
so if i move to the right
you have a column called product
price so let's see what is the average
product price from the product table so
i'll select this product price column go
to the transform tab
under statistics i'll select average
so this will give me the average product
price which is
714.4373
you can consider any unit you want let's
say this is in dollars
now again we have to cancel this step to
move back
okay
now if you want to find the maximum
minimum product price you can do that as
well
so
let me select my column
product price and go to the transform
tab
under the transform tab
we'll click on this statistic drop down
and let's say i'll select minimum so
this will give me the minimum product
price which is 2.29
similarly
if you want to find the maximum product
price so select this product price
column go to the transform tab
and then choose maximum
so this is the maximum product price in
the product table we have
let's cancel this step
okay
now you can also round the product cost
and product price column to two decimal
places so if i show you both the columns
you have your product cost
and you have the product price column
you can see the floating values of the
decimal points are not constant it's
varying
so let's limit it to two decimal places
what you can do is
select both the columns and then go to
the transform tab
in the transform tab you have here
rounding
i click on this drop down and select
round
now here i'll give my decimal places as
2.
if i click on ok
you can see here
both the columns the product cost and
the product price column have been
rounded up to 2 decimal places
i can scroll down you can see
all the values have been rounded up to
two decimal places
all right
now
let's say you want to add a column
called discount price column
by multiplying 0.9 to the product price
column
and let's say you also want to round
that new column to two decimal places so
how to do it
so we want to give a discount of
10 percent so i'll select this product
price column
go to add column
and then i'll choose custom column
here we'll write a formula
so i'll give my new column name as
discount price
and
my formula would be
i'll select product price
i'll click on insert
and then i'll multiply this product
price by
0.9
so this will give me my 10 discount
on the product price and click on ok
you see here we have a new column added
which is discount price
so
the product price is
34.99 if you give a 10 discount
it's 31.491
all right
now the next question was to change the
or round the decimal places to two
so i'll go to the transform tab under
rounding and click on round
let's say i'll give two and click on ok
so even this has rounded the discount
price column to 2 decimal places
now we are done with our mathematical
operation on this product data set
so we saw how to find
some average count how to round up
values how to add a new custom column
so let's go ahead and
close it
and load it on to excel
you see here we have our
new product table
added here and
the last column if you see it's the
discount column that we added
okay now it's time for us to explore
another feature
so we'll use a table called adventure
works calendar table which has basically
a date column
and let's see
how using power query you can prepare
that data as well and make some
manipulation some calculations
so let me go ahead and import adventure
works calendars table again this data
set is provided by microsoft
so i'll
go to my new sheet
and i'll go to the data tab click on get
data and from here i'll click on from
text slash csv
and you can see i have my calendar table
here i click on import
now this will open in the query editor
you see here this data set has only one
column which is a date column
so let's click on
transform data
okay
now if you see here
the first row is actually the column
name
so
let's
do the transformation here let's push
this as the column name so i'll go to
the home tab
and under home tab you have this option
called use first row as headers i'll
select this
you see here we have the column name as
date
now
before making any
operation let's see
if all the fields are available
you see here if i click on
the date drop down
year month quarter weekday day
everything has been
shaded out and i can't access this the
reason is
the date settings are not correct
so we change the regional settings let
me show you how to do it
so we'll go to file
and i'll select
options and settings and go to query
options
under query options
we have something called as regional
settings
here
under regional settings we'll select
english united states instead of english
india
so i'll just scroll down
and
here we have english united states
and i click on ok
now once this is done
i'll go to my data type and i'll select
date as my data type
i'll choose replace current
okay
now you can see
my date column has been formatted if i
go to the date tab you can see i have
access to all this
now let's do some
operations on this date column
let's say you want to
find the earliest and the latest date
from aw calendars table or the adventure
box calendar table
so what you can do is select this column
go to
date drop down under transform and here
we have the option of earliest and
latest so if i click on earliest
this will show you the last date which
was 1st of january 2015.
let me close this
similarly you can see the most recent
date
i'll go to the date drop down and click
on latest
and you have
30
june 2017 as the latest date
i'll close this
now let's add a new column say the name
start of the week and others
so i'll select my date column
go to
add column
here under add column i have
my option to
select the day name the week name and
others so i'll click on this date drop
down
and under day
let's say i want to choose
name of d
this returns the d name
similarly
let's say
i want to find out
the start of the week
you can see we have the
start of the week column or start of
week column
now one thing to notice here is
in this power query editor the week
starts on a sunday
now suppose you want to start your week
on a monday you can do some
transformations on this formula tab
so here in the formula bar you can add
a 1 here to make sure your
week starts on a monday so if i hit
enter you will see all these
values will change you can see it's 28 4
and 11 this will become 29 5 and 12.
let's hit enter
you can see it here
your start of the week is on a monday
now there's another method to make sure
your week starts on a monday let's
cancel this step
okay i have to insert it once again so
i'll go to date and here i'll choose
start of week
now the week starts on a sunday
so
one more method is to
add day dot monday you can see
automatically
power query is giving me a suggestion so
i'll hit tab to finish it and i'll hit
enter
now you can see the values have changed
and our week starts on a monday
now let's see
we want to add a few more columns like
start of month name of month start of
year
and the year value so you can just click
on the
date column or select the date column
go to the transform tab
okay not the transform tab let's go to
the add column tab
and here let's say i'll choose year
so we have all the year values and
similarly
let's say i want to know the
start of the year
now you can do
a few more transformations let's say i
want to know the month
now here it gives us 1 which means
january that's february
march and so on and so forth
let's say we'll do one more
i'll click on this
go to my
date
drop down and here i'll choose let's say
i want to know
the day of year
all right now we are done with all our
transformation and preparing our data on
our date field so let me just go to the
home tab i'll click on close and load
now this will load the
data set on to excel you can see it here
we have the data ready now you can use
this data to make some
analysis
draw a pivot table draw a pivot chart
and do a whole lot of things
now while working on a project it is
possible that not all your data will be
in a single file it could be stored in
multiple files so it's important to
combine and bring all your data together
now we will see how to join your data
vertically
i have my data present in a csv folder
so let me show you the folder first
so this is my csv folder let me open it
and
i have some files these are named as
project one two three four and five
let me open just one of the project
files
it has a very small quantity of data
you can see it has a month column and an
amount column let me close this
and
let me show it to you again let's open
project four
all the files have the same number of
columns you can see this also has a
month column and an amount column
now we'll combine all this data together
and load it into excel let's see how to
do it
so i'll open a new sheet
and i'll go to my data tab and click on
get data
then i'll go to from file and this time
i'll choose
from folder
now this will ask me
to give the folder location of the path
location where my csv files are
so i'll choose
browse
and here you can see i have my csv file
i'll just double click on it
and click on open now it has selected my
file path
or the folder path
then i'll click on okay
you can see these are the files you have
project1.xls
project2.xls and so on
i'll
click on this combine dropdown and i'll
hit combine and transform
now this will give you the preview of
one of the data files
you will see it now
you can see it here it says sheet1
okay
now it's processing all the
data files present in that csv folder
and this will be uploaded onto our power
query editor
now you can see here on the power query
editor
all my
data files have been
combined vertically
here you can see the month column
on the extreme right it's the amount
column
and to the extreme left we have the
source name or the
source file where the data came from so
first is project one
then we have project two
if i scroll down we have project three
files project four and similarly we have
project five
now this is one way in which you can
merge your tables vertically
so we are done with it let's just go to
the home tab and click on close and load
all the transformations that were
applied you can see it here we have our
final table
and we have successfully
combined
five excel files
again
you can also join your data horizontally
this would be like an sql join where the
data is present in multiple files or
sheets
based on a common key column you can
join the tables so you can perform a
left join a right join an inner join
based on the problem that you are trying
to solve
so let's merge two tables based on a
column
i'll show the data set first it's an
excel file which has three worksheets
so here is my excel file which will be
using to
merge our data horizontally you can see
there are three worksheets
the first one is year 11 which has data
regarding the student name
the gender of the student and the course
the student had opted for
similarly we have another for 2012 or
year 12 we have the student name
gender as well as the course
and finally we have a courses
table or a courses sheet which has all
the details regarding the course
so we have the course name the teacher
who teaches or teacher who taught that
course we have the lesson type the
number of credits and the assignment
type
now we'll use this
data sets
to load it on to excel using power query
so i am on my excel sheet let's just
open a new sheet i'll go to the data tab
and here i'll click on get data and this
time i'll choose
from excel workbook
and i'll select my file which is
students and courses i click on import
so we'll just see how to import two
tables and join them horizontally
so let me first select
the courses sheet
and i'll click on transform data
now this has
loaded the courses table onto power
query editor
the table looks fine we have the course
column teacher everything is fine
now let's load
one more table and then we'll merge it
so here under the home tab you have
a section called new source
i'll click on file
i'll again
select my students and courses and click
on import
and this time let's choose
another table let's say year 11 which
has the column name as student gender
and course i click on ok
it has successfully loaded this table
onto power query editor
now if you say this
the first row is actually our
column names so i'll go to the home tab
and select
use first row as headers
so this will push the first row
to the column names you can see we have
done it successfully we have my student
name
the gender column and the course column
now let's merge it so
if you see here in the home tab we have
a section called merge queries
let's click on this drop down and select
merge queries
here
i have my table which is year 11
and let's
choose one more table
that is
courses
now the kind of join
i'll choose as left outer join which
means it will take all the
rows from the first table and matching
records from the second table
here i need to select the common key
column so if you see both the tables we
have the course column as the common key
column so i'll select
this and now you can see there's a tick
mark which means it has selected the
rows and the column successfully you can
see it says the selection matches 175
175 rows from the first table
and let's click on ok
let's just expand this
and click on ok
if i scroll to the right you can see i
have successfully merged
both the tables
now if you want you can remove
unnecessary
rows or columns suppose if you see i
have the course column
from the year 11 table and here also i
have
the course column now this is
redundant let's just remove one of the
columns i'll just select this column
i'll go to
remove columns and i'll select remove
columns
okay
the rest looks fine we have successfully
merged both the tables by using a left
outer join
let's just click close and load
now this will take some time to load our
data onto excel you can see it here
we have successfully loaded it on to
excel
now we are done with our demo part
now let's just see
what all we have done in our demo so
i'll
go to my first sheet
here you can see
we had
imported a simple
text file first and then we plotted a
graph which is a pivot chart
then you saw
how to upload
a file from the web so here we
imported a
ufo champions league table which was
present on wikipedia
and then we plotted some
graphs and charts you can see we made
some
analysis using pivot tables
and then we imported another web file
which was based on a population data and
we used the unpivot option or the
unpivot feature in the power query to
reduce the number of columns
then we made some calculations to our
customer table which was from adventure
works
then we used another table
called the products table here we saw
some statistical calculations and we
added a column called discount price
where we used conditional operations
and then
you saw how we manipulated
a date column
and then we saw how to append and merge
multiple tables
business intelligence is a set of
processes and techniques to analyze raw
data and extract information that helps
drive business decisions it helps you
keep track of business data and draw
valuable insights there are several
tools that play a key role in business
intelligence some of the popular tools
are power bi tableau and click view hi
guys welcome to this tutorial on what is
power bi in this video you will learn
why power bi is needed what is power bi
the various features of power bi and the
different components of power bi later
you will look at the architecture of
power bi what power bi services and how
to create a power bi dashboard finally
you will understand a case study on
mayer and do a demo using power bi now
let's understand why power bi is needed
first power bi has the ability to access
vast volumes of data from multiple
sources it allows you to view analyze
and visualize huge quantities of data
that cannot be opened in excel some of
the important data sources available in
power bi are xl csv xml json pdf etc
second power bi provides an easy to use
drag and drop tool with features and
functionalities that allow you to copy
all formatting across similar
visualizations power bi has exceptional
integration with excel it helps you
gather analyze publish and share excel
business data power bi helps to
accelerate big data preparation with
azure using power bi with azure allows
you to analyze and share vast volumes of
data azure data lake can reduce the time
it takes to get insights and increase
collaboration between business analysts
data engineers and data scientists power
bi allows you to get insights from data
and turn insights into actions to take
data driven business decisions finally
power bi allows you to perform real-time
stream analytics it fetches data from
multiple sensors and social media
sources to get access to real-time
analytics so you are always ready to
make business decisions now let's see
what power bi is power bi is a business
analytics service provided by microsoft
that lets you visualize your data and
share insights it converts data from
different sources to build interactive
dashboards and bi reports as you can see
we have an excel data about sales
using this data power bi helps you build
different charts and graphs to visualize
the data now that we have understood
what power bi is let us look at the
important features of power bi first is
power via desktop power bi desktop is a
free software that you can download and
it allows you to build reports by
accessing data easily for using power bi
desktop you do not need advanced report
designing or query skills to build a
report second as already discussed power
bi supports stream analytics from
factory sensors to social media sources
power bi assists in real-time analytics
to make timely decisions third support
for multiple data sources is one of the
major features of power bi you can
access various sources of data such as
excel csv sql server web files etc to
create interactive visualizations and
finally custom visualization custom
visualization is another vital feature
of power bi while dealing with complex
data power bi's default standard might
not be enough in some cases in that case
you can access the custom library of
visualization that meets your needs
let us jump into discussing the various
components of our bi as you can see
there are six major components of power
bi now let's discuss them one by one
first is power query power query is the
data transformation and mass of engine
it enables you to discover connect
combine and refine data sources to meet
your analysis need it can be downloaded
as an add-in for excel or can be used as
part of power bi desktop second we have
powerpivot powerpivot is a data modeling
technology that lets you create data
models it also allows you to establish
relationships and create calculations it
uses data analysis expression language
or dax to model simple and complex data
third we have power view power view is a
technology that is available in excel
sharepoint sql server and power bi it
lets you create interactive charts
graphs maps and other visuals that
brings your data to life
next we have power map microsoft's power
map for excel and power bi is a 3d data
visualization tool that lets you map
your data and plot more than a million
rows of data visually on bing maps in 3d
format from an excel table or data model
in excel
then we have power via desktop power bi
desktop is a development tool for power
query power pivot and power view with
power bi desktop you have everything
under the same solution and it is easier
to develop bin data analysis experience
finally we have power q and a the q and
a feature in power bi lets you explore
your data in your own words it is the
fastest way to get an answer from your
data using natural language an example
could be what was the total sales last
year once you have built your data model
and deployed that into power bi website
then you can ask questions and get
answers easily
now let's see what power bi service is
power bi service is the software as a
service part of power bi it is also
referred as power bi online to access
power bi service you need to log in to
app.powerbi.com
now let me show you that i'll go to
google
open a new tab and search for app dot
power bi dot com
it's loading
but this is how the home page of power
bi service looks like i have created
some dashboards on it first you need to
log into app.powerbi service
you can see i'm logged in
now under my workspace if i go to
dashboard
here i've created
a finance dashboard you can see the
different charts and graphs are prepared
and pinned it to the dashboard so power
bi service allows you to connect to your
data create reports and dashboards and
you can also ask questions to your data
now as you can see in this dashboard we
have created some charts and graphs so
this is a tree map
there's a pie chart there's a bar graph
below you can see the line charts and
donor charts it tells you the total
sales that were made the total number of
units sold the sales by product sales by
country sales by segment and lots more
one of the key features of power bi is
creating dashboards from multiple
reports and data sets power bi dashboard
is a single page visualization to tell a
story the visualizations on a dashboard
are generated from multiple reports and
each report is based on one data set
a single page dashboard is known as a
canvas the visualizations you see on the
dashboard are called tiles
these tiles are pinned to the dashboard
by report designers
now let me go back to my dashboard so
this is called a canvas
and each of these are called tiles so on
the top you can see we have three tiles
now let's understand how to create and
publish reports in power bi dashboards
power bi allows you to create different
reports on power bi desktop these
reports can be published on the power bi
dashboard using power bi service here
you can see there is a power bi report
created on power via desktop if you
click on publish
it will take you to the power bi service
where you can build a dashboard here is
the button for power bi publish once you
click on power bi publish it will take
you to the dashboard so this is a single
page power bi dashboard on power bi
service now let's understand the power
bi architecture power bi architecture is
a service built on top of azure there
are multiple data sources that power bi
can connect to power bi desktop allows
you to create reports and data
visualizations on the data set power bi
gateway is connected to on-premise data
sources to get continuous data for
reporting and analytics power bi
services are basically the cloud
services that are used to publish power
bi reports and data visualizations using
power bi mobile apps you can stay
connected to their data from anywhere
power bi apps are available for windows
ios and android platforms now let's look
at a case study on how mayer which is
one of united states largest supermarket
chains used power bi to solve its
business problems initially mayer had
become dependent on its it organization
to extract insights from its data it was
time consuming and inefficient as you
had to wait for iit to build every
report mayer was unable to perform ad
hoc and real-time analysis easily so
what maya did was it connected power bi
to an on-premises sql server analysis
services cube this allowed them to
refresh 20 billion rows of data in near
real time with power bi teams can now
pull in the data faster and perform
real-time analysis to derive insights
from data a bakery department inside
mayer used power bi to compare its sales
with regional performance they analyzed
where meyer was behind the regional
trends focused on the problem and
created a solution with power bi they
can now drill down into hourly sales and
send out a sales flash to 800 maya
business leaders so power bi enabled
them to standardize data sources and
empower store directors and team leaders
to develop and track that data to ensure
what they can improve now let's do some
practical hands-on demo with power bi so
this is how the power bi desktop
interface looks like on the left you
have the report view the data view and
the model view the report view is where
you visualize your data with different
charts and graphs to build reports the
data view allows you to view the whole
data while the model view is where you
check if there are any relationship
between the tables
on the right you can see the different
visualizations that you can build we'll
quickly run through all of these in our
demo
so here you can see there's a finance
sample data that will help you draw
insights about the sale of products in
different countries we will create a
report to visualize different charts and
graphs and analyze those sales so let me
go to my power bi desktop first we'll
import our data so let me go to our get
data tab and choose excel as my data
source i click on excel so here is our
finance sample data
we'll select sheet1 you can see the data
here click on it and then select load
this might take some time to load the
data now if i go to my data tab you can
see the entire data set it has fields
such as segment country in which the
sales was made the name of the product
the units sold and the sales price and
many more let's start building our
report now i'll go to my report view so
first let me create a text box
let me resize it
let me name it as
finance dashboard will increase the size
of the text we'll use font consoles
center it will also add a background to
this use blue color change it to white
and
increase the size now let me first show
you how you can create a matrix i'll go
to visualizations and click on matrix
let me resize it
from the datasheet tab i'll select sales
and drag onto values
so you can see the total number of sales
that were made now let me do some
formatting so i'll go to the format tab
click on column headers let's add a
background color and
let me increase the text size to
20.
similarly under values we'll increase
the size of the text
to 20 as well
we can also click on
border and choose the color of the
border let me take as
let it be black so this is a simple
matrix that we created which shows the
total number of sales that were made
similarly let me choose matrix once
again now we'll drag on the units sold
onto values
we'll continue with the same drill under
column headers we'll add a background
this time let's choose some other color
and under values let's increase the size
of the text to 20. even for the column
headers let's increase the size of the
text to 20.
again we'll switch on
border we resize a bit
so here we have two matrix created for
our report
the first matrix shows us the total
sales that were made the second matrix
shows you the total units that were sold
now let's move ahead and create a simple
bar chart so under visualization i click
on clustered column chart
under this we'll drag the date column on
to access and the sales onto value
let me expand it so it shows you the
sales per year this is the sales that
were made in 2013 and this shows you the
sales that were made in 2014.
now there's a drill down option which
gives you more granularity
this depicts the sales by quarter if i
drill down further you can see this
shows you the sales by month also you
have some options like short buy and
sort by sales so you can see october
month made the highest number of sales
moving ahead let me now create a pie
chart where we will see the sales by
different segments
under visualization i'll click on pie
chart let me first resize it
here
i'll drag the segment column on to the
legend and the sales column onto the
values as you can see we have the sales
made by different segments
doubling segment made the highest number
of sales with 44.22 percent now let me
add a border to both the visualization
i'll click on the pie chart and go to
the format tab
i'll switch on the border similarly for
the clustered column chart i'll go to
the format tab and click on border let
me resize a bit all right next we'll
create a very simple table that will
depict the total sales made by each
product so under visualizations i click
on table let me bring this below
so from the data sheet i'll first drag
product onto values
you can see the different products and
then sales just below it
so this depicts the total sales that
were made by each product and finally it
displays the total value of the sales
that were made this is same as the one
shown here
now let's do some formatting under
format tab i'll go to values and
increase the text size to 15
and expand it also under column headers
i'll increase the text size to 15.
then let me go and add a border
now let me create a map that will show
you the sales that were made by each
country so first let me create a new
page and under visualization i'll click
on map now i'll drag the country column
onto location
so you can see we have our map ready and
we'll drag sales onto size
you can see the different countries and
the sales that they made if i move the
map you can see the sales made in the
europe region
let me resize it i'll add a border to
this
now let me go ahead and create a donut
chart that will show you the profit by
each segment under visualizations i'll
click on donut chart
and move this to the top
now from the data sheet i'll add profit
onto the values
and
segment
onto the legend
if i expand this you can see government
segment made the highest amount of
profit with 65.04 percent
let me resize this and we'll add a
border
okay in the final visualization i'll
show you how to create a tree map this
tree map will tell you the total amount
of sales made by each product so under
visualizations i'll click on the tree
map let me expand it
i'll drag sales onto values and product
onto group so here you can see our tree
map and the sales made by each product
you can see now we have our report ready
we have created two separate canvas to
visualize our data
now
if you want to change the color of this
bars then simply go to the format tab
and under data colors you can choose
whichever color you want in power bi
desktop you have an option to switch
your theme
this will make your dashboard or the
report look more attractive so now we
are under the default mode let's try out
different themes
that's frontier
temperature
solar which is a little yellowish the
one which i like is tidal
i hope this was helpful in making you
understand the basics of power bi and
how it works you learn the various
features and the components of power bi
and looked at the architecture of power
bi finally you saw a demo to create a
report using finance data set
so what are the benefits of power bi
here are some of the benefits
so extract intelligence rapidly and
accurately so that's
basically transforming your enterprise
data into rich visuals and accurate
reports for enhanced decision making now
one thing we already know
that when we talk about data data in raw
format might have lot of hidden
information if we look at different data
sets which i'll show you in the process
it might have a lot of meaning but then
the real meaning comes out of the data
if we can create visualizations
if we can create relationships between
different data sets
and thus that can help us in enhanced
decision making
now power bi supports advanced data
services it integrates seamlessly with
advanced cloud services like cortana to
provide results for the verbal data
queries as well
when you talk about
seamlessly integrating with existing
applications that's one more benefit of
power bi so it adopts analytics and
reporting capabilities easily to embed
interactive visuals quickly in your
applications
you can build rich personalized
dashboards so it basically provides a
unified user experience with customized
dashboard and reports that meet your
exact needs
it also has a way where you can have
secure way of publishing your reports so
you can set up automatic data refresh
and rapidly publish reports allowing
multiple users to avail the latest
information across your organization or
across your working community
so power bi can connect to different
sources we'll see that in a while
so basically you have an option which
says get data
and that basically opens up a window
where you can find different type of
data sources such as excel your csv or
text json pdf
getting data from databases or directly
accessing data from databases now before
we get further
into understanding how power bi looks
like it would be a good idea to share
information in how you can set that up
on your machine so when it comes to your
power bi
and let me open up a notepad here
so for example i bring up a notepad
let's say when you talk about your power
bi components
so you basically have
power bi desktop
and that's mainly your playground or
that's mainly used for
any kind of development activities
you have your power bi server
or you can say service so now this one
is where
you would make reports
online
and
share
or
make them available
to different bus
now that's one more component of rbi and
then you also have your power
bi mobile which is mainly for
viewing the information i would say
viewing reports so these are the three
main components we can also look at the
licensing information of these so these
are the main so power bi desktop is
something which you can set up on your
laptop or on your machine
power bi server is where you can log in
with your user id and password and power
bi mobile is mainly to view your reports
now how do you set this up before you
can explore or start working on power bi
so here is a link
which you can basically use
so if you look into this
so this one basically says service self
service sign up for power bi it says
sign up of power bi service as an
individual normally when you would want
to
use power bi you can use a website
called http
and then you have basically
app
and
let's say
i think it's called app.powerbi.com
now this is the place where you can
basically log in now if you see here i
have created an account and if you look
at my account it says auatl.on
microsoft.com now how do you get this
kind of email because when you talk
about power bi it will expect you to
have a official id and it does not take
ids which are from common
domains such as google or yahoo and so
on so this particular link gives you an
idea how you can do that
so basically you have what is power bi
basic explanation on that it says
signing up for power bi service so power
bi desktop it's a totally free download
and then you have mobile apps also a
totally free download and here it says
that what kind of email addresses it
supports
and if you look into this you have to
either
sign up because that does not accept
your private email ids or you can go for
this one which says enroll us government
organization
and this is where you can basically sign
up for power bi so
it basically says try free if you go to
the website say power bi.microsoft.com
or you could go into this one which i
was saying
http
slash app.yourpowerbi.com
and this is what you can use or as
mentioned you can go to
powerbi.microsoft.com
for example if i open this in a
different tab
it takes me to power via microsoft i can
say start free
i can click on this
it says drive free but then when it asks
you to sign in this is where
some of us face problem because it does
not take your private email id now how
do you tackle that what you can do here
is
on this page which says learn about
alternate ways to sign up you can
basically open up this link
and in this link it says sign up for
power bi with the new microsoft 365
trial
account and what you can do is you can
basically
click on this link
which takes you to the office 365
and what you can do here
is you can search for something which
says say 365 e3
and here you have tried for free
so in my case it is translating okay
so here you have an option which says
try it for free click on this one and
then basically go ahead with your sign
up process now once you do that you can
basically create an account or give a
email id so it asks you to give an email
id to check if you already have an
account
and once you do that it will guide you
through the process where you can create
an account like i have done
now once you have done that so for
example we can go into
my
this page which i said http
slash app
power bi.com
now once you have created an account you
would be asked to log in now i can click
and log in here
and then basically given my password
and once i do that it takes me to the
power bi server or service now
on the top
right it might say that go for a trial
version i have already selected that and
this is a pro trial which is giving me
validity for 60 days so this is the
service which i can use now what it
means is i can be using my power bi
desktop which would be also installed so
once you
log into this page you can basically
click on apps you can basically search
for something like power bi
and that will show up in the app and you
can install and download on your machine
now once that is there you can basically
bring it up so for example
in my case i can just say power
bi desktop
and that's the app which i have
installed on my machine
and basically that comes up so that's
your power bi desktop which is coming up
and
it will still ask you to sign in so that
you can share your information
through power bi so you see here on the
top i'm already signed in
and here it also shows you some
tutorials and videos
which basically helps you in getting to
know something more or what's new so you
can always browse that
so
you would have your power bi desktop
which would be set up
you would also have your power bi
service which would be running and then
basically whatever you have developed on
your power bi desktop you can share that
through the power bi service now usually
when you talk about licensing i can give
you brief insights here so you basically
have
your
power bi service as i said licensing so
you have the pro version
which is basically
uh your 9.9
per user
per month
and basically it has some kind of
limitation so it has say max 10 gigabyte
you can work on
some features like incremental refresh
is not allowed you can always look onto
the microsoft website for more details
and in those kind of cases you usually
go for the premium account if you are a
extensive user and premium account
basically is conditional based so it
depends on your requirements and then
basically you pay for the service what
you use so that's mainly about your
servicing now when you talk about your
server and service as i said it is
basically making your reports online and
sharing and making them available to
different bus so that is
the highlight so when you talk about
sharing reports
that's one of the things you have
anomaly detection
that's also possible here
you can talk about automation of reports
you have
security that is you can go for role
based or
row level based kind of security
implementation all those are some of the
features of your power bi server and
service so it is good to know and
basically have your desktop and power bi
service setup now once you have that
then you basically have your power bi
now
when you talk about your power bi it
basically helps you with various things
so this is how easily you can have it
set up and then basically you can
explore this so for example as i was
saying power bi can connect to different
data sources now i do have an option
here which says get data i can click on
this and that shows me all the different
data sources i can even click on more if
i'm interested in looking what more
power bi desktop tool helps me to do so
it shows me all the different ways in
which you can get the data you see here
the servers so the database services
your folders your different formats you
can click on file formats or databases
you can look at power platform so if
basically you are connecting to a
platform and getting some services you
can connect to the cloud that is azure
you have online services and then you
have other options so these are all the
ways in which you can get your data when
you talk about visualizations you see a
lot of
visualization options here which can be
used once your data is loaded
and i will explore and explain more
about this so you have
something called as insert
wherein you can go in for different
visuals or different types
you can also get into say
transform the data now that basically is
going to pop up and bring a power query
editor now that's where a lot of your
etl works happen so when you when you do
a transform data it opens up power query
editor
which we can use to transform the data
or change the data or modify the data as
per our requirement before
loading all of it into our power bi
so you also have option here that says
modeling wherein we can create new
tables or we can work on our data where
we can manage relationships so as of now
we don't have any data so it does not
show this one is activated but that can
be activated this is where you can view
your reports so this is in short
exploring your power bi we'll see what
are the different options which we can
use here
so
it basically supports different kind of
data so when we look at the
visualization pane that
basically allows us to create different
kind of visualizations here and we will
understand that
so you can basically visualize on your
different data
and create different kind of charts
graphs maps
and basically derive insights from your
data now when you talk about data models
that's where you can
basically establish relationships so
when you talk about data models
it is basically used to connect multiple
data sources to build a relationship now
we might have different data sets or we
might have data coming in from different
tables where we may want to basically
get insights or get data from multiple
data sources
for our purpose now in that case data
models to help us so for example if you
have two tables let's look at the
standard tables so you have products
lookup table
and you also have the sales table now
usually what you have in any kind of
scenario is
if we basically say you have
your data tables so that's basically
where your data resides and then you
have series of your lookup tables so
usually you might have say your data
tables here
and this is what i am talking about
which might have some data for example
let's say
sales is one of them
you might have some other data table
which might be for example let's say
budget table
or might be something else
and
these are your data tables now at the
other end you might have your lookup
tables so basically you have various
lookup tables
and these look up tables for example
let's say this one is customer
this one is territory
let's say this is product
and let's say this one is a calendar
so these are basically my lookup tables
so we can basically as i said your data
might be coming in from different
sources let's say database or let's say
some kind of files or let's say
some kind of systems what you have
so your data might be coming in from
different places now
you might want to transform the data so
this is where i could say there is your
query editor which i was explaining
so you have your query editor which
basically allows you
to edit the data table or basically
allows you to edit the data before it is
loaded right you can hide a column you
can add a new column you can modify your
column so your query editors would be
basically used to work on
the data which goes into your data
tables now you might have a lot of
lookup tables as i said so let's say
these are my
lookup tables
and these are my data tables
so what we need is sometimes we need
information
based on our lookup tables and data
tables now that's where data modeling
comes into picture so basically if i
would want to extract information from
here so i can notice that there is a
product key here
and there is a product key here now this
is where we are already talking about
say foreign keys or we are talking about
your relationships right now when you
talk about relational databases you have
something called as foreign key
constraints which is
in in power bi terms i would say it's
not exactly a constraint but it is more
of a filter propagation instead
which is used to basically connect your
different data sources and you could
have
basically
cross filter directions you can go for
single
or one to one or one to many or many to
many kind of relationships which
basically allows you to work on the data
so we will learn more about data models
when we are doing a quick demo there
where we can talk a little bit about
normalization and denormalization
the way the data exists
right and then you basically would want
to gather insights from your data so
when you talk about your
two data sources as i said so you have a
products lookup table you have a sales
table now if you would want to calculate
the total order quantity of each product
name
which is we are talking about the order
quantity as a
information here and you have product
name here now how do you get that
information what we see here is we would
want
something like this or we would want
more information so how do we do that so
what we can do is
the order quantity for each product is
basically showing us the same value now
this is because the product and sales
tables are not connected and there is no
relationship between them even if you
would want to take two sources and just
get information out of them probably i
would complain that there is no
relationship established between them so
what we do is we create a data model so
what we do is we build a relationship
between both the tables using a common
key column which exists in both cases as
i said there is a product key here
there is a product key here so that
basically allows us to have a
relationship between these two now that
could be
one to one this could also be related to
other tables so it could be one too many
you could have many to one so all those
relationships are possible so product
key is basically used to create a
relationship you see the arrow mark and
then there is also this star which can
basically mean one to many now
when the product key is used to join
these two tables or form a relationship
then we can look at the product names
and the order quantities which basically
gives me a total now that's the basic
use of your data models now what about
this dax so basically data analysis
expressions now that's a
library of functions and operators that
can be combined to build formulas and
expressions and power be a desktop
usually when we work on our data sources
when we would want to connect them it
automatically shows us these data
analysis expressions however this gives
us
extension it basically gives us more
power to work on our data
now sometimes instead of working on dax
or dax expressions it would be good to
go for better data modeling and have the
relationships established better and
sometimes when the relationships are
established you could use your tax which
basically gives you more power on
working on your data so your values are
calculated based on information from
each row of a table
it appends values to each row in a table
and stores them in the model it
increases the file size so that's what
happens now you can right click on any
column to add a new column and for
example in this one it shows that there
was a quantity type calculated column
which was based on the calculation what
we see here on the top in the in the
expression bar which says what kind of
calculation was performed and that
basically gives us the value for
quantity type and that is basically
added here to our existing data
so that's the
power
of dax and power bi so you also have
something called as
measures so dax allows you to create new
calculated columns and measures so
basically here if you see we are
working on aw underscore sales and then
we have selected quantities sold
and what we are looking at in the report
is we can basically right click on any
table name to add a new measure here so
we have added what we call as quantity
sold
as the measure so values are calculated
based on information from any filters in
the report we will see this how this can
be done and that basically here the
measure does not increase the file size
it does not create new data in the table
themselves in comparison to what we were
seeing earlier that is your calculated
columns
so these are your type of dax functions
so dax allows you to create new
calculated columns and measures
so you have date and time which
basically allows you to work on date and
time
data or fields you have logical
functions which allow us to create new
filters or add more filters to our data
you have text functions which basically
allows
us to say transform the data into a
lower case or an upper case or basically
get the length of a string or
concatenate two fields
or basically
do a filtering based on some criterias
or replacing some content you also have
statistical functions which can be used
you have information functions which can
be used so these are different types of
dax functions
which we can use in power bi
so we will learn more on power bi
through a quick demo where we can
use some data sets and those data sets
could be found on internet
although i can also upload that on a
github link and you will have access to
those data sets
so let's learn about power bi through a
quick demo
by uploading some data sets and playing
with those data sets
let's
look at a sample data set and let's
upload it
and as i explained while uploading let's
also transform the data so that we can
have selective
fields so selected data loaded here
instead of loading the complete data set
and then let's see how we can visualize
this or how we can use the information
in this data set now what we can do here
is we can click on get data and then we
can choose one of the data formats which
we would be
looking for so for example i can go for
excel
and basically
click on this now here are some of my
data sets so let's look into
the folder here
and
these data sets are also available on my
github link which i'll share with you
later so here we have something called a
super store let's click on this and here
i already have a data set which is
global super store or i also have
selective data so let's
select this one
click on open
now that's basically connecting to my
data source and that will show me what
does that excel sheet have so it has
different tabs
which is orders people and returns so
let's select orders
and that basically gives me a preview of
the data which i have and if you scroll
all the way to right it shows me city
state
and then country and if you see here we
do see information of all the countries
now this can be huge amount of data
which may which we would want look into
but say for example my use case is that
i am interested in looking for the data
for united states and
as a country and all it states so we
will do that when we do a transform
now we can also select the returns tab
and that shows me
these three fields however the first row
should have been the heading
of this
particular data set and we will
transform that now i can go ahead and
click on load but that will load all the
data so instead of that let's go for
transforming so let's click on transform
data now once you do that it brings you
your toolkit that brings you your power
query editor which allows you to
transform your data so for example we
have
our data from returns tab or returns
data source as you see here so we see
column 1 column 2 and column 3 and that
also shows the type of
the data here
it also gives me a quick small option
here let's select this and then i can
say use first row as header now there
are various other options which you can
do you can add a custom column you can
add column with examples you can keep
the top rows
you can remove the top rows you can keep
errors keep duplicates so there are
different ways and you can also do a
merge query or append query so as of now
let's just say use first row as headers
and that basically shows that now my
first row has become the header you also
see
in the applied steps it basically tells
me
if i have changed the type of the data
if i have made any other changes those
steps will get added here
so it basically shows me the name as it
returns it shows me applied steps where
i have changed the type and now i
basically have this information now this
is something where you can change the
type or you can basically set it to a
particular format however we are not
doing anything of that sort right now so
we can do that for any of these columns
so this looks good
when it comes to orders let's click on
this and as i said i would be interested
in selecting for country as united
states only and let me just work on that
data however we can work on all the data
so let me scroll all the way to right
and here i have the country now there
are these filters which we can use
so basically i can click on this and
that shows me all the countries are
selected now there is also something
called as text filters which we will see
how we can use to select particular data
i basically have
other ways of filtering the data so for
example now i will just uncheck the
select all and what i would be
interested is in united states so let's
type it here that shows me has an option
here
select this and then basically say okay
so that should basically now filter out
and it shows me the data is united
states
only and then you have different states
and rest of the data remains so if you
look at the applied steps it tells me
that there are filtered rows
now we have done the basic
transformation for this data set
on these two data sources that is orders
and returns so here you have an option
which says close and apply so close the
query editor window and apply any
pending changes you can click on this
and it says apply so for example i can
just say apply for now and that should
basically apply the changes
which i have performed
using my query editor that is i have
transformed the data so that i can have
selective
data uploaded in my power bi now it's
doing that it shows me it is working on
both of these data sources that is
orders and returns so that's done and
now basically if there are any other
pending changes we can
just do a close and apply so that
basically has closed and now you would
see the data appearing here
so i have uploaded the data
as per
my preferences now if you click on
the data tab here
so it basically shows you your data
fields it might take some time to
populate but if you see in the country
field now
if even if i click on the filter it just
shows me united states now that's what
we wanted so we have already uploaded
this data in orders you can always
expand the
option here which shows me all the
fields which are there in this might be
this is an aggregation might be that's
an ordered date so this is again some
kind of aggregation we can change the
data types so we are looking at all the
fields in my orders table or basically
coming from the orders data source
i also have returns which shows me three
fields and that shows me the data which
is returned order id and region so the
column names are applied correctly as we
want and that basically looks fine now
we can also look at
your
model so when you click on model it
shows me these two however there is no
as of now relationship established
between them so it says
under properties select one or more
model objects to set their properties so
right now these are not related there is
no relationship established between them
so if i would want some data which
relates to orders and returns
then that would fail because it would
say there is no relationship now i can
go to
the first option which says report and
we have not created any report here
although we can create a simple report
we can look at the data so we have our
orders field now
we can basically pull out some
information from here we can choose what
kind of report we may want to create so
for example let's go for
the table option from visualizations you
have various options here which we can
use
this is where you can do a formatting
this is where you can select the fields
this is where you can search and filter
out the data you can also add data
fields here so first let's click on
table
and that basically gives me a table now
this table
as of now does not have anything so
you can use the filter and slices
option here which will affect the
visualization or basically what you can
do is now since we have
orders here so this is my orders and i
would like to work on this so let's say
for example country is
i can select country as a field and if
you say
it shows me country is all as of now and
it says the value is united states what
i can also do is i'm interested in the
states
so i have state now i can basically drag
and drop it here and then the state gets
added here so i can basically say select
all
and that should basically take care of
my
state field being added here
so
state is all country is all
now
we can basically look at something else
so might be let's choose sales
and
i can just drag and drop sales here so
that basically says if you would want to
have any kind of advanced filtering
which says filter type so go for
advanced filtering is less than or equal
or you can also go for advanced filters
so
that's fine as of now so we have added
some fields here
and that's basically
my data here
so
let's go for
filters here
which basically should select all my
fields
now if you see the visualization shows
my country
sales and state which we had either by
selecting the fields and dropping
them here or you can in this section
where it says fields so you can for
example let me show it again so i can
just delete this
i can click on the table option
i can just drag it here
i can basically make it bigger and i
need to add data to this one so it says
add data fields here so now let's say
country
is what we are interested in we are also
interested in states
so let's drop that here
and let's say sales so this is also what
i'm interested so i'm looking at one
specific country i'm looking at sales
per state and when we look at
sales it basically tells me that this is
summation so you will basically get
the total sales which have happened now
we are looking at this data here we can
always go to formatting we can click on
grid we can basically increase the font
here we can change the grid color
so for example let's make it for example
blue
so i can just select this
and it should basically
allow me to have the grid color as blue
now i can go in for the grid thickness i
can go for row padding outline color
so we can basically make it a little bit
more readable
and then we can basically increase the
font size here
to look at the information
and you have other options here so what
would you want to do with column headers
so i can basically have the font color
background color is fine
do you want to have an outline
do you want to have a change in font
what is the text size might be we can
make the heading a little bigger
and then basically you also have the
field formatting so all those could be
done you could go for background and all
these things can be done in formatting
so now we already have our data here and
this
basically looks good and this is
basically
one of my visuals
which i have here
and this has given me some information
for sales and basically i can scroll
this i can
also make it bigger
so i could select a particular field if
i'm more interested in looking at the
information for a particular state now i
can add more fields to this
so this is
my
one of the reports which i have created
now
what
i can do with this report is i can
basically have more data fields i can
add filters to this
i can basically look into all the data
here by just clicking somewhere in the
grid but somewhere outside if you select
a particular row then that data shows up
here you have an option of focus mode
which you can go for you can look at the
other options which says export data now
if this is the data which you are
interested in
you can export it you can always to
show as a table if you are interested in
you can do a sort by country sales or
state so for example let's do a sorting
by state
and that basically gives me the data
which has been sorted by state
information
now we could obviously have
the information here so i can then
change the order so it shows me
alphabetically this is the information
which i have so i've created a simple
visualization using the data which i
have and what i can do is i can click on
save so that basically asks me to save
this as a power bi file which has an
extension of pbi x and i can basically
call it my report so let's say
first
report
and here i can say country
or i can say state
wise
sales
in
usa
let's say
usa
and that basically is my first report
now
once you have saved this report you can
always look on your machine for example
if i go in here
and if i go into this folder might be i
should look on desktop
and
this is where i should have saved it
so it shows me first report statewide
that will open up in power bi and we
have created a simple report which we
have basically used by taking our data
now i can also do is i can publish this
if i would want to
share this information so
publish this report online in power bi
service
you can basically select
your report what we have here
and i clicked on publish so it says
what's the destination so you can have
different workspaces i will choose the
default that's my workspace i can click
on select now it says publishing first
report statewide sales in usa to power
bi you can create a portrait view of
your report and you can do all that
stuff so let it publish and then we can
basically look into our power bi server
that's a service where the information
is already shared
or published i would say which can then
be shared with different resources so we
can come here
and basically i can look into the power
bi
and this is where i will be able to look
into my workspaces and let's look in my
workspace so it says this is the place
where i had initially downloaded power
bi data set it says your data set is
ready let power bi help you explore your
data right so you can always do this you
can click on view data set
which basically allows you to
bring out your workspace and first
report state wise sales now that's the
report which we have published so let's
first check in our desktop if that's
done so it says
success open first report in power bi
now i can click on this one straight
away and that takes me to my service
now once it takes me to the service it
shows me
the report which we created
which we published and it basically has
the option where i can save it
as
a
a different copy or give a different
name i can embed this in
a website or a portal i can publish to
web
embed this report for public access by
anyone on the internet we can do that we
can export it to powerpoint so we can do
all these options you also have an
option of view where you can change the
view
you can basically also edit report here
so you can do that if you are interested
in something specific
you can do a sharing to teams so if you
have your teams or groups set up you can
share it with them
you have an option of common panes you
can basically
view usage metrics report now that can
be sometimes helpful you can basically
go ahead and go and subscribe a
particular report so if there are new
changes made you will be the one who
will be informed you can click on share
now if i click on share here from my
service it says only users with power bi
pro will have access to the support
recipients will have the same access as
you unless row level security on the
data set further restricts them so i can
grant access and this is where i will
have to give the email ids of the people
with a message
that i would want to have them
look at this report
right you can also allow recipients to
build new content using the underlying
data sets and you can send an email
notification to the user so as of now i
don't have any other groups so i'll not
be sharing it but i have created a
simple report now let's also look at
edit report let's just to see what it
helps us and when you click on edit
report
it basically brings up this one which
says your file view
it gives you the filters it basically
allows you to add data fields to this so
it is basically giving access to these
data sets
which were in my desktop
it is basically allowing you to give or
create different visualizations
now here we have the data which we are
looking at and if say for example
somebody is interested in filtering the
data so you could do that so you could
click on filter here and that basically
applies this is the filter we have now
country is fine sales
might be i can click on sales and i
would say okay let's look at
sales which is more than a particular
amount so we can say is
greater than
and might be i can give a number here so
i can say 30 000
and basically
i can say apply filter
so right now i'm liking filter and i
would look at the values
which also shows me the total value is
changed so
you have not only created a report you
have published it and now
from the service you can edit it so i'm
looking at particular data here and then
basically i can click on file and i can
save it or i can say save a copy of the
report and let's say
i will call it
the same name so i'll say first
report
underscore
state wise
sales
and i will say modified so let's do a
save
and the report has been saved
so now you're looking at the data here
so
that is basically giving you information
so when i click on my
workspace here
i can click on reports and that does
show me my previous report it shows me
the modified report it gives me an
option of looking at the usage metrics
report so say for example you want to
click on this one and it will basically
give you the usage metrics so let's
click on this one
and
that basically shows me the report usage
metrics which is generated so views per
day unique viewers per day
you would want to look at the different
platforms who was using it views by user
and this can be sometimes useful if we
would want to look into this one now i
can go back to my workspace i can click
on reports
and that basically
took me to usage metrics i could be
sharing it
i can analyze in excel
i can look for quick insights based on
this data what we have
you can basically look at the related
information you can also look at the
settings of this one
and basically this is how you have your
data report here now that also shows me
the data sets option so which basically
gives me
the data sets which can be used to
create further reports and we have our
data here
so
for example if i click on create report
it basically gives me these data sets
and we can continue working on this so
this is how i have
a simple report created without
basically working on two different data
sources but i have selected some data
here
and then i can basically add details to
this so for example now if we look at
orders and say for example this is the
data i have
and say you would want to add some
fields so let's go to returns and say
for example i would be interested in
looking at
the the products so might be what i
should do is i should replace the report
here instead of country it would be
interesting to look at
the product
which we have or basically customer id
so we can look at customer id we can
look at the order id which would be
interesting to see if there is a
particular order
what was the sales which was generated
and if there were any returns which were
happening on that so for example here
when i have these let me cut out country
as a field and i will basically take
order id and place it here
so now if you see my data has been
easily modified
so i have my order id i have sales and i
have
statewide information so
you have basically all the information
but this is now order id state and so on
now what if i would want to
also see
based on the order id if i say i would
want the returned field
so for example i would want to take this
one and let's drag and drop it here
now that says cannot display the visual
now why is that so if you click on see
details that says cannot determine
relationships between the fields so it
cannot display the data because power bi
cannot determine the relationship
between two or more fields
and how do we fix that so for example if
i click on fix this now it says
there is a missing relationship between
these fields use auto detect to search
for relationships or create them
manually now i can click on auto detect
which will try to search for fields
which exist in both the data sets or
basically i can create relationships so
let's click on create relationships and
that basically takes me to this page
which says there are no relationships
defined
from table to table and so on
so
i can click on new
now here it says select the tables and
the columns that are related now i can
say orders now those are my fields where
you have order ids and it automatically
shows that returns also has an order id
field although all the values might not
be same but this is how you can create a
relationship and it says the cardinality
says many to one so you can have
basically many to one relationship you
are saying cross filter direction is
single
so make this relationship active and it
has already helped us
basically identifying the field so i can
say okay
so it says
now these two tables should be related
or should be connected based on order id
so
here we have this and let's basically
say close
now
once that is done
if you see
i have order id i have returned
i have sales column and i have state and
if you see in returned i do have a value
of yes
which shows
this particular order id
had generated some sales
and it was for state alabama and it was
returned
and the value is yes so if you scroll
down you basically see all the values
now we can add different filters where
we can say i would want only yes and no
now this is again an interesting report
so let's go in also into the formatting
and what we can do is we can look at
say the grid option if we would want to
basically say vertical grid and let's
say
on
and it says vertical grid color so let's
select this might be i can try doing a
black here it puts it in the right nice
table format and that basically looks
good so you have sales
returned and so on and this is basically
the order which i am seeing here so for
example if i would want to
change the order and if i am saying okay
i would like to look at sales and
returned and so on so we can be doing
that we can come here and say for
example i have sales and return let's
try
moving the sales column over here
might be state is
an information which we would want in
the beginning so let me also
move the states all the way here so it
gives me state it gives me the order id
sales and if
there was
a return which was happening on that
particular product so easily i've
modified my report now what i can do is
i can just save it
and i can do the same thing so i can
publish it i can basically continue
using it or i can work on a new report
so let's continue learning and
now here we will also see
how you can load some data and perform
some transformations and basically get
multiple results or multiple tables or
multiple data sets which can be then
further used for reporting so power bi
does give you a lot of options now here
you have an option as we saw earlier
that is get data or what you can do is
you have an option where you can create
new data also it says enter data now
this is something which can be easily
used if you have
relatively
less number of fields so you can
basically add
more
columns here and you can basically add
values so for example if i would just
call it something like
scientist id
okay and then i can say scientist name
and then basically i can say
uh
domain
and then i can say for example let's say
year of joining and
and i can keep adding the number of
columns here i can delete the columns
right and i can give this and i can say
country
so
that's it and now we have created these
five
countries sorry five columns which we
have given some names and we can start
entering some values so
i can basically say let this scientist
id
be 22 3 4
i can give some name so let's give peter
let's say domain and i can say
biotechnology
i can give year of joining 2011 and i
can say germany as the country
and i really don't want this particular
column so i can go ahead and delete this
now i can come here
and then i can give something else so i
can say this is scientist id
i can give john
let's say
the scientist is mainly working in
physics
and then i can say 2018 and let's say
france
and go back here and let's say
four five six seven and let's say
marie
and let's say
she does her research in
uh molecules and let's call it 2001
and let's say
italy
okay and you can continue adding data in
this way now you can
say if the data is already here so i can
say for example no i do not want
this particular row
i do not want this particular row
so
you can basically keep adding values
here now you can say edit
so
here we have to give some names so let's
say
scientists
okay
and then
if you choose edit
it basically brings up your power bi
editor which allows you to work on these
fields
if you would want to make some changes
now we can make some changes here
we can see
what are the number of rows we can
basically perform any kind of
transactions here so this one basically
tells me what is the data type so here
we see scientist id and this clearly
tells me this is an integer however we
will not want to do any kind of
computations here so
we can as well change this so i can just
do a right click and i can work on this
particular column what i can also do is
i can just click on this
and this tells me that you would want to
change it to
date time or you want to change it to
some number so i can just say string
because we are not going to perform any
computation here
so on the id column so let's say
text
and i'm changing it so it says replace
current add a new step so selected
column has an existing type conversion
would you like to replace the existing
conversion or preserve the existing so i
will say replace current and now the
data type has been changed it is
of a string and if you see this step has
got added here so it says that
the change type
is the kind of transformation we did
here so that's fine now what we can also
do is we have the scientist name but we
don't like the column name here so it
would be good to change this
so there is something called as
remove or remove columns and so on so
when you do a right click it gives you a
lot of options in applying filters or
doing some transformation if i just
click on this one so what i can do is i
can look at the date time
and
let's go here so we have
an option which says do you want to
change the type now we could have done
that here or like i said you could
choose the time and do it you can just
say transform and how do you want to
change it so do you want to change it to
uppercase well you can do that and
changes all the values of this one
what i can do is i can again do a right
click
and i can choose
basically if you would want to clean up
the data or if you would want to convert
to lower case you want to capitalize
each word
so let's choose that and if you see here
the steps are getting added now to undo
any particular step if i just
cancel this then i'm back to this if i
cancel this i'm back to my original form
so you can anytime undo your changes
and you can basically work on this
so
we are working on this particular column
now there are various other options that
you can look at so for example these are
this is some of my data but it does not
have much information it would be good
to load
some bigger data set and then use these
transformations
or basically
working on changing the data types as i
mentioned
or if you would want to do a filtering
and remove certain fields and only
select particular fields if that's what
you're interested doing a right click
where i want to create a copy of this
and then basically i can
use that particular copy
now what i can also do is
i can add column from examples i can
duplicate column and then i can
make some changes to that so this is my
duplicate column and say for example you
would want
this one to be changed so we can
say remove duplicates we can basically
if you are doing some kind of change you
want to change the format here you can
do that you can use for other things
like filling up and all that now i can
just call it rename and let's say
um
alias scientist name
right and i can continue adding columns
or i can do some transformations and
once you have done with these
transactions now this one if you see it
shows as integer but is it an integer no
this is an date format so i can go for
modeling and change the formats what i
can also do is i can select this and it
says it's not a decimal it's not a fixed
decimal it is date time it is date
it is date time and time zone
right and you can select any one of
these so for example let's make it date
which
makes it more meaningful but then what
happens is when you do this it is going
for the default dates or the older dates
so i don't like that
so what we will have to do is we will
have to
basically transform this and
here we have transform you have change
type
so you have date and time you have date
you have time so let's choose date and
time and if you see here it gives me
some default timing based on these
values which we do not like so again
filter it out but what we can do is we
can just
make sure that this is
changed or you want to make it a string
because we are not going to do any
computation here so i can keep it as
date but then if i have more fields like
month and days and so on
then you can do that so here it also has
the option so when you have selected
this you have an option called transform
and transpose sorry transform also has
various options which allow you to work
on these do you want to do some
scientific calculations do you want to
work on
the date field so as of now it is just
integer so we can use one of these we
can do a group by but
obviously we don't have much data here
so as of now let us retain this i can
just change this to text and that's okay
because we are going to look at this
later we can add more data and work on
it so as of now once we have done all
these changes you can go back to
say home and here you have close and
apply and i can basically say close and
apply so the changes will be
applied and then my new table which we
just created by entering some random
data
performing some basic transformations
will be available so if you look into
this one
so that's where my data is it shows me
the columns but there is no aggregated
column as such here you don't see any
summation mark you just see the field
names or the column names you see the
values now obviously if you go into
modeling
there is no
or there is no existence of a different
table which you can join these tables or
you can perform some transactions
come back to the data set so this looks
good and we have it here now obviously
we have not created any visualization
based on this which we can and we can
continue working on it so here this is
my data set
which is a small table where we have
created some data and we can use it
anytime now let's work on a bigger data
set and see what kind of transformations
we can do we can then also see on
modeling or basically using some smarter
ways of working with the data
so what we would want to do is we would
want to
load some data here
so let's go into
sorry let's go into home let's go to get
data
let's use our old store data and i'm
going to take the global super store
which is huge data set with all the
countries and the products and the sales
which have happened
and we can take this data but before
loading it as i suggested earlier we
should basically transform the data we
should basically transform the data so
that you don't end up loading everything
and you don't work on all the data i
mean unless you really want to so here i
will this excel sheet which i am talking
about has two different tabs we have
used it before so let's use orders let's
use returns
and that basically shows me the data
what we have so i can do a load but
that's not what we would want to do so
you can do a load and you can get all
the data but let's go to transform
make some basic transformations before
we load the data so our power
bi editor allows us to work on this now
here we have
it says this preview may be up to nine
days old
so i can do a refresh i can select this
and i say first thing is use first row
as header because that's what i want
so it is basically
setting the first row as header which
looks good
and we have some order ids we have the
returned if the product was returned so
let's look at the filter here so it just
has
yes values
which we are looking at
so
[Music]
it says list may be incomplete let's say
load more
and let's see what are the filters here
so either there might be a product which
is returned or it might be blank field
so that is chosen so that's fine we have
order id we have region which is
basically showing me different regions
here
let's look at orders and orders
is again having your row id order id
order date ship date ship mode so you
have quite
large amount of data here for your
different countries now in earlier
example i chose united states and then i
was only focusing on the states and city
in united states
so we can do that now
i can basically work on refresh so
whatever preview was stored in the
memory we are just refreshing it now
here we have this
row id and if you see the row id is an
integer obviously we will not be
performing any kind of computation here
so
here
you don't have any row id but here we
have row id so let's make it
from integer let's make it string
and
i'll say replace current so that's that
looks fine it's a row id which we will
use to search but we are not going to
perform any computations unless you want
to find on
an average on row id or anything else
now you have order ids so
what we can do is we can
filter some values
we can rename the field as we desired
right so for example let's go in here
and what we can do is let's go into
a customer id ship
okay
and here you have say state you have
region
okay now at any point of time if i would
want to filter out the values the easier
option is
that you can select on this one and here
you can do some text filtering
okay or you can basically select the
values from here so for example
if i say let's get rid of
select all what we will be interested in
say united states and uk that's the data
we want and then
i can basically say okay
so
it is basically going to filter out the
data which is for united states and uk
as of now now what we can also do is how
about doing some more filtering before
we basically work on this so let's go in
here and we are looking at united states
and uk related data
and let's look at
it is sometimes good that you can
basically
work on the data here so for example i
go into orders now what i would want to
do is i would want to look at
the fields
okay
and we want to we have not yet loaded
the data so if you look in the
background i just have my scientists
because we have not applied these
changes we have not loaded we are still
in the
transformation stage right now what we
can do is let's go for
so we can do
segment and all these kind of fields
can be used for grouping the data so we
will see that whenever you have a data
set you would already know there are
certain fields which have repeated
values which can be used to group the
data
and we can do that we can
change
any kind of values which are not
going to be computed on so for example i
have postal code i can
use this but again we are not going to
find a postal code which is greater than
something right so integer is not the
valid type let's change it to text
okay and
if for example
i would want to
look at this so i have done some
changes here
okay and this shows me null so for
example let me just reword this back
and let's make
it whole number
okay so there are certain
columns or rows which do not have some
values and we can basically get rid of
those values so as of now we can do a
filtering here
so let's keep the postal code as integer
or
let's
change it to text do a replace
content
and now what we will do is we'll scroll
all the way right
might be i'm interested in
technology category so that's what i'm
interested in so what i can do is here i
can do some filtering
so i can basically choose
technology now the easier way would be
since these are categories and there are
only three categories we really don't
want to go and apply text filters here
but if you had something like an office
supply
and
office inventory
then you could have done some text
filters so let's not do some text
filtering here what we can do is i would
be interested in technology
so that's the field i'm interested in so
now you are only having data which is
related to technology
okay and you have some product names so
this is where we want to do some kind of
filtering
so
we can rename the field we can select
some fields so let's for
example let's go for
any of the field which i think might
have more entries here so for example
let's go for
canon wireless or canon image right so
let's go for product names
and i will say let's
go here
now i could have done a transformation
but that's not what we want we want to
do some filtering so let's go to text
filter
and here
i can say begins with
i can say ends with i can say contains
so let's go for contains
and it says enter a value here so
you would want to keep the rows where
the product name contains something and
it gives you some suggestion
right so where you are seeing in some
values here so for example if i would
have selected this then it applies the
complete thing but that's not what i
want so i will
get rid of all this and i will say it
contains canon now i can go for advanced
filtering also
okay
wherein you can select advanced and then
you can give
different columns
and
what do they contain
what kind of values you're looking for
so you can do that but we will not go
for advanced in one step let's go for
basic and let's say okay
and now i should get all the products
which are
canon
and you have different products so this
is one kind of filtering i've done it
tells me what is the category of this it
is machines it is copiers it is
obviously belonging to the technology
category we are looking at
uh the market which is for this
particular data when you look at the
country we are still focusing on united
states and united kingdom that kind of
data right so we have filtered the data
we have done some
uh selection based on the data here and
what i can do is i can then basically
rename a particular field
so i can do that i can say i'm
interested in
sales
which is the data here
we can
basically
look into the quantity so sales is
something which we are interested in but
might be we are interested in sales
which are
more than a particular value i am not
interested in lower amount of sales i
would want to look into united states in
uk data but i am interested in sales or
i am looking at
if the discount percentage was something
or if the profit was
more right so we can apply different
kind of values here but
what we can do is with these changes
because you don't want to transform and
make changes all here
you want to make the changes once the
data set is uploaded so we have selected
some data we have create done some
transformations we can basically
break a particular column into multiple
columns if that's what we want if we see
that we will do an aggregation based on
year
or we will do a aggregation based on the
country or year and order id right so we
can break this data into multiple
columns so we can do that but for now
let's do a close and
apply and
let's apply this so that's going to
apply all these changes it's going to
load my data but remember now we are
having selective or selected data which
gets loaded
so that should get
be available here so it takes time
sometimes
so you have to wait
and then you can go ahead and check here
so for example now i'm looking in tables
let's basically minimize this let's go
for orders and this is the data i have
which obviously row id if you see
so you have all the row ids and again
again you can do filtering here but this
is where you have already loaded the
data the data is available and then you
can start working on the columns here
so we have this
if you closely see we see this summation
mark and this basically means that
these are my aggregated columns or these
values are measures which can be used
for calculations so we can see that we
can create our own aggregations so we
can do that we can rename the field as
we have seen
we can filter out the data so we have
all the fields showing up from orders
and let's also look at the returns
which basically has the columns the
order id and your region
so
it basically shows the region here where
was the
product returned from and we have this
information so what we are doing is we
when we were doing a text filter in the
previous
example remember it was case sensitive
okay and you have to take care of when
you're doing a text filter you have to
give a field which exactly matches as it
exists in the content now
okay this is the data we have and let's
look at the order column right now what
we can do is we can do some quick
transformations here and we can
basically look for
more data here so
let's say we have
uh some filtering to be done now
i can do a filtering based on my
uh
products
so we had all these products but now
let's do a filtering on product and then
products you have copiers you have
machines
so you have
mainly two categories right and when you
look at machines it basically talks
about your pc
uh
something so let's look for machines and
here
we have
basically the copier fields which are
more
so i can basically
go for filtering here
and that's the data we have so we don't
want to really unselect any of these
here but what i'm doing is i'm saying
text filter and let's go into this one
now and let's say contains
okay so i'm saying contains and then i
can basically say
let's say copier
now that's what i'm interested in and
show rows where product name contains
copier
okay now you can give a and condition
here
so
if you would want a specific copier if
you are interested in okay let's also
say
uh contains and let's go for laser also
laser
and let's say okay
so you see the data gets filtered out
here and
we have the sales which we are seeing
here so let's go to sales and we will be
interested in anything above
500 so let's go to sales
let's go for number filters let's say
greater than
and i will say for example 500 oh sorry
500
okay
and
let's say okay
so that basically filters out the data
and then
i am also interested in quantity where i
would want
the quantity to be
more than
one or more than two so for example so
let's go in
here
and you can basically choose what is the
filter you want so you can apply any
number of filters now you have the
filtering here you can always click on
the filter and if you want you can just
do a clear filter and the filtering will
be gone so you have all the data right
and
this is
the particular data we have
and here i have say for example
product name now i can keep the filter
because i'm interested only in these
values or
i can filter out so this tells me that
when we did it and
it is basically going for laser and
copier right so
let's say for example clear all filters
the thing is gone what we can do is
let's go here
go for text filters say contains and
here i will say
it can be a copy here
okay or
so last time we did a and and i'll do a
contains
laser so
let's choose this that gives me more
entries so either the product name has
copier or it has laser
it has the quantity it has the product
name
and we have all this detail here now
what we can also do is we can do some
transformation
on the product id so for example you
have product id or order id so order id
shows up as
looks like the country name
uh the year and then the order id so we
can basically
split it up so i can select this and
here
i have option of
let's go to home so when you have you
have selected this column so you have an
option of transform data here so use the
power query editor to connect prepare
and transform the data so if you really
want to transform the data here if i
basically select this
if i
just where i click here
now here it just tells me do you want a
new column do you want to create a copy
of this column
okay you want to create copy table so
this is your transformed data what you
have and for example let's create a copy
table
and let's come in here
so
you should be able to see your
copy table now so let's go
in and select this one
and what you need to do here is creating
a copy of this or copy table
would not be the right option what we
can do is we can work on
transforming this rather than doing it
from here so you have this option of
adding a new column going for a new
measure
renaming it right so that's
okay but what we can do is select this
particular column let's do a home and
first thing is let's go to transform so
i want to transform the data
now let's select this one
and it brings up your power editor again
here we were interested in orders so we
are looking at
our data here
now if you see my country is united
states and uk so you can confirm that if
you look at category it is technology
product name has copier and laser as we
selected so those things are retained so
you have not lost any changes as of now
so this order id column what we have now
as i said you can be doing a filtering
okay you can select this particular
column and then you have other things
which can be used to transform here like
you want to change the data type you
want to use first row as header you want
to replace some values
okay you want to run some merge queries
you want to do some analytics so all
these options are here now what we can
do is while this column is selected i
can do where i click now there is an
option called transform which is
basically going to help me in changing
the data here okay now i can basically
duplicate the column so i really don't
want to work on this column itself but
it would be good to have
a duplicate column on which we can work
on so i can do a split column here if i
would want to but let's create a
duplicate column so let's say duplicate
column
now that gives me a duplicate column so
we can rename it later so now i will not
work on my original column but i'll work
on a duplicate column and what i'm going
to do is i'm going to
basically transform or split this so
again to where right click now you have
a split by so we can say split by by
delimiter or by number or by characters
or by position so by lowercase and
uppercase so you can do all of this so
let's go for by delimiter
now if you see
it basically identifies the delimiter
which is hyphen or dash
now you can go for split at left most
identifier right sorry left most
delimiter right most each occurrence of
delimiter and that's what we want to do
you can look into advanced options where
it says split into columns
so do you want to split that into
columns do you want to split that into
rows because that's more or less like
doing a group by and you can say number
of columns to split into
so we have here one two three four
values so that looks good to me
and uh let's do
say for example if i choose three
so i can choose three and then split
using special characters so you could do
that
so let's for example let's say okay
and let's look at the data how it looks
like we can anytime delete the data we
can keep it the way we want right so
what we did was
we created a copy of the column
then we did a split
and
what we have seen is we just have three
columns now if you see the fourth bit is
gone fourth bit doesn't show up right
because i just did a three
as the
[Music]
resulting column so i have the order id
okay and we can check if there is
already an order id column so we have
order id but that has the complete order
id year and the
relatively product id so you can see the
customer id you can look at this one so
it basically has
your order id and then let's look at
the fields here
so we have
the product id which says t e c m a i'm
looking at the first one 3 7 0 0
and
that has in no relation to the order id
right so we can make sure that there is
nothing which is
conflicting with our entries now once
that is done so we have order id which
can be used to categorize the data
you have order id which is basically the
year
okay and you have order id
which is
basically having some more value now i
can keep this data as i want so i can
basically click on this i can go for
renaming and i can say let's say let's
call it
order
id
and let's say
ids so let us
in case there is
a particular column and you would want
to look at
so
just give the name correctly now order
ids is fine
so here we will also rename this one so
let's call it
uh order
year
and that's going to be ordered here so
we can again change this to
string
okay and here you have the order id so
let's rename this one
and i have my
let's call
order
numbers
right
so we have we are seeing all the steps
which we have added here we just split
the data based on the delimiter and we
have
now three new columns which have got
added to our existing data which was
already filtered
and we have done some
splitting up of data by creating a
duplicate and then renaming it right so
if you
go and look at your transformations now
if i would have done a split here
straight away then my original column
would be gone but probably we want the
original column because sometimes you
may want to search order id with a
consolidated information sometimes you
may want to segregate it based on
year right now we have the year field or
order date field here you have the ship
date right but then might be you want to
just aggregate based on year you don't
want to really spend time in aggregating
or extracting the month and day and so
on so my these three columns can be
useful now what i can also do is i can
merge the columns if i want so we have
split the columns but what i can do is i
can say select
select
select
so using your control and now do a right
click so you should have an option
called merge columns right now this is
something which is
we would want to merge
so let's say merge columns and let's say
do you want to keep a separator so yes i
want to keep a separator but might be
this time i will give my separator is a
colon and then what is the merge column
name you want to create so let's call it
something like
um
order
okay uh
here
and then let's call it
num
right so sometimes renaming the fields
to a name which makes more sense or
based on your naming convention is good
so let's do a merge and
now what i have done is i have done
merging of those columns
so
i split the data i merge the columns and
now if you see my
the columns which i had created those
columns are gone because you didn't
merge you did a merge and now you have
the fields which are either
uh
earlier you had
something which is
separated by
a
hyphen and here you have
something which is separated by colon
right now anytime if you want you can
unmerge this by removing this step right
and you can get rid of this merge column
so if for example i would do that
so
i have my data back
right i have my data back so what we
could have done is we can select this
okay and then what we can do is like
what we did earlier so you can
basically
go for
removing the columns
okay you can do a merge column
okay
you can select one by one and create
duplicate of those and then you can
merge them right so all the possible
options are there so you can the best
option would be to create a duplicate of
these columns and then basically merge
them as per your convenience so might be
you can say order id is an order number
is the pairing what you want here is
something which you don't want right
because we already have the date field
so i can basically say remove
and this one is gone now i will select
this and this and let's go for merge
columns and
i want to give a separator which is
might be without the ear and you have
space
or you can go for custom like earlier we
had
give a
symbol
and then what do you want to call it so
let's say order
specs
okay
right so this makes more meaning because
we already have the date field so why do
i want the year into my order id so i
can always be doing a segregation now
based on order specs right now this is
some simple
transformations what we are doing here
we are seeing the
data which we have
okay now what i can do is i can
basically first apply these changes
so that all my changes what i have done
are applied
right now once these changes are done we
can basically go ahead and
save this file so i can just say save i
can go for save as i have different
other options so
if you would want to
perform keep performing your
transformation then you can just do this
you can add a column you can view the
data so for now our transformations are
good enough and what we can do is we can
basically
go back to home we can do a close and
apply and we will be back to
our data set which has been modified so
we can see
if the data what we have has been
transformed
so we have order specs here that's good
we did not do any filtering or
we we have the filter left here which
basically tells me that there are these
different fields we have not removed
them but what we are doing is we are
just applying a filter to choose copiers
and laser printers
so that's what we have here
and this is good enough now what i can
do is once this is done
i can basically save it
so i would want to call it some kind of
report if you would want to create okay
so let's call it
as
let's say second
report
and here i will say
country
technology
specific
info
let's save it
and now basically i have saved my data
so what you can do is you can go for
creating other report or basically
having this information published if
that's what you want to do if you want
to go for visualization because right
now what we are seeing is we have lot of
data here we have lot of data here it
shows me there are these
tables or data sets which we have worked
on that shows me
here in the models but there is no
relationship with them
if you go into visualization then you
don't have
any option or you have not created any
visualizations based on this data but if
you go here
now based on the data what we
transformed if you see
we
have order specs
right now that's what we chose
we basically have other fields so you
have ship date you have aggregated
columns which can be used for
visualizing and we can work on this
so i can come back here and what i would
be interested in
is this data set is fine but i want to
do some grouping i want to
basically
have some selective data in this
and for that what i can do is
let's go for ship mode now this is
something what we have so
we are in this
data field
now we have this transform so let's go
back to transform again
and let's choose our orders
so that's the data we have
and now if you see here this is
you know huge amount of data what we
want is we want to group them based on
the shipping mode
so here you have a option called group
by so i can select this
i can go in here
i can basically work on okay get rid of
duplicate values but that's not what we
want to do you want to do a group by so
as i said you can do a group by from
here or you can choose from the
transform option above and you can do a
group by so let's do a group by
now
how do you want to group the data so i'm
saying i want to group the data here
based on shipping mode
or
which is the other column you want to
use to do a group by so let's go for
shipping mode
and what is the new column name
right so we want to basically find out
that
you want to go for ship mode but
that's not enough i mean i can do a ship
mode and i can do a grouping by but you
want to just count the rows no that's
not what we want to do so let's go to
advanced so ship mode is fine so that's
your grouping right but then what we
also want to do is we want to do a
grouping based on
say sales so here for example let's go
for sales
okay
and what should we call this so might be
we can say
shipment
wise
sales
whatever you would want to call
so you can basically
get
the operation do you want to really
count the rows no we want to basically
do a summing or we want to
might be find out an average price right
so let's do a sum
okay and
here
i would want to do a summing based on
say for example
sales
so this is what i'm going to use for
getting a count of the sales now
grouping by might be we will change this
instead of
instead of sales we are using a ship
mode what we can also do is let's go for
a segment
and that would be valid grouping so it
will take a combination of ship mode
segmenting group the data based on that
and then get me the sales which is
which is basically let's call it
shipment wise sales
so it gets a sum so let's do a
okay
and that's my more relevant data which
i'm looking at so i'm looking at the
ship mode i'm looking at what is the
segment
and then i'm looking at what is the
total sales there i'm looking at
again the ship mode standard and home
office so always remember when you are
choosing multiple fields or multiple
columns for grouping by
you are basically having
a combination of two fields so that has
to be unique and your grouping is done
based on that so now you're looking at
the sales wise
and this is something as
an important information what we have
so we have done some transformation
and what you can do is
you can use
other ways like you can use pivot to get
individual values from it you can run on
merge queries which is
basically running some merge queries and
merge the query with another query in
this workbook if you have so you can go
for this now i can basically go for
apply and close so just to add to the
group by step what we did was if you see
here i have removed the group by filter
which we just did a couple of minutes
back and what i have done is instead of
transforming your complete data set
you can basically create a copy of it so
for example i can just do a copy
and then i can come here and do a paste
and i have done that and i'm calling it
order summarized but this is my complete
data now what we will do here is we will
basically go ahead and do a grouping by
again like what we did earlier based on
your shipment
based on your segment
and
based on the sales so that's what we are
looking for so let's go for the ship
mode
and
we go for group by
and here you would want to go for
advanced to ship mode
and this one i will go for segment
so that's fine now we want the new
column name so let's say
shipment
wise
sales
so i want to do a summing not the
counting of rows and i want to do a
summation based on sales like what we
did earlier and then you say okay
and that basically
gives you the data here now
what we have is we have the resultant
data based on the data which is coming
in from here we did the same thing just
one minute back but we worked on the
original data set so what i did was i
created a copy and now i'm working on
this one so i'll say close and apply
and now we are back to
our desktop
so it is applying these changes where we
have done some transformations we have
done some grouping by
and what we can do is
once we have the data here we can
anytime look at our data sets or tables
so this is my original one
if you see now i have order summarized i
can just pull out this information
i basically have my
returns which we have not really touched
and we have the scientists so we have
all the four data sets here
now what we can also do is
let's look into order summarized and we
just have this data here so
this is fine and you can continue
working on this you can basically
merge columns from two different data
sets
and then you can get
the
merged column
and you can rename it so you can
obviously do that
you can basically do a uncheck
whenever you are working on these data
sets so what you can do is
if you would want to work on
transforming for example let's go back
here
and say i want to do
some transformation on it so how did we
do it we just did a transform
and
you can go back to transform
so you have this data here and
the data what you have you might be
interested in transforming this into
something else
and then
you don't want to
maybe load this data so you have this
option where you are selecting orders
and then you have something called as
enable load which can be unchecked so
when you do a uncheck what will happen
is whatever changes you perform
only those changes related data set will
be loaded
and they will still be available but
this will not affect your
it will not affect your original one so
for example let's say copy
and let's go in here i will do a paste
let's say orders
oh i did a paste i need to rename this
so let's renaming let's say orders
and here
i will say summarized
and i will say us
so i'm renaming it now let that get
loaded
we can perform some transformations on
it
so i have here
where's my country so let's look for
country
yeah
and let's look for country so here i
will go for only united states
okay that's what i'm interested in and
then i can choose well i'm interested in
just central us
so i can basically go for
just the central us and i can get rid of
all of these
so now i should have only central u.s
data
and this is fine and this is the data
might be we are focusing on right now
for doing some visualization might be
looking at sales
might be looking at the product
names so you have the product name now
remember you don't see any filters here
right because the filters are
coming from the resultant set and your
transformation so
if you have any filters you would be
seeing in the top row now this is the
data we have
let's uh
let's not restrict it to region region
would then reduce my data but that's
good enough for us
i can just say no
i'm clearing off this filter
i'm still looking at united states but i
want to look at all the regions yeah
whatever we would be interested in
category
and that's anyways chosen as technology
which we had chosen when we were loading
the data
we have copiers and machines
right and
we can basically keep this now
this is fine i can apply the changes
i can apply the changes based on this
one
and what i can do is i can just say for
now apply
so that's going to apply all the changes
which you have done in orders or summary
or the new one right and what i can do
is now i can choose order and i can say
don't enable this in load so it says
disabling load will remove the table
from the report and any visuals that use
its columns will be broken we are not
creating any visuals as of now the table
will be removed so that's fine
and now i will say close and apply
so what happens is you are loading the
data based on the changes
okay now you have your
order summarized you have returns you
have scientist but you basically do not
have orders anymore so that was not
loaded so i only have this one
i only have this one
and
you have returns you have scientists you
don't have the orders column right now
that particular
data set was not loaded at all because
we did not
choose that to be loaded right now while
i'm in this
orders
which is
let's see here
and actually you can drag in yeah
so you have order summary and this has
basically
kind of data which i'm looking for so i
really don't need the
orders table so you can do it in steps
and you can aggregate this you can have
aggregated data you can have all the
data which is filtered transformed
grouped by
and then basically just load it and the
original data set which you used that's
no more
being loaded here now at any point of
time if i really want
i can go back to transform data and
remember it is still here it is still
here it's not gone right so you can
basically select this and you can say
enable load and you will have the data
back which you can continue working on
right so these are some quick
transformations which really help us
in
working on the data now obviously if you
have data you want to perform some left
joins right joins
you have inner joins outer joins so you
can always do that
you can take two different data sets
might be i'm interested in taking the
orders summarized which talks about
standard class consumer shipment wise
sales
and here if i look at order summary i
have other details but the thing is we
need to make sure that these have the
values
these have the values say for example
the segment column here
and the segment column here can really
be used to join these two tables so if i
create a relationship
or
if i create a join i can basically merge
the data so this is how you work on data
we will also see some more examples on
might be modeling the data using some
expressions to work on the data so we
already looked at creating a report
selecting particular fields
and then publishing the report onto your
power bi service now this is the report
which we had created which says state
order id sales and then i also added
this returned field and that was
basically by creating a relationship
between order and returns which we can
also have a look in model so this is the
relationship which is created if you
just place your cursor here it tells me
that we have a relationship between
order id of returns
and order id of orders and that
basically allows me to join the data
bring it in my one report now this is
basically your data sources you can look
at and if you click on your
visualization so that shows you your
report now what we can also do is we can
make it interesting now we would not
want to
scroll through the fields to see
wherever or what was the
order or what was the order id which was
returned
now i can do a sorting i can filter out
what i can also do is i can use this
option which shows slicer here and that
basically allows me to work with this
data so we have this report here
and basically as i said you can click in
here it shows the data now what i can do
is i would want to filter out
information or slice the information
using your returned
either being yes or
having a field which has no value how do
we do that so basically i can drag and
drop the returned
here as a field which comes from returns
now that basically shows me only the
value as yes but i do know that there is
there are some fields which are blank
now how do i add filter to this so i can
click on this one
and
then i can click on slicer now once that
does so it basically pulls out all the
different values so you have either yes
or you have the blank field for returned
so what we can do is we can select yes
you will see only
the orders and their ids and sales where
the products were returned so that gives
me hundred eight thousand one one eight
and i can select blank so that will
basically get me
all the orders or products which were
not returned now this is a simple way
when i can add a filter to or a slicer
to my report to basically
give
viewers a choice of
selecting different fields and you can
add any number of slicers you can
basically say
i would want particular kind of
information so for example if i go into
orders and we know we have the state now
i do have the state information here
and basically i can if i would be
interested i could filter this out in my
report itself i can sort it i can look
it in a different order what i can also
do is
how about
bringing in state here and basically
dragging it here
so that gives me the state option it is
giving me a visual
which is basically
giving me a geographic location of all
these points so yes that can be good
what i can also do is i can keep this
which basically shows me the state map
might be it can be useful you can zoom
in you can zoom out you can look at
specific information here you can drag
and drop here so that's fine what i can
also do is i can
again take the state
and bring it here
and that
basically can be instead of my map i can
go for slicer so that gives me all the
values here and which basically allows
users to choose the fields
or the states which you would be
interested in looking at so for example
if somebody is interested in looking at
the data for georgia just select this
one and you see the map automatically
shows you where in the map that's the
place
and it shows me all the sales for
georgia state now i can also basically
select yes and that shows me which were
the orders which were basically returned
so that gives me a quick overview of
statewise what is the geographical
location
if the orders were returned or maybe i
can just click on blank and it shows me
the non-returned orders
i can again go here and uncheck the
georgie option and that shows me all the
states now once you have done this this
looks like a comprehensive report which
can be useful for the viewers for your
management team and so on so we can just
do a safe and that basically is saving
my report so i have this report now what
if i publish this report
so i can just do a publish
and when i publish it says okay
workspace so let's say select
and then it says replacing this
data set may impact two reports you
already have a data set named by this
one
view the impact i would say replace
or i will say
view impact so that basically takes me
to the power bi service because
sometimes we may have some reports which
we have already uploaded and updating an
existing report might basically affect
my existing report so it basically shows
me the impact analysis it shows me one
workspace there are two reports they are
they have not been added to dashboard
but these are the ones which will get
modified so let's for example
as of now go ahead here and let's look
into
my power bi so go back to your desktop
and i'll say no i don't want to replace
so click on cancel
so i do not want to publish it might be
what i can do is
i can try saving it as a different
report so let's say save as
and now i will basically say
additional
filters
okay let's save it
so now you see the name on the top
changes to additional filters and now
it's saved to publish this
and now i can go ahead and publish it
select your workspace
and basically it says this is the report
being published with our additional
filters with a map which gives a
geographical
area showing us the information
and then basically what i can do is once
it is done i can
look into my power bi service like we
did earlier you can do a filtering
we can basically query this data we can
share it with other users who might be
interested in looking at this particular
data now this says it is done so it says
get quick insights and might be it's a
good option to
look into what kind of insights it's it
gives you so click on that
see the beauty of power bi where it
tries to search for
any kind of insights which it can gather
from the kind of report which you have
built
now once the insights are ready it will
let you know what we can also do is
we can come in here click on
view data set
so you see now it shows your additional
filters and here you have
option
where it should be showing your report
so let's say view
and view is fine
so
and if it doesn't show up
sometimes it might be taking time for
refreshing so you can always go here and
then you can click on your report
and that should get populated
so this is the report these are the
filters which i have
gives me an option of choosing all the
states
and basically allows me to edit the
report and
look at all the information here
meanwhile we can see here it is still
trying to gather some insights from the
data
and now you see there are some insights
here so it says sales which is coming up
and a subset of your data was analyzed
and the following insights were found so
you're looking at sales by
ship mode so it says standard class
second class first class and same day so
there were different shipping modes in
our data and that's what it shows me the
sales which one had the majority it
shows me the profit so which city or
state had
more profit so new york city has
noticeable more profits here
average by shipping cost by sub
categories so there are these different
subcategories which we can look at such
as copiers and machines have noticeably
more shipping cost
profit by product name
and
you can basically look at the row id and
quantity so this is where you're looking
at a regression analysis you're looking
at row id and quantity so there is a
correlation between row id and quantity
so these are two different variables or
fields which are related you're looking
row id by category
row id so it says california has
noticeably more row ids
sales
your profit count of region and count of
returns so there is a correlation again
between two different variables
average of shipping cost now we would
have taken a lot of time building all
these visualizations
but power bi has already helped you in
gathering all these insights and then
you can basically select which one of
these is what you are interested in you
can focus and look for more information
based on all the fields it has given you
good amount of insights which will help
anyone who is looking at this particular
report
so that's your quick insights here
and
we have this information
now
once you have this information this is
basically where you have your focus mode
so it says subset of your data was
analyzed following insights were found
you can
basically say download
and
here you have other options which allow
you to work with your power bi so
let's look at this one so this is where
we have our report
and
we can continue exploring it more
one more interesting feature which power
bi has other than
having your insights ready to use
which is basically in your workspace and
you can basically use these insights
what we are looking at various options
here
and basically you have this option where
it says spin the visual if you are
interested in a particular
insight you can always spin it which you
can always go back and look into what
you can also do is you can
also click on edit report here now
that's a report which has already been
published
to
your power bi service not yet shared but
that can be shared or that can be
subscribed now once you click on edit
report
it has option of reading view mobile
layout
you have basically an option which says
basically
options for navigating through the data
set you can go for
how visuals on the canvas interact with
each other
you have all these options and one of
the good options is ask a question so
you can always click on ask a question
and that basically
says
some suggestions now you can open this
and it says
okay ask a question about your data try
one of these to get started what is the
average sale
sort orders by order date sort orders by
product id
how many ship modes are there compare
quantity and discount so do not worry
that
your report has
only four fields so it has state order
id sales and returned
with some filters but what about
you looking at how many ship modes are
there so it is already looking at your
data so if you click on this one here
and you can see what are the different
fields what we have and you have ship
date and ship mode so this is one of the
fields which it is showing you to ask a
question now what you can do is you can
say how many ship modes are there let's
click on that
let's ask this question it says four
ship modes and do you want to add this
to report yes you can you can let it be
as it is so you can basically keep this
question here
and here you have an option the visual
is showing number of ship modes when you
place your cursor here
if you
see here turn this qna result into a
standard visual
and let's do that
and basically it is saying
number of ship modes
right so now that's the power of
your bi
power bi which has basically allowed you
to ask a question and quickly
add a visual to your report now what we
can do
is we can basically save this
or you can say save as and give a
different name so might be i'll just say
save because i would want to have this
information and the report is saved so
in this way you can basically not only
create smart visuals
you can not only relate
different data sources using data models
or relationships you can add maps you
can add filters you can add quick
questions
you can basically just go here and say
for example you would want to
ask a different question now we see the
fields here how about looking at the
shipping cost right so here i can say
um
what is the
highest
shipping
cost and that shows me some suggestions
let's select that and that shows me the
value
which is great
and i can keep it as it is i can
basically convert this to a visual i may
want to keep the question because might
be this question was asked
and
you would want to see the result here
might be you can move this somewhere
here
and that gives me some kind of question
which was asked and we can do a safe
and that's my report which has been
saved
in my bi service the data set is still
there you can basically go ahead and
share this
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
let's take a look at some of the
benefits of tableau as your business
intelligence tool so why would we use
tableau it can be connected to 40
different data sources the more data
sources it can connect to it means that
you are more likely to get direct access
to your data it can build interactive
dashboards with just a few clicks which
can help you quickly understand your
data and it lets you see your outliers
there's also simple analytics built
right into tableau such as trends and
forecasting that can help you understand
your data on a deeper level tableau has
been a leader in the gartner magic
quadrant for the last six years and that
includes 2018. here we will take a look
at an overview of the products offered
by tableau so we have tableau desktop
which is where you do all of your
development this is where you connect to
and build visualizations and dashboards
today we'll be using tableau public
which is a free version of tableau
desktop but with some limitations such
as having no r integration and it can
only support up to a million rows of
data also any data published here is
made public so you can't use this for
private company information then there's
a new tool called tableau prep where you
can prepare your data by seeing it
visually before you connect and build
reports there's also tableau online
which is a cloud-hosted version of
tableau server a place where you can
publish your dashboards and it enables
you to share your dashboards in a secure
way tableau server has an option to be
on-premises
so let's just do a quick comparison
between building a visualization in
excel and building one in tableau
okay so here we have an excel file full
of data that we will soon connect to and
use for some of our demonstration
purposes
and you can see that we have information
about orders if we wanted to find out
the quantity sold and the sum of sales
for each region we could do that by
creating a pivot table so we'll make it
i selected my cells we'll make it in a
new worksheet and here we have the
beginnings of a pivot chart
and we can grab region and pull it into
our columns
and then we'll grab
sales
and put it into values
and then we also want to look at
quantity and put that into values and
it's automatically summing up sales and
quantity but you can choose if you want
it to be sum or not and then we'll take
our values and put it on rows so that we
can see
sales and quantity
one on top of the other and that's the
basics of a pivot chart now let's do a
similar thing in tableau
okay so we have our connection to the
data and tableau automatically splits
out the dimensions from the measures
we'll go into more depth on that later
but we can come and grab a region and
put it onto columns
and we get a similar thing maybe a
little nicer formatted and then we can
come and put quantity
there
if we want to add sales to it we can
double click on sales and we'll have
quantity and sales one on top of the
other we can put sales on top by
dragging quantity
down in that box we also have this show
me dialog box which allows you to
see what visualizations you could build
using what's already on the screen or
the things that you have selected so
right now we could quickly switch it to
bar charts and now we can see quantity
and sales across our region with bar
charts or we could switch it to stacked
bars and we can see our quantity across
the regions if you close that we can see
our legend over here and then our sales
across the region
so in tableau we have a lot of really
quick flexibility to turn just text into
a visualization
so in summary we can see a side by side
of what we made using pivot tables in
excel and what we made in a similar
amount of time in tableau let's get
started with the tableau installation as
for requirements you need windows 7 or
later or you need your mac operating
system to be 10.11 or later here are
some of the browsers you can use to
install tableau
we will be installing tableau public
today and to do that you just google
tableau public download and click on
that first link and then you put in your
email address and click download the app
so
let's just
look up tableau public download
and it's this first one you can click
download now it takes you to the tableau
public page where you can click sign in
and create an account free
this gives you a place to save the
visualizations you make but keep in mind
anything you save on tableau public is
public and then you come here and you
enter your email address and click
download the app and it should give you
executable file
that you will download
and
once it's downloaded
you should be able to open tableau
public so let's go take a look at the
tableau public opening page
so this is what tableau public looks
like when you first open it on your left
you have the different things you can
connect to
this is more limited in tableau public
than it is in tableau desktop so if you
invest in tableau desktop you have
many many things you can connect to you
can also connect to data by clicking
this drop down connect data piece that's
especially useful when you've already
started your visualization then we have
this central portion called open this is
where anything that you have opened up
previously will show up you can also
click open from tableau public and when
you have
my connections timed out so i need to
log in
um but when you log in
it says no workbook found try publishing
first this is where you'll see all of
your published tableau public dashboards
over here we have discover and it has
some how-to videos
visualization of the day
which is where people who have made
tableau public visualizations get
recognized for their skill and you get
some pretty cool ideas when you look
there
so let's get started by connecting to a
data source we'll click microsoft excel
and we'll choose our excel file and open
it up and this is our data source page
this shows you the sheets on the excel
file and allows you to drag them in so
that you can see the data show up this
gives you a preview of what your data
will look like
you can see the tableau is starting to
classify our fields so anything that has
abc on it
shows that that's a column that has
strings in it we also have a globe which
is where tableau has recognized these
values to be geographical
so we have
state and it's recognized that it
contains states it bases it on
the keywords that it stores to identify
if it's geographical and so it takes a
look and you've named it city and it
knows that city is geographical we also
have the calendar symbol where it's
recognized that it's a date field and we
also have row id that shows up with the
hashtag and it recognizes it's a number
so now that we have our data source
pulled in we can come here and hit sheet
which is where you start to build your
visualization let's take a look at all
the different pieces of this before we
go any further we have the data that
we're connected to up here
is our orders sheet from the sample
superstore excel sheet we have
dimensions on top and measures on bottom
these are where we're going to get the
fields to drag and drop here we have our
cards we'll look more in depth at our
cards in a moment and these are our
shelves the column shelf and the row
shelf
where you can drag things in to make
changes happen in the visualization
center we have our show me tabs where
you can see we took a brief look at this
earlier but you can see all the
different visualizations you can build
here
a neat thing about show me is that when
you hover
it'll tell you what types of fields you
need to build it so
for a symbol map try one geographical
field
zero or more dimensions or zero to two
measures and that's how you can build a
geographical symbol map
and when you're done with show me you
just close it
let's take a look here at our sheets so
we have sheet one and sheet two a sheet
is basically just one visualization at a
time
let's get rid of the extra sheet we have
a dashboard which is where you can pull
multiple sheets on to show multiple
visualizations at one time
and then we have what's called the story
which allows you to show
a sequence of visualizations so that you
can tell a story
perfect okay so we saw that tableau is
categorizing
our different fields
and it is also giving it a role
so we have dimensions on top and
measures on bottom
dimensions contain descriptive values
such as names dates and geographical
data you can use dimensions to reveal
details in your data that is qualitative
details we also have measures which
contain numeric quantitative values that
you can measure measures can be
aggregated and when you drag a measure
onto the view tableau will apply an
aggregation to that measure it's sum by
default
so let's show this by building what we
built before
we'll grab region and we'll see its four
distinct
values as a dimension and then we'll
double click on quantity and we can see
the
numbers here the measures and you can
see here that it is the sum of quantity
and now we can also double click on
sales and we can see quantity and sales
to discuss a little bit more about
dimensions and measures you can see that
in general measures are numbers and
dimensions are not but sometimes like
row id it is a number now why would we
have a number up here instead of in the
measures so you can tell the difference
between number whether it should be in
measures or it should be in dimensions
based on whether you'll need to do any
calculations on it or if you would want
to be able to aggregate it at some time
so for sales
if you have
several orders in a day
you might want to know what the sum of
those sales are
but if you have several orders in the
day
and they're on rows 2 3 4 and 5
you might not want to know the sum of
the rows so tableau is smart enough that
when it sees id it knows that it belongs
up in the dimensions now you can switch
so if row id was actually something you
would want to aggregate for some reason
you can drag it down to the measures and
add it down there
but in our case row id isn't something
that you want to sum or average can you
think of any other numbers that might
not show up as a measure that should be
a dimension comment below with your
answers as we discussed before
dimensions are on top measures are on
bottom and you can see that blue is
associated with dimensions and green is
associated with measures but it's a
little bit more complicated than that so
dimensions are qualitative and measures
are quantitative but blue means we want
our label to be discrete and green means
we want our label to be continuous let's
make a new sheet and make a
visualization to kind of show this so we
can bring on quantity and we're going to
use it as a dimension but you can see
even when it's a dimension you can
choose continuous or discrete so right
now it's a dimension but it's green a
little bit different than what you might
expect and then we'll do sales so now we
can see over the different quantities
what our sales was yeah has been for
this last this period of time that we're
looking at i believe it's four years so
for when people bought three items the
total sales was
that number and you can see that this is
an axis so it's from 1 to 15. now if we
change it from continuous to discrete
you can see that 1 is a label 2 is a
label and it's not an axis ranging from
1 to it doesn't even have 15 because
there are no values under 15. these are
just individual labels so we go back
it's green again and you can see that
it's an axis so we have two greens on
here so we have two axes and change it
back to discrete and now we have one
axes and one set of individual labels so
let's go back to our sheet three we have
all of these different
sales by the different quantity numbers
and up here we have our sorting when you
hover it tells you what kind of sorting
is going to happen so we could sort
quantity descending by sales so we can
see that when they buy three things we
have the highest sales
you can do the opposite
where it's the lowest
to the highest
number of sales you can also do sorting
more in depth by clicking on the
quantity and right clicking sort so we
could just sort
by
descending or ascending or by sales or
alphabetic
which is
not what we want
you can choose the field or you can
manually change your sorting here
and now we're back to what we had at the
beginning now that we've had an overview
of how tableau works let's go into a
little more detail
tableau is very much built on the
premise of drag and drop so
let's build a simple visualization
and talk about
what each of these shelves and marks
cards specifically do
so we're going to make a simple chart
which is average sales by region
so we know we want
sales
on
let's do sales on
rows now for rows and for metrics since
this is continuous like we talked about
before it's making an axes
for our sales
we also can drag
region
onto columns and it makes one column per
region so that's how it works with
dimensions if you
pull a dimension onto columns you're
saying i want one
blank per column i want one region per
column so if you wanted to do it by
instead of region
if you want to remove something from a
visualization you just pull it back off
or you can hit undo or control z
tableau has the benefit of having
unlimited undos so let's say we wanted
to
bring on city let's say we want one
column per
city and that's what you get and there's
a lot of cities
so that's what it looks like let's take
city back off
i want one column per region
and for
sales
i want my rose axes
to show me where sales are great
now let's say we want to adjust the
color of these bars you can click on
color and you can select any of them so
let's pick this nice blue or we can pick
an orange
and that's how you can determine
the color
but if you want
something else to determine the color
you can take
region
and drag it onto color and now we have
one color per region
now with measures again since they're
continuous it's going to be more like a
scale
so
if i want them to be
a different color based on sales and i
pull sales onto color it's going to be
darker where there's higher sales and
lighter where there's lower sales so
it's continuous
from light to dark but for region
it is one color per region so they're
distinct colors it's not continuous
great
let's say we want to sort this
biggest to smallest
and we can look at size here so if we
want to adjust the size manually we can
click on it and drag it
but if we want the size to be based on
something else
you choose a measure for the size so if
we want it to be
wider
based on
sales we will drag sales onto size and
we can see that it gets bigger with
bigger sales we do the same thing
and replace the sales with profit
and now it's bigger if there is bigger
profit and drag that back off so you can
determine manually or you can do it with
your measures
for label let's say we want the sales on
to label now we can see
the exact sales number
for each
region
um what if we wanted the name of the
region there as well we can drag region
onto labels and we can see sales for the
west region
you can adjust which one goes on top
see how we have two t's here those are
both labels
great uh two tip
when we click on tool tip it'll show us
what's going to happen
when we hover so as i hover here on east
it says region east sales and that shows
the sales amount
um now we talked about
i'll take my labels back off wanting to
make this visualization not for the sum
of sales but for the average of sales so
we will right click on our sum of sales
here in the rows hover over measure
which right now is sum and change it to
average and we have a different
result here so let's sort again and we
can see that the south
region actually has the highest average
of sales which was not the case for the
sum now let's say we want our sum i mean
our sales to be on the label but look
it's giving us the sum of sales label so
we just do the same thing
and change it to average
now we can see our average on the label
the label has some interesting
options
like you can format this
and we could say maybe we want it to be
all of them to be blue
and that happens right there
you can also choose to only show
the minimum and the maximum this becomes
handy on
a line chart where you don't want all
marks labeled because it gets very messy
but you want the tallest and the
shortest part to be labeled and maybe
you just want the tallest so we'll click
label minimum value and remove that
checkbox and now we just have the
tallest value there
and one card that we haven't used yet is
the filters card so
we could allow people
to look at this but rem only
certain
regions so what we can do is we can come
over to region and right click on it and
click show filter and it will add it to
that filters card and now we can remove
central from the mix and just look at
those ones you see if we remove south
the new highest east
now has the label but if we put it back
in south will have the label again if we
don't want to have these filters we can
pull it off there or if we wanted to
filter out
by country oh we just have united states
so let's not filter by country
but we could pull in
category
and we have these filters by category if
we select them all
they'll all be there
and we click show filter and it will
bring it over here and we can remove our
technology and the self still has the
highest for the other two but if we only
include technology you can see the
difference there
so that's the basics of filters
one another thing that i can mention
here
is that you can change the type of mark
manually so you saw when we pulled on
region and we pulled on sales it
automatically made us a bar chart but we
could change this to be a line chart and
you can see that the color changes
because we told it too based on region
if we pull that off
then it would be a line chart there
you can change it to be a lot of
different type of visualizations here
so when you're not using show me to help
determine your graphs you can choose it
manually right here
okay
now let's
look at
building a scatter plot so scatter plot
is when you have a bunch of shapes and
points on a visualization with two axes
that are both measures
so if we take
sales
and put it on the
y-axis
and we take
discount and put it on the x-axis we can
see
our point that represents all of our
data with the sum of sales and the sum
of discount
and if we wanted to see this per
order we'll take order id and put it on
to detail now what detail does is it
determines the level that we are
building our visualization at so
grabbing order id and putting onto
detail
gives us all of these little points so
for each order what was our sales
and what was our discount so we have
out here some outliers that you can find
very quickly
let's actually do
product id instead so i'll put it right
over top of order id and it will replace
it
now we see all of our products
anything that has high sales is up here
anything that has high discount is over
here you can see that it sort of has a
trend
where
things with high sales do not have high
discounts which makes sense if we wanted
to
know what
category these products i'll show up in
we could take category
and put it onto shape
and now we have three different
shapes that tell us the categories
tableau has a cool new highlight feature
which allows you to show
just the dimension that you want to see
but it leaves the other ones in place so
for example if we click on furniture
first we have to turn on the highlight
feature and then click on furniture
and now you can see all of the furniture
items popping up in our visualization
and how they're kind of clustered in
this area and the pattern
for them when we click on technology we
can see their pattern which is a little
bit different so we have them by shape
with category let's drag category onto
color as well if you remember category
will determine the color
and the shape at this point and so we
can kind of see the patterns happening
there
so if we want to see our high discounted
items
they're all over here and most of the
things that are getting
high discounts are office supplies which
is interesting
and then our highest sales product up
here
now we could take that product id and
find out what that product actually is
out of our oh look we have product name
let's replace product id with product
name
and we see that that is a canon image
class advanced copier
so this copier is our big sales person
and
office supplies binders do not give us
very many sales and we're highly
discounting them
so now you know a little bit more about
the details card and the shapes card and
about using highlighting
in tableau
let's say
we wanted to know by subcategory what
our profit is like we could grab
subcategory and pull it onto columns and
we would say we want one column per
subcategory
and then let's grab profit
and pull it onto rows
and you can quickly see
which categories
are profitable and which ones are not so
we can also take profit and put it onto
color
so that you can see that even more
clearly
right now it is going from orange to
blue which is tableau's default if we
wanted to change
from what color to what color it was
going we have a lot of options in here
when you go to edit colors
so maybe you wanted to go from red to
blue
just to emphasize that the profit that's
negative is bad so we can hit apply and
now we can see red to blue we have our
categories here our sub categories here
but let's separate it out by category so
what i'm gonna do i'm gonna take
subcategory off
i'm gonna put on category and that's my
category and then i'm going to put
subcategory on after it so when we put
it in order like this the order matters
in tableau so first it breaks it up by
category and then inside of that it
breaks it up by subcategory so
furniture's all here and then there's
our subcategories under furniture if we
were to move subcategory to the front
it really doesn't group it appropriately
because first it's breaking out by
subcategory and then by category and
that's not effective we end up with
furniture furniture furniture furniture
spread out across our visualization so
again let's put category to the front
and now we have our profit by category
by sub subcategory
and we can
click
sort subcategory descending by profit
and now what it does is within the
highest group within each group
it then sorts it by profit so you can
tell it's not going to break this group
apart to move tables to the very end
it's going to keep tables inside of
furniture and then it doesn't move
furniture to the very end either
so
what we have here is a quick view by
category by subcategory how we're doing
on profit we can see that tables is our
biggest drain on profit and so if we
wanted to improve the profitability of
furniture
maybe we would
not sell tables anymore it's just not
working out for us
another thing about this visualization
that we could do to improve it
is you can see that there's some of
these words are getting cut off
so
we can right click on this axis and
click
rotate label
and now you can read the whole word and
so that's helpful
also up here we have our title which
right now is the same name as our sheet
so if we rename the sheet to
profit by
sub category
then it names the title up here so this
is making it look a little bit better
and then here we have profit
and it shows it but without any like
dollar signs so let's come up here to
profit and click format and you can see
that we can format the sum of profit
to be currency
and
we can do it currency by the thousands
and we can get rid of these decimal
places
and now you can see it's just a little
bit nicer
a little bit more clear maybe we don't
have to have the label here that says
category subcategory so we can hide
field labels for columns
because it's pretty clear that these are
categories and these are subcategories
so those are some formatting tips for
you formatting in tableau
is one of those things where there are
just a lot of different ways you could
change things
so in more in-depth videos especially
from simply learn you'll learn more and
more about this
also as we are
building these visualizations if you
want to
have access to this data set so that you
can build along with me just make a
comment in the comments below and the
simply learn team will send you this
data set now we're going to take a look
at creating a hierarchy in tableau
so we'll make a new tab
and we're going to make a sheet
called
sales
by product
and so we will be looking at sales as a
number
and let's bring on product name
now there are a lot of products names so
it's going to make sure that you really
want to do this i'm going i click add
all members and now we can see all of
our products and their sales
overall time
so if we sort this we can see our
highest sale selling item which we
discovered earlier as the advanced
copier and we scroll down to the bottom
our lowest selling items
so we have our products and we can group
that by sub category
and you can see i need to put it in the
front again
and by category
all right i'm going to take product name
back off and we're going to talk about
hierarchies so
a product rolls up into a subcategory
which rolls up into a category you can
create a hierarchy by
let's start with subcategory and
dragging it onto category and it's going
to create a hierarchy we'll call it our
product
hierarchy
and now it knows that category is the
parent to subcategory
let's do the same thing by grabbing
the product name and putting it
underneath subcategory
so now it knows categories the parent
then there's subcategory and then
there's product name this allows you to
instead of pulling this off or putting
it back on
you can bring category on and then you
can expand it by pressing this plus
button and now we see but here's our
sales by category by sub category
and then here's our sales
by category by subcategory by product
name this is really useful when you're
creating a details section for your
users
and so when somebody wants to know
let's say you have
show filter for category and a filter
for subcategory
show filter for subcategory and they're
looking at category here and they're
just like i see technology has the
highest sales and i just want to see
technology so i'm going to unclick
furniture and office supplies
let's put category on top and then so i
just have technology will i want to see
what has the highest sales inside of
technology and let's sort it
phones phones does so i just actually
want to look at phones so i'm going to
remove accessories copiers and machines
and what has the highest sales inside of
phones
and sort it and now i can see quickly
the detailed information
without having to change my
visualization
let's give this visualization a little
more depth
first i'll add back in all of our
categories and subcategories
by showing across region
so we know technology had the highest
but how does it look across region now
part of the point of tableau is to allow
the users to read the visualizations
very quickly and when you have big
blocks of text like this it's kind of
hard to see which one has the highest
because it doesn't quite stand out very
quickly
so what we can do
is take
sales and drag it onto color
let's change our marks to a square and
now it's going to color each of these it
colors every one of these cells based on
its darkness for sales this is a little
bit heavy of a color you can click color
here and change the opacity to give it a
little bit
of a lighter look
just makes it a little bit see-through
great so now it's a lot easier to see
that the west seems to have the highest
sales
and that technology in the east is the
very highest so now when we drill into
subcategory it keeps that coloring and
we can see more in depth and quicker
that phones has the highest across most
of them it's not quite the highest in
the west because chairs is the highest
in the west
there's one place in tableau where
hierarchies are built in
and that's in dates so dates in tableau
can be very complex because they allow
very complex visualizations so we will
not go into depth about dates at this
time but let's take a look at how they
work for hierarchies so we have order
date that we can pull onto columns here
and you can see that it's blue meaning
that it's discrete so each one of these
is a header instead of it being an axis
across the top
now let's drag
profit
onto rows
so now we can see our profit
over time for each of these years
and tableau has some hierarchies built
into dates already so when i click this
plus on columns it'll split it out into
quarters so this is a header and these
are all sub headers underneath that
header because it is distinct um and
discrete right now instead of continuous
so it's split out year year year year
and quarters quarters quarters quarters
this allows you to quickly compare
quarter one across all of the years and
quarter two across all the years and
quarter four across all the years
another way you could add some more
detail to this is by taking maybe
category and pulling out a color and now
we have one line for each category and
we can see that a drop in technology
is a big part of the responsibility for
that drop we were seeing in quarter two
of 2016. so let's take that back off and
let's take quarter back off
and let's explore continuous dates so
here in dates we have our top section of
dates and then you see it repeats and we
have the bottom section of dates so
we've got year but we also have year
here quarter and quarter now the top
ones are all discrete and when i change
it to a bottom one
year same thing same here it changes it
to be green and now it's continuous
so now instead of this being a header
for 2013 and a header for 2014 it's an
axis so the difference here is when i
press the plus and then changes it to
quarter instead of adding quarter to
year now it's doing quarter four each
year and making one continuous line and
we can keep going
and drill down to month
you can go pretty far
now when we add category as color we get
our three lines for the three categories
and we also have highlighting turned on
here still so when we click on
technology we can highlight technology
with the others in the background so we
don't lose the context of the other
categories
let's take that back off
next let us talk about calculated fields
so we'll make a new sheet and we're
going to create our first calculated
field we can create a calculated field
by clicking this arrow which gives us
some options and clicking create
calculated field or we can come and
click in the white space below
dimensions or below measures and we
right click and click create calculated
field let's name it
profit ratio so this is for if we wanted
to create a visualization that showed
the profit ratio but we don't have that
measure readily available to us to bring
in fields for our calculation you can do
it in one of two ways one is to start
typing it
and it will start auto prompting you for
the different measures or for different
calculations or
values you can use or you can come and
drag it in so if we want profit and we
want sales if we do profit divided by
sales that is
a profit ratio
unaggregated
okay and let's make a second calculated
field we could come here and click
duplicate
and that will duplicate our field but i
just want to start over again so i'll
click create calculated field
and i will call it profit
ratio
aggregated
and in this one we're going to do sum
click
of profit
click divided by
sum of sales
okay so now what's the difference
between profit ratio
aggregated and profit ratio on
aggregated how will those behave
differently in tableau let's look at
this by looking at a single
order so first let's bring on all the
orders and all the products
under that order and let's look at this
order
so
i want to filter this whole dashboard to
only this order so i can right click on
it and click keep only that creates a
filter up here that only has that box
checked
and if i want to get rid of this later
i can just pull it right off of filters
and everything will come back but i want
to so
keep only
and now let's take a look at profit
ratio aggregated i double clicked on it
and i added it here
and profit ratio unaggregated again
double clicking another side by side
let's give us a little bit more room
so when i dragged that out it gave us
more room so we could see them side by
side and the entire titles okay so i
chose to look at one order and these
product names because the combination of
order and product name is unique one per
row we know that tableau will aggregate
the data up to the lowest level in the
visualization and i brought it all the
way down to the lowest level of the data
source so we have no aggregation right
now
so when we're looking at it without any
aggregation these two calculations are
the same profit ratio aggregated let's
look at that again we'll click edit and
that's the one where we sum profit and
some sales before we divide
and then we've got profit ratio
unaggregated so let's also look at
profit and look at sales this is a
technique that i use when i'm trying to
understand how my calculated fields are
working try to break it down to the
lowest level possible and see if it's
doing what i expect
so we've got profit and we've got sales
now both of them are at
0.5 or 50 percent and that's because
profit is 8 and sales 616 for adam's
telephone messaging
now
let's take off product name
when we take off product name we can see
that they start to vary we've got profit
ratio aggregated and profit ratio
unaggregated so here we have profit and
sales the profit ratio should be profit
divided by sales so let's open up a
calculator
and make it a little smaller
so if we take profit at
219.1
and divide it by sales at 508.6
we get
0.4 not 1.8 so where does this 1.8 come
from
well let's put product name back on here
what happens is with profit ratio
aggregated it sums up the profit and
then divides it by the sum of sales so
that's what we did when we took off
profit ratio and aggregated we had the
sum of profit and divided it by the sum
of sales which is what we want profit
ratio unaggregated however
does the calculation profit divided by
sales and then
sums it afterwards you can see it right
here it's the sum of profit ratio on
aggregated so it makes this calculation
and then
it adds up 0.5 plus 0.5 plus 0.3 plus
0.5
and that's where we get our 1.8 which is
what we see
when we pull off product name 1.8 so for
most calculations you want to do profit
ratio aggregated
where you determine how it's aggregated
before you do the calculation
so let's remove profit ratio on
aggregated
and
delete it let's go to profit ratio
aggregated
and just call it profit ratio
perfect now we no longer need anything
that we have on our visualization right
now so let me show you a quick trick to
clear the board tableau has this button
up here which is called clear sheet you
can also do on windows alt shift
backspace and you just click clear sheet
and it will start you over with that
sheet and that really helps when you've
dragged a bunch of things on and really
made a mess when you're trying things
out okay so we're going to build a
visualization and we're going to look at
region and we're going to look at it by
profit ratio and so now we have this bar
chart by profit ratio let's color this
by region we can also pull on profit and
sales and we can see all three of them
side by side split out by region
now let's say we also wanted to see
each region
by sales per customer so let's create
some calculated fields that will help us
do that let's create our first
calculated field that's going to get us
a count of customers
let's call it total
number of customers
and so we have customer name and
customer id let's do
count distinct
of customer id and that gives us the
total number of customers
apply so right now we could take total
number of customers and see which
categories have the highest number of
customers perfect but that's just one
part of our calculation we want to see
total sales divided by total number of
customers so let's make our second
calculated field and we're going to call
it
sales per customer
we're going to do our sum
of sales
which we can drag in
and divide that by
total number of customers now you see
that calculated field we just made pops
up inside of our calculation
dialog box and we hit apply
and it shows up so we hit ok and let's
replace
total number of customers
with sales per customer and now we can
see our sales per customer ratio and
which ones have the highest or for this
next part i'm going to make a couple of
visualizations in a row that all applied
to the same information using a couple
of different tactics so
first
let's use show me so i want to look at
region and sales for this visualization
so i'm going to control click
region
after i clicked sales so one more time
i'm going to
click on sales and i'm going to control
click region
and i'm going to click show me and it's
going to give me all of the different
visualizations i could make with region
and sales let's pick
tree map
great so now we have a tree map that
shows us our sales
by region
and we have the size and the color of
the box is both sales so let's say we
wanted the size to be sales but the
color to be profit so let's grab profit
and drag that on to sales so now we can
see our most profitable to our least
profitable let's
edit our colors and we're going to
change it from red to blue diverging red
to blue but let's go to advanced and
make the center number
zero
this means that it will never be red
unless it's less than zero so let's hit
apply so it's all blue and if anything
ever goes negative then it will be red
okay let's call this sheet
sales profit buy region
perfect
now we're going to start using our
geographical
fields so we have state city country and
postal code let's double click on state
and see what happens
awesome so it is
generated these two fields tableau has
generated longitude and latitude for us
and it's been able to recognize the
states in the united states and where
they're located and given it a longitude
and latitude
so next we will
look at sales
by state by double clicking on sales and
what it's done was change the size of
the dot based on sales now i think i'm
going to move sales from size to color
and it has automatically changed it to a
filled map instead of dots on a map
perfect so now we can see the states
with the
biggest amount of sales let's put it
back onto size and we have our circles
again
let's put sales on to size not stayed
onto size and we have our circles again
but let's make them a little bit bigger
these two marks on the tableau size line
are to give you an idea of how big and
how small you should go before it gets
too difficult to see so when we go
bigger than the bigger line it detects
that you're getting close to having
overlap
but it's up to you as the builder okay
so we have size for
sales again and for profit on to color
again so you can see
anything that is more profitable is
darker and anything that is less
profitable
or less than zero in this case is orange
let's do what we did with color before
change it to
red blue diverging
and set our center point to zero okay so
now we know that if anything is red it
was negative in profit perfect let's
name this sheet
sales
profit
by state
great now let's look at sales and profit
by category so we have category and
we've made columns so
this is when we drag something to the
columns shelf just remember we want one
column per category
and let's double click on sales and it's
going to put it into text and that's not
what i want so let's take sales and drag
it onto rows and it automatically makes
a bar chart so now we have one bar with
the axis of sales for furniture office
supplies and technology
now let's
take profit and also put it on
rows so now we have two bar charts one
for sales and one for profit we can
change which one is a bar and which one
is maybe a bubble chart
by clicking on its appropriate marks
card so if we want to change them both
we can click on all
and change them both to maybe circles
and you can see how they go up and down
but if we want to just change
one of them let's put those back to
automatic we'll go to profit and change
that one to
the circles so now we can see
those profit numbers and if we want them
to be overlaid on the same area we would
right click on profit the second measure
on the rows and click dual axis so now
let's put them onto the same axis you
can see that their axes are not lined up
let's go to sales and change it back to
a bar
so now we have two charts occupying the
same space
one of them is a bar chart and one of
them is a bubble chart and we can see
our sales versus our profit at least
they're not the same amount of dollars
obviously but we can see a higher sales
and a higher profit we also have medium
sales and a medium profit we have a
medium sales but a really low profit and
it's interesting to see that contrast so
let's rename this sheet
as
sales
profit
by category
and
finally we're going to make our details
sheet so we're going to go down to
subcategory level and bring it onto rows
and remember subcategory can expand out
to the actual products let's bring that
back in and we're going to bring sales
onto columns which makes us a sales bar
chart and profit onto columns which
makes it a profit bar chart now let's
color them by their appropriate
individual color so we'll go to the
sales marks card and drag sales onto
color
now sales is colored by sales we'll do
the same thing here we did before
we'll go red blue diverging
[Music]
and make the center
zero we actually don't have to do that
for sales because sales will never be
negative but it's pretty important for
profit so we'll go to the profit marks
card and take profit onto color
and do the same thing there
we have red blue diverging
advanced center is zero great
so now if it's negative it will be there
so let's sort this
by profit and so both of them have
sorted with profit in mind and we can
easily see our subcategories that have a
negative profit
rename this
and we'll call it our details sheet
so now we have these four visualizations
that all have to do with similar
information
i think i want these bigger on the
states so we'll just keep making that
bigger perfect now we're going to make
our first dashboard so for our dashboard
we have
information over here that shows you
what sheets you can bring on these get a
little bit more complex so they'll be
covered in more in-depth type of videos
and then we have our size so
we could make a range of sizes based on
um maybe what you're viewing this on but
we're just going to change it to a fixed
size
and we're going to make it
1400
by
a thousand and this is our
dashboard size so let's bring on sales
profit by region sales and profit by
state now a map needs a little bit more
horizontal space than region does let's
bring sales and profit by category
underneath the region
and the detail underneath the state give
our map more space again perfect
now tableau has this neat feature called
uses filter so you can click use this
filter here and now if i click on any of
these it will filter the other
dashboards based on these features so if
i just want to look at the south and i
click on south it zooms into all my
south states now my categories have
updated to be just the south ones and my
details have updated as well so
we could see that central has pretty big
sales you know bigger than the south but
the profit is lower than the south so we
can click on central and focus on
central
let's use
that uses filter
on all three of these
dashboards that lead us up to the detail
so building a quick dashboard like this
let's make this taller would allow you
to do
some sort of analysis such as let's take
a look at central because they have
relatively high profits but low sales so
we click on central and then we see oh
man texas is having a really hard time
so let's click on texas and now we're
seeing in texas that we have
negative profit in these categories so
we can control click on furniture and
office supplies and we can see all of
our products that are really just
killing us in texas all of our
subcategories and if we want to go
deeper into products we'll just click
that plus sign and now we see all the
products and we'll sort again
and we can see all the products by
subcategory that are really just killing
us and are maybe not worthwhile to make
anymore so we're gonna have to
reconsider making the 3.6 cubic foot
counter height office refrigerator at
least for texas it's not very helpful
there and then when you
back out of that subcategory section you
can also click
somewhere neutral in the dashboard or
click on each thing that you had
selected to unselect it and go back to
the main part of your visualization and
start it all over again now let's move
on and take a look on how to create
parameters and sets so new sheet
and let's make a quick visualization
that we'll apply our parameters and our
sets too
so let's take a look at all of our
customers
by their sales and let's sort customer
name descending by sales great so now
we're going to make a parameter that
will allow the user of the dashboard to
choose how many customers they want to
see how many of our top customers that
they want to see
so let's click this down arrow and click
create parameter
and we will name it
top and customers
great we're going to make it an integer
and we're going to give them the option
to choose the number of customers within
a range our low is going to be 5 so
we'll let them see 5
or up to 20
and we're going to let them skip with
step size of 5. let's start their
current value right in the middle with
10.
okay so now if you want to see how this
parameter looks you can come down to
parameters before we only had dimensions
and measures on the left side of our
tableau workspace but now we have
parameters that has appeared once we
create a parameter we can right click on
the parameter and click show parameter
control and we can see our top end
customers right now our parameter
control isn't built into any of our
visualizations but you can see how it
works we allow them to go down to 5
and
up to 20 with steps of 5.
great now we're going to create a set a
set is a custom field that defines a
subset of data based on some conditions
so the set we're going to build is going
to be based on customer name so when you
right click on customer name you can
come down and click create hover on
create and create a set with so far when
we created a parameter and a calculated
field you clicked here
with this down arrow and you saw create
calculated field and create parameter
but it's not there a set has to be based
on an existing field so you come and you
click on the field you want it to be
based on and then hover on create and
you see set
so here's how we can create a set let's
name it
top and
customers
by sales so we're going to allow them to
select the top end customers and have
that select our top customers by sales
so we want this set to include anything
that is in the top however many they
defined by the parameter
by sales so you can come over here to
top
and change it to by field we want it to
be top but not just top static 10 we're
going to click here and our parameter
shows up so it's going to be top top end
customers
and then you can choose
another field here for it to be defined
by and it's sales and we want it to be
by sum of sales
if we wanted it to be by
the average profit we can come here and
click profit and change this to average
and now we would see our top end
customers buy average profit
but we want sales and some
okay so we've created our set and we can
drag it on to rows to see how it works
and we can see these are our top 10
customers by their sales and we have
this in slash out
that's generated by our set so if we
take our set
first let's see how this line moves when
we change our number here so right now
it's 10 when we move it up we see our
line moves down to include the top 15
and now we can quickly see our top 20.
we'll go back to 10
and let's grab the set and drag it onto
our filters so now we have filtered the
data down to our top 10. if this were
applied to a dashboard this would allow
the end user to see the top 10 quickly
and then maybe expand it out to the top
20 if they're interested in that
information now let's move on to
creating a donut chart so a donut chart
is basically a pie chart with a white
center so let's start by building a pie
chart which in tableau is pretty easy
especially if you use show me so let's
create a pie chart for each category
by sales so you're going to click
category and then we're going to control
click sales so we have them both
selected we'll come over to show me and
click
pie and there we have our pie chart
we'll close show me let's come up here
and click entire view so we see our pie
very clearly here if we wanted to have
one pie for each
region we can take region and drag that
onto columns
so we have one column for each region
and then one pie for each of them you
can see that the pie varies in size
based on sales as well as the angle is
for sales so east has more sales in
general than south
and this helps you to see that
technology
has smaller sales in the south than it
does in the east so i recommend keeping
if you're going to make pie charts
allowing the size of the pie chart to be
affected as well as the angle by
whatever measure you're using but for
our purposes for donut charts we're
going to want them to all be the same
size so we took sales off of
size and now we have all of our pie
charts the same size now we're going to
make what's called a dual axis chart and
to make a dual axis chart we have to
have two axes so let's grab
number of records and we'll grab it and
drag it to rows and we will change it
from sum to minimum and that's because
every record will have a minimum number
of rows of one and then they all end up
on the same axis great and now we're
going to make a second number of records
by minimum and we can do that by doing
those steps again by dragging number of
records up here and changing it to
minimum again
or a quick trick that i can show you is
if you want to
duplicate anything you have on the chart
here you can just hit control and then
click and drag it and it will duplicate
it so if you wanted your number of
records to also be down here onto your
details or on your labels you can
control click it and then leave it there
great so now we have our two axes and we
have our two marks cards that each
affect their own
set of visualizations so let's go to
this top one affects these so let's show
that by changing the size
and it's made these bigger and this
bottom one affects these and we'll do
that by changing it to
circle so now each of these are a circle
let's take category off of color and we
can take some of sales off of detail and
let's change the color to white
and now we're going to put this white
circle on top of our pie chart by
clicking here on our second measure
and clicking dual axis and now it's got
them lined up one on top of the other
and we have our donut chart so we want
our donut
slices to be a little thinner we can
change the size of our inner circle and
make it bigger
perfect and so now we have one pie chart
for each region one doughnut chart for
each region and if we wanted to take
this header and put it inside of our pie
chart what we can do is take region and
put it on the label for the circle and
it's putting it down here
you can come and edit that by clicking
on label and changing its alignment
so let's put it in the middle
perfect so now we can see
our header here so we don't need it down
here anymore you can right click and
click
show header and it hides that header we
also don't want to see our labels for
our axes so we right click and click
show header there and now we just see
our pies
so to get how the number of sales here
for each of them let's go to
remember our pie marks card and let's
take our sales and add it to label so
now each of our slices of pie
can tell you how much sales they have if
you take the sales here that's on label
right click and click format we can
change that to currency
and let's get rid of our decimal places
perfect now close formatting and let's
say we want the total amount of sales to
be in the middle here with central so we
go back to affecting our circle grab
sales drag it to label
so now we have four doughnut charts
formatted to allow us to quickly see the
sales numbers
for each segment and also for the donut
as a whole you can also change the
colors the tableau selects for each
slice by coming to the marks card that
has color for the pie so category color
and clicking edit colors and you could
change it to
any of these automatic ones
where if you double click on one it
gives you all of the options for colors
that you could possibly want there's
also several different palettes you
could choose from so let's say we like
this one and you can just click assign
palette and it will grab those off of
there those look very similar to what we
have already so i'm going to pick a
different one
and click assign palette click apply
and this allows you to make some color
changes and you fit your business a
little bit more
specifically
perfect let's say
we make our
pies bigger
increase that size
and we'll also increase the center size
oh not that much perfect
now we'll use a similar technique to
create the two-dimensional pie chart
a two-dimensional pie chart can be used
so that you can show
two pie charts at the same time or a pie
chart that's kind of split up by
different categories this has been
available in some other tools and
tableau can do it too so let's just
demonstrate that we're going to start
again by creating our
generic
category by sales so with control click
sales we come over to show me and click
pie and it makes our pie for us it
remembers the colors that you have
determined in other pages so that's a
nice feature again let's make it entire
view so we can see our pie nice and big
and now we're going to
create our dual axis again so we grab
number of records put it on rows and see
how it adds an axis but each one of
these categories has a different value
for the number of records however they
have the same minimum
value for number of records and it puts
them all right back onto the same spot
great and then we will control click and
drag to make our two axes and let's come
to our top one
and make it bigger
that affected both of them because we
still have sales on size
for both of them
so sales is affecting the size of the
pie chart as well as the size of the
angles so let's take sales off of size
for both of them
and make the second pie chart a little
smaller perfect now let's also affect
our second pie chart by having the color
defined by region instead of defined by
sales let's talk about how i'm replacing
it with region so you could change the
color by dragging region onto color and
that replaces it or let's go back and we
can drag region right on top of the
thing we're trying to replace and it
will replace it there
great so now we have the smaller circle
that's going to go on top split up by
region with the angle defined by sales
and the category is on the top one with
the angle defined by sales let's pick
some nicer colors
maybe we'll use the same palette we used
for
category
this one this one seems right but we'll
pick different ones than those three so
we click on the one we want to change
and click on the color we want to change
it to i'm just going to keep following
this right down
click apply great and then we
put it on top of the other one by
clicking dual axes now sometimes it's
easier to see these when they have a
border so we can come to color we click
border and add maybe some black lines
to allow you to see the inner pie
separate from the outer pie
maybe
our border could have white lines how
does that look
and we can make them both bigger
like we did before
well not that big
and you can also add labels like we did
before
we'll take sales onto our labels here
and you can see that hovering allows you
to see all the information you need now
one more thing so while we like to hide
this axis
we'd also like to maybe hide this grid
line that's occurring so you can click
right click and format and let's go to
our line
that changed that zero line to none
perfect get rid of some of the clutter
on this visualization i still feel like
this outer pie should be a little bigger
and we want to clean up our tool tip so
it doesn't have min number of records in
it this piece should be 100 behind the
scenes so we can come to tooltip right
as you click on it it'll pop up with
everything that's in your tool tip and
we're just going to erase
mid number of records i erased too much
you need to leave your angle brackets
okay and now this piece of the pie no
longer has that the inner one let's do
that there too
min number of records remove that right
out
and there you have it a two-dimensional
pie chart and here are our donut charts
this demonstration goes to show you that
even when tableau doesn't have
visualization you're looking for in
their basic show me options you can
still get to it so donut charts aren't
included up here and neither is a
two-dimensional pie chart but without
too much extra work we can make it
happen
these visualizations are a little bit
more complex than your everyday
visualizations and so i recommend going
through this tutorial with the data set
and following along if you want access
to the data set just comment below and
the simply learned team will get back to
you also comment below with any
questions you have
at this point in the presentation we're
going to put together some dashboards so
first let's build our worksheets for
this dashboard we're going to build a
worksheet
called
sales by year which adds the name up
here and we're going to
take our order date and drag it onto
columns and now we want this to be a
continuous axis so we're going to change
it to our continuous year and now we
have an axis and we're going to look at
sales
so now we have our sales by year if we
want labels on each of these dots we can
drag sales onto
labels and if we want to have different
color lines for each region for example
we can drag region onto color
and that splits our lines up
into the different regions and gives us
a legend over here perfect now we're
going to duplicate this sheet by right
clicking down here and clicking
duplicate now we have sales by year two
let's rename it to
profit
by year
and then let's drag profit right over
top of sum of sales
so that it replaces it with profit now
it's been replaced with profit and all
of these different data points are here
however it's still showing the title of
sum of sales and that can be very
confusing so always make sure that your
labels are consistent with your data so
let's take profit and drag it over top
of the type labels as well that's more
consistent with our axis
so now we have sales by year and we have
profit by year
let's do a couple of things to clean
these up
like
right click here
go format and we'll change our numbers
to
currency custom
and now it's marked as dollars
one thing you can do in tableau is let's
undo that
since
sales is going to be dollars pretty much
everywhere we use it we can define our
default property for these numbers so
when we right click on the measure here
you can go to default properties and you
have the options to change the defaults
for any of these things and we're going
to change our number format
change it to
currency custom
no decimal places hit ok and that also
has updated this sheet now that only
works on places where you haven't
specifically defined it to be formatted
differently so we could still define it
to be different here on this sheet than
it is on any other sheet
let's do the same thing for profit
change our default properties
to
the same thing great now let's build our
dashboard
we're going to call this
our
overall dashboard
change our
size
this size is a personal preference of
mine i think it fits nicely
on the laptops that i use and that is
used by most of our customers and let's
drag sales by year now watch what
happens when i drag it on here it brings
sales by year but it also brings the
legend
for the region that was created the same
thing should happen with profit by year
it's detected that the same legend is
being used so it didn't bring over a
second legend and we have highlighting
turned on let's see if this works for
both charts we click on central and you
see it highlights central in both charts
that's great so now we have a dashboard
showing us profit by year and sales by
year but let's say we want to be able to
filter this dashboard to just maybe one
category so let's go back to our sales
by year sheet
and let's drag category
onto filters
and now it's going to let us select
we're going to select all
and hit ok
and then right click on category and
click show filter so now it is over here
and we're going to do
a similar thing on profit by year but
we'll do the shortcut where you come
over here to category you right click on
it and you just click show filter and it
puts it here and it puts it here
so now we have
a filter here for category
and a filter here for category
and so when we go to overall
we can come to our
drop down here more options hover over
filters
and you can see category now here's an
interesting thing that we'll see
even though we have a category filter on
both charts when i take furniture out
you can see only sales by year changed
and profit by year stayed the same now
why would that be
that's because we have two different
filters for category one on the sales
worksheet and one on the profit by year
worksheet i'll show that
by clicking here
going to filters
and grab category now we have category
that will affect
profit by year and not sales by year
that's not what we want we want one
filter to affect them both so
let's back it up a bit
take these back off let's go to profit
by year now we're going to take off
category let's go to sales by year and
we're going to say we want this same
filter to affect both worksheets so
we're going to right click here hover
over apply to worksheets and click
selected worksheets now we select sales
by year is selected and we select profit
by year okay so when we go to
the profit by year sheet
you can see that it now has category on
there let's go to overall let's come
here
filters category and now we have a
filter
that affects both worksheets
there we go let's format this filter a
little bit we'll come to more options
and we're going to select we want them
to be able to select multiple values
still but let's do it in a drop down
so now
you still have those options
but it is a little bit more compact
let's do
a couple more filters so we can do by
category
let them filter out regions
let's do it the the shorter way right
click show filter there it is
apply to worksheets
selected worksheets
both of these
okay
dashboard
filters and by region
multiple values drop down and let's let
them
change their
time selection so this one's a little
bit different since we've already
determined that we wanted year and we
wanted it to be continuous filters for
continuous
fields are a little bit different than
filters for
these
discrete fields and that's because
continuous fields are a range instead of
just a list so we don't list out a
continuous field we make a range for it
so we've already defined that we want it
to be continuous year and if i come over
here
and click on right click order date and
click show filter it's doing discrete
year by default
so
remove filter if you drag order date
onto filters
it lets you pick what you want it to
look at
um let's come up here to year that's
already marked as continuous and click
show filter and now it is year but it's
based on a range and we have this slider
and you can see how that slider affects
our visualization
let me show you a trick to make this
apply to both not a trick but just if
you have not applied it to both
worksheets but you already added it to
the visualization see it's here but it's
only affecting one worksheet you can
change
the worksheets
settings right on the filter instead of
having to go to the worksheet where the
filter exists
and it will only give you the options of
the worksheets that are on the dashboard
so there we have it
now it affects both and now we have our
overall dashboard
now let's say you want to be able to see
the total sales on this chart as well as
the sales split up by
each of the regions we can do that as
well so let's go back to our sales sheet
as a quick tip you can go to the sheet
by clicking this go to sheet button here
or here
in the event that you want to go to a
sheet but you don't want to scroll back
and forth to find where it is so go to
sheet now we're going to do a dual
access chart again like we showed
earlier and i'm going to control
click and drag
so now we have sum of sales twice
this marks card affects the top one so
we can see that by
if i change the opacity
how it changes the color right here this
is the top one
and this marks card is the bottom one
and we're going to remove region
off of color and that makes our combined
one line again perfect now if we want
this to be on the same space as this we
right click here the second measure in
the rows section and click dual axis so
let's put it right on top i can see this
versus this now if we wanted to on hover
show that this is overall sales we can
click on tool tip region is missing
because we don't have it with the color
by region anymore so we'll erase that
and put
oh we don't want it to be orange let's
make it black
overall sales okay so when you hover
here it says overall sales so we can see
the difference easily let's make it um a
little bit more of a color that'll stand
out just a little darker than the others
perhaps
so when we go back to our work all right
dashboard we can see sales and we can
see our overall sales let's do the same
thing for profit by year
go to sheet and
control
drag release
we'll go to our marks card for this
second sheet and pull off region
make it darker
change our tool tip
not orange
overall
profit
okay
and right click
dual access
there we go now i forgot to do one thing
on the last dashboard when you make a
dual access dashboard it doesn't
necessarily
um sync up these axes and so this axis
over here is for the overall line and
this axis over here is for the region
line
so if we want it to stay that way we
should
edit our axes
and instead of calling it just profit
over here
we'll change it to overall profit
and over here
profit by region
just so that it's clear which axis goes
to the which one
or you can come here and click
synchronize axes so it's very clear that
this is much bigger than these
and if you synchronize the axes
let's go back before we named him
okay synchronize the axis then we don't
need both of these headers so we can
come here and click show header and we
just have the one let's do the same
thing on sales by year
synchronize
always good to make sure that your axes
are either synchronized or well labeled
and let's hide it let's see what it
looks like now
great
okay one thing to keep in mind
when we do
filter
to just one region
the lines are going to end up at the
same spot
if we filter to two
then it's only the sum of those two
so
perhaps the header overall sales and
overall profit isn't quite accurate
because it isn't overall necessarily
when we have it filtered um why does
this happen
why doesn't this line always show the
total no matter what you select here
well that's because this filter applies
to the whole dashboard so it filters
this line to those regions just as much
as it filters these lines
so i'm going to remove out that tooltip
line because it could be a little
misleading
let's continue on and make a dashboard
that digs a little bit more into sales
specifically great so we'll make our
first sheet we'll call it
sales by region
and we're going to make another pie
chart so
let's do it using show me we'll click on
region
and then we will control click on sales
open up show me click pi let's close it
again great so now we have the sales by
region pi we'll make it the entire view
and when you hover you can see that it's
showing us sales
in dollar amounts now it would be
more
like a pie for it to be percentages so a
lot of pies each of these slices is
shown as a percentage of the whole
at one hundred percent so let's come
here to our slice size we'll right click
on it and we're going to use what's
called a quick table calculation
and change it to percent of total so now
when you hover you can see that the west
is 31
of the pie
great
let's also label each of these slices so
i'm going to control click and drag
region onto label
and add region to the labels i'm going
to undo that and show you what would
happen if i just dragged region onto
labels without copying it without
holding control it will move it
and get rid of our colors and we don't
want that so we're going to control and
drag another way to do this go back is
by taking region and dragging it onto
label just straight from over here but
in this case for the sum of sales where
we've applied the quick table
calculation we want that quick table
calculation to also show up in our label
so i'm going to control and drag and it
brings that quick table calculation
along with it if i were to
undo just drag sales on it's going to go
back to that dollar amount and i'm going
to have to add another quick table
calculation so instead ctrl and drag
that's probably one of my very favorite
tableau tricks great now let's add a
filter for region so i'm going to right
click here and click show filter and we
will make sure that this gets added to
all of our sheets once we've made them
all
okay next sheet we're going to call this
sheet
sales by state
let's do a map
great so um one way to get your map
started is to double click on any of
these dimensions that have a globe next
to them so since we want to go with
state we can double click on state
and it starts mapping out state so what
it does is it adds latitude and
longitude to our rows and columns that
are generated here
and another way to get going so let's go
back is to click on the geographic part
you want and then control click on sales
like we did for
map sorry for our pie chart come over to
show me and choose one of our maps we
could do it with the circles but we're
gonna do a field map
click on that so now we have our field
map based on state
we can choose one of these different
palettes if we'd like let's try this
one or blue teal
or we could do green so that darker
green means more money
great so now we have all of our states
colored by sales let's also control and
drag sales onto label
and you can see we have the dollar sign
and the money formatting that we made
earlier and let's control and drag state
onto label
now maybe we want the state to be on top
so we can click on label and it pops up
with all these different options and if
we want to edit the text you can click
here
on the ellipses
and edit it there so let's cut state
and paste it at the top there i think i
lost my center alignment so we'll do
that again hit apply see what we think
great okay so now you can see that it
puts the state on top you can also see
in some of these places where they're
super close together that you can't see
all of the state's labels and that's
because
this option here in labels is unchecked
allow labels to overlap other marks so
tableau senses when the marks are too
close together and it's going to become
too hard to read and we'll hide anything
that overlaps with each other if we
click this option now you see everything
but it gets a little crowded over here
so let's unselect that and you'll be
able to see what the sales are upon
hover
great now we have our sales by state
for filters for this one let's no let's
right click on sales here and click show
filter so basically wherever you're
using your metrics your dimensions or
your measures you can right click on
them
and create your filters um so now we
could
the lowest amount for a state is 920
for sales for this time period and we
could filter out ones that have sales
lower than that but
i think this isn't what i want let's
remove that filter let's do it for the
state show filter great so now we could
filter out
a state we could just show
arizona
or show them all
excellent let's move on to our next
visualization
new sheet rename it to be called
sales by
sub category
great so we're going to drag on category
onto columns and subcategory we could
either drag on subcategory here or
because of our hierarchy press plus now
we have subcategory and category and
let's bring on sales it's defaulting to
this bar chart which is perfect that's
what i want and now we could color it by
subcategory and this is a discrete
coloring we could also color it by
sales
and this is a continuous coloring so the
darkest corresponds with the height now
we don't need to do this there is
already an indicator of who has the most
sales and that's based on the bar height
so if we wanted to color it by
subcategory then each one of them gets
their own color we could color it by
category to
add to
the distinction between the different
categories so that's very clear
where they start and stop let's do
by subcategory excellent so now we have
three different dashboards oh let's add
some filters for subcategory so let's
bring on
category as our filter so we'll right
click here click show filter there's
category and
let's do a filter for
our date so we're going to come here to
order date let's drag it onto filters
and let's click years
now these are all the years options
we'll click all and hit ok right click
here and click show filter
so now instead of doing a range where we
could drag that line now we have
discrete filter and so we can check and
uncheck boxes to choose what years we
want to see
awesome let's start with our dashboard
let's call this dashboard
our sales dashboard and
change our size
if you have any questions about
different sizes what's available here be
sure to ask that in the comments below
and let's start with pulling on our
sales by region so last time we pulled
on a chart we saw that it added the
legend for us
but this time you can see it added both
the legends
and the filter so last time we created
the filters after we built the dashboard
but this time you can see that the
filter
um gets brought in when we brought in
the dashboard let's do our sales by
state side by side here and let's do
sales by subcategory underneath so i
dragged it you can see how i pull it
towards the bottom of the dashboard and
it kind of fills in the space where it's
going to be
and then brings it in so now it's
brought in all our filters and all of
our legends it defaults to putting the
filters and legends over here we're
going to click select layout layout
container it's going to select what's
what they're all inside of and we're
going to make it take up this whole side
but it doesn't need that much space
so you can see in tableau there's a lot
of dragging there's a lot of dropping
and
a lot of resizing to get things the way
you want them to be give our map more
room
and we have a mixture over here of
legends and
filters let's move our legends out of
there so we can grab this legend and
come and put it on this side
and this legend come and put it over
here
so that we're getting a little bit more
near the visualizations they belong to
this legend goes up here with this one
i'm going to actually click here and
change it from
a tiled so right here it says tiled
object to a floating object that lets it
sit on top of a visualization i'm going
to put it on top of this visualization
right up here
excellent and then we have this one
that's showing us the size of sales
that's because on this dashboard it says
that size is determined by sales but
since it's just one
circle there's no size comparison so
it's not like we have several circles
and we have to look and see which one's
the biggest so that we can tell that the
amount of sales so we don't need this
legend and we can just remove it from
the dashboard let's clean up some of
these we have several different versions
of what your filters could look like so
my personal favorite is multiple values
drop down it gives you some of the most
flexibility but if you wanted them to
only be able to select a single value
you could turn it into a radio button
list so that it's a selected all or it's
one at a time
you could also do a drop down or a
slider and make that happen
a slider is a little bit different from
a range on the range you can see that we
could edit either side and it's picking
everything in between but with discrete
values if you say everything in between
it doesn't make a lot of sense because
what's everything between furniture and
technology we don't know that office
supplies goes between those there's no
order so
let's do
multiple value drop downs
for big ones like state there is the
option
of searching so i know i want utah and i
search and there's utah
instead of having to scroll through the
list this could be really helpful for if
you had a filter for by products and
that would allow somebody to look at
just one product at a time if they know
their name of the product but also not
have to just open up the product list
and scroll and scroll and scroll since
there are very a lot of products so we
can filter by region by doing this oh
this is a great reminder you saw that
this did not change all the
visualizations we have yet to apply
these filters to all the worksheets so
let's do that right now apply to
worksheets selected worksheets and we
will click all on dashboard hit okay
we'll do this again
[Music]
until we have selected them all
great so it's really nice you get to
choose what worksheets you wanted to
apply to because in the event that you
had maybe um a total number up here at
the top that you just wanted to stay the
same all the time no matter what they
selected you could make that happen by
not selecting that worksheet to be
changed by these filters okay great so
we can change what region we're looking
at by
selecting central here and then we're
just looking at central throughout all
the visualizations i love looking at it
on a map and seeing just one at a time
it just really makes the region name
just stand out to you but if we wanted
to use this as our filter to filter the
rest of the dashboards we can click this
uses filter button and now when we click
on central here it stays in context here
but the other two dashboards change
one thing you may notice is that texas
is not the darkest on this chart because
of the scale the scale goes up to half a
million there but then when we click on
central the scale updates just for
what's selected so everything else is
filtered out and now the darkest of the
dark is only 170 thousand dollars and
texas becomes the darkest on the
visualization there are some ways you
can change that but if you're wondering
why do my colors look a little
differently when i filter that's why
great we could also click use this
filter here so if we just wanted to look
at texas we click this this updates to
just central this updates to just texas
down here and unselect
by
clicking on maybe another state or when
you click on the state again it should
unselect and we could do the same thing
here or if we just want to look at one
subcategory and say
let me scroll down a bit storage now
everything updates to the storage it's
interesting i wouldn't have known very
quickly that there are some states that
didn't have any storage sales but now
when we click on storage we can tell i
showed you before that you can control
click and look at binders and storage
and it puts those two together also in
tableau you can drag
and we could select all of these so we
have art binders envelopes fasteners
labels paper and storage and none of
those are getting sold here
i don't know what's up with wyoming
excellent so now we have our sales
dashboard and
let's get started on our next one our
next dashboard is going to be the profit
version of this dashboard so some of
these visualizations we can use again so
let's go to sales by region right click
and click duplicate
rename it to
profit by region
now you have to be careful whenever you
go to reuse a visualization because like
i mentioned before you got to make sure
everywhere
that sales is used you have to replace
it with profit i'm also going to drag
this sheet to be
more at the end here after the sales
dashboard just to keep them separate so
that we have the sheets that lead up to
overall than the sheets that lead up to
sales and then we'll have the sheets
that lead up to profit great so we'll
grab profit and drag it onto angle size
and that updates the angle size drag it
onto the size of the circle shouldn't
make a difference since we only have one
circle and onto the text now when i
dragged it on it didn't do the percent
of total anymore so let's change that to
the quick table calculation of percent
of total for there and for
the label
percent of total there we go now we have
our percent total again by region region
okay here's another thing since we
duplicated that filter it's going to be
using that exact same filter
you see it's using region from sales by
region all the sales dashboards but we
don't want that so let's remove out all
the filters here
and these action filters that are
generated by our filtering that those
come from
this
these are called action filters
and it's generated when we click this
uses filter button okay back to profit
by region great we're clear of filters
and let's add back in
a region filter and this one no longer
has the icon
that shows you that it affects multiple
sheets which is what we want for now so
you might want perhaps there would be a
situation where you would have two
dashboards and you would want these
filters that you put on here to affect
both dashboards and in this case that's
not what i want great so another one we
can use the basics for is sales by
subcategory so let's duplicate that
great profit by subcategory already
exists we made this earlier tableau will
not allow you to make a worksheet that
has the same name as another worksheet
you can
call it number one or since it does put
the title up here you can put an extra
space at the end or it does detect that
space it counts it as a different title
even though it's the same title just
with a space that does cause some issues
so like when we're looking here and
we're saying oh profit by subcategory i
want that oh this is when we made it but
you don't want this one you want this
one and it gets a little confusing the
nice thing is when you're dragging
things onto your dashboard when you
hover you should get a little picture
here of what dashboard what
visualization you're looking at it
really helps you to make your decisions
and not just have to do it by name if
you're a little bit disorganized and you
have all of these called sheet 5 sheet 7
you won't know exactly what that is
right away so that little preview is
very helpful great profit by subcategory
we'll do the same thing by removing out
all our filters so i just click on it
and hit delete
you can also control click
and then hit delete or you can drag them
off into a space that's not the
visualization space great and we only
have some of sales right there so we'll
change that to profit
and we have some negative profits there
we'll keep the colors the same for
consistency between the two dashboards
and let's bring on
category as a filter okay
show filter there we are
and let's do our order date filter right
now order date we'll do years okay
all the years so it gives you this
option here because it assumes that
you're making a filter because you want
this dashboard to just be filtered to
your selection you can do that you can
make a filter that isn't exposed to the
end user so let's say you were making a
big dashboard and it was just focused on
furniture then and you don't want them
to be able to select a different
category for because of your analysis
you can make that happen
you can just click furniture and not
show this by clicking hide card here but
in this case we want to be able to make
this interactive
in a lot of different ways great profit
by subcategory exists now instead of our
map we're going to make an area chart
so i'll rename this and call it
profit
over time by category
so we're going to
bring on our order date into columns and
it goes to our discrete value let's
change it to our continuous value so we
get the axis let's grab our profit onto
rows and it makes this a line chart
we're going to change that to an area
chart an area chart is nice because when
you split it up by category by dragging
category onto color you can now see
what category is responsible for how
much profit like you do with a line
chart however its area is what defines
that so you can see that area over time
and do comparisons and also it stacks
them on top of each other so that you
can tell that for 2013 our profit was
around fifty thousand dollars really
quickly otherwise we have to add that
line this line here and it makes these
lines smaller and lower more difficult
to see so
back to our profit over time by category
so that's some of the benefits of having
an area chart and if we wanted to go a
little more detailed than here you hit
this plus and now we have over quarter
we have some negative profits that's
interesting but let's go back to every
the year great and for this one we're
going to make one more pie chart so we
could start from scratch or we could
duplicate our profit by region pie chart
which i'm going to do
we're going to do this for the
comparison between a pie chart and an
area chart so it's going to be profit by
category
but not over time so right now it's
profit by region let's drag category
right on top of colors there
and now it's split up
it's having some trouble because it's
splitting it by category but because of
we brought region onto text it's also
splitting it by region so we have region
region region region inside of this
category and we don't want that so we're
going to drag category right on top of
region here as well and now it's just
the three segments so whatever you have
in this marks card unless it's on
tooltips will affect your level of
detail in the visualization here when
it's on tool tips sometimes it won't
change the level of detail but it could
have an effect on like so if we brought
oh let's do this right now so right now
the level of detail of this chart does
not go to the category by
region like it did before you can bring
it onto detail here and it won't affect
color and it won't affect labels but it
will change the detail and you see how
it splits it out again this is what it
would look like if it's by region by
category and you have much more slices
to this pie we'll go back but if we take
region and put it onto tooltip it's not
at a low enough level for that tool tip
to make any sense so it's going to put
that star you see region is star that's
because this section of the pi covers
multiple regions if we filtered the
region to just central now it populates
so there are sometimes benefits to
having it in there even when
at all levels it doesn't make any sense
but we won't leave it there
excellent so you can see
how the color is what determines
is a big part of what determines how
many slices you get the level of detail
for the whole chart is a big factor as
well on how many slices you get great
profit by region profit by category by
subcategory and by
profit over time and we have
our category filter we don't have our
subcategory filter yet we grabbed
category but let's right click on
subcategory and click show filter there
we go now we have a filter for category
and subcategory
here's our region one
we have region in two places and we
don't want that
we wanted to apply it to all of them
we'll do that when we get to the
dashboard
and
we have category year of order date and
subcategory great those are all the
filters i wanted so let's build our
dashboard
we'll call this our profit dashboard
once i get it set
to the size i want
profit we'll start with profit by
region
and we'll have our profit by category
over time next to it great we'll give
that
some different space have this at the
bottom
have this underneath there
now it's bunched all these up
next to it so let's again drag it over
to the side it's always good to pay
attention to the highlighted section and
it gives you kind of an idea oh you see
i accidentally dragged an individual
filter instead of this whole section so
when i grabbed this i didn't grab all of
these so if you want to grab all these
and they happen to be inside the same
section you can come and click select a
layout container and now i'm grabbing
all of them
there we go
we'll do the same thing as before you
know what i'm going to make these
floating
because then it kind of sits inside of
that same area i'll make that one
floating
and this one too
this category
legend applies to both this chart and
this chart so that's very nice and this
subcategory legend i won't make floating
i'll just put here by subcategory
and this profit by category doesn't need
quite that much space
let's give
our bar chart some room
excellent we don't need the size of the
circles
make these
drop downs now
because i didn't have to on
this chart and this chart change profit
to dollars because we set that as the
default it definitely saved us some time
so
i recommend setting default number
formatting
at the beginning of your visualizations
really nice
excellent now you can rearrange the
order of these so i like to have the
date at the top it's sometimes hard to
get it to the top so i take it the
second to the top and i drag the top one
down and then um category above
subcategory just for logical sense
excellent and we have our profit
dashboard let's see there is this check
box down here called show dashboard
title so if we wanted to have the title
at the top here you can click that
button any floating objects
don't shift down
like everything else did
there we go
so we could have that title we could not
have that title that's up to you
excellent so at this point we have our
overall dashboard that looks at sales
and profit we have our sales dashboard
and we have our profit dashboard our
profit dashboard isn't 100 complete
because i forgot to make sure all of
these filters apply to all of these
worksheets so let's go ahead and do that
right now
applied worksheets selected worksheets
all on dashboard
one thing that is nice from this view
it's really nice to click on dashboard
and you only see the ones on the
dashboard but you can click here and say
show all worksheets in workbook
and you can see the rest here so if you
want it all on the dashboard and you
wanted this one or something like that
then you have the option to see them all
great perfect so before you ever publish
a dashboard it's always good to double
check that your filters work
when you filter to just one
year this area chart becomes a lot less
useful but if you're looking at two or
more
you start to see the shape of it
great
now we're going to take a look at
linking from our overall dashboard
to our sales dashboard
great so we'll go to our overall
dashboard and we'll be creating what's
called an action
so you can make an action
on
a worksheet
you can see right here
actions or on a dashboard actions so
since we're linking between two
dashboards this is going to be a
dashboard action
sorry just trying to unhighlight there
but if you're ever looking for an action
you made and you can't find it look in
the other one great this is our actions
dialog box here we can see the highlight
that has been generated when it says
generated next to it that means that you
didn't come in and define an action it
was made by
clicking
this highlight button here that'll
generate an action
or when we look on our sales dashboard
we clicked on this uses filter button so
we should have several actions here that
were all generated
we have a couple different kinds of
actions
when you go to make an action
there's a filter action that we see when
we click use this filter a highlight
action that we can see from here in
region and go to url action that we
haven't used if you have any questions
about go to url please post them in the
comments below
it basically allows you to be able to
select a url here and so
if you had a dashboard that had to do
with maybe stocks you could put in a url
here and then put your stock ticker
symbol there so that you could have a
url that would then take you to a
finance website that shows you your
stock information it can get pretty cool
okay but we want to
link from this dashboard to one of our
other dashboards and you actually do
that using a filter action so we're
going to name that action go
to
sales dashboard
and we wanted to happen when we click on
our sales sheet so you see right here it
shows us the two sheets that are on this
dashboard when we click on the profits
dashboard we don't want this action to
occur this is our go to sales dashboard
now you can have an action occur on
hover
or select you've seen select happen
that's what our filter uses filter
actions use and on menu so we're going
to do it on menu
and
the targeted sheets it defaults to this
dashboard saying when i click on this i
want the rest of this dashboard to
update but instead it's going to take us
to our sales dashboard
so when we click on this i want these
sheets to update
now
we're going to define what filters it's
going to apply by default it's going to
apply all of the filters based on what
we click so if we click here it will
filter to just 2013. let's say we click
here it'll filter to just 2013 and it
will filter to the region we selected
so
let's see what happens when we do that
okay it's just going to default okay
now when i click on this it's going to
filter to 2013 and west go to sales
dashboard this is where it pops up when
you have it on menu
it's taken us to our sales dashboard it
is filtered 2013 and west
just so you know actions will not affect
these filters here you see that it
thinks all of them are selected because
it creates a separate filter there is
such thing as show only relevant values
for these filters so if we click this it
will filter this to only the ones that
are relevant so we can see that it's
only 2013 that this dashboard is
filtered down to but if we click all
values in the database this filter
doesn't have any only one particularly
selected it does have them all selected
right now
so
we can get here
for that information and to get back
we just need to navigate back to overall
great so it works there
but when we click on this up here
go to sales dashboard
we get a blank dashboard now
that happens because
it's trying to pass region information
to that dashboard
but this doesn't have any region detail
on this line it doesn't know what that
is so it's giving it a bad region value
so let's fix this
go to our actions we're going to edit
our go to sales dashboard and we're
going to select what fields
it'll filter on
we will filter on
our order date
year
and
let me go back to that
we clicked order date year and it goes
to the target data source sometimes your
target data source will be a different
data source than the one that you are
using for your source data source now
that gets a little bit complicated right
now we're just using one data source so
that's not something you need to worry
about in a simple visualization like
this
okay and we're gonna add one more
we're gonna add region and it
automatically selects region over here
but you could select it yourself let's
see what happens here okay if
one dashboard has region in it and the
other dashboard doesn't have region in
it or doesn't allow you to filter by
region then sometimes you'll get an
error here that will say it's missing
out of your target dashboards
so we don't have any errors so let's see
what happens
so we go to click here
go to sales dashboard
what if
we
take out region
remove region and we're just doing it
based on year
okay okay
click here go to sales dashboard and
there everything is
so now
it will filter back to the year that you
selected so this is all 2013 but it will
not filter to the region you selected
so even when we come here and we select
west
it takes you to the dashboard but it
doesn't filter it to west
you have to do that yourself
so now we have links
from sales to
sales
let's make one for profit to profit
go to sales dashboard add action
filter
we're going to call this go to profit
dashboard
and we're only going to come from the
profit table to make this happen let's
go to profit and let's select our fields
we're going to do the same thing
where it's only going to filter it to
the year now you can see oh i started to
type in i didn't show you this before
but you can
search text so i started typing in year
and it shows you that under order date
you have all these different options in
this dashboard right now if you remember
we're using the continuous one that is
marked by
the little calendar
so that's it knows it's a calendar date
instead of just trading it like a
discrete field
okay
excellent go to profit dashboard and
there we go this visualization like we
said when it's filtered to just one year
isn't quite as useful but one thing you
can do
is for west here we can select
both years i'm i'm going to do it by
control clicking click click
go to profit dashboard
and now we've got 2015 and 2016. so
that's how you do linking between the
two dashboards if you wanted to be able
to include region as well you could
put a note in the tooltip for this that
this doesn't work for
region linking from this area doesn't
work or perhaps
you could not have this total line on
the same visualization you could have a
separate visualization that shows the
total or an area chart instead and that
will let you not have this problem of go
to sales dashboard not linking
appropriately
so now we're going to create our final
dashboard our segment dashboard and it's
going to use
a parameter in it so we'll get to take a
look at parameters on dashboards
so let's rename this we're going to call
it
profit and sales
by segment
you don't have to name all of your
dashboards a description of what they
are but it makes it really nice and easy
and it automatically puts it up here but
if you wanted to change this you can
just come in here and name this whatever
you like and then it will just show up
up here so
we could call this segment analysis
click apply or okay and there it goes
that means this and this does not have
to be the same
if we go forward again segment analysis
and profit and sales by segment that
allows you to have some
more useful names down here that make it
easy when you're looking at them side by
side but have a name to match your
dashboard up here great so we're going
to
make
a profit in sales it's going to be a
bars and circles chart and we're going
to bring in our segment that we haven't
looked at yet
consumer corporate and home office and
then we're going to look at it segment
and we're going to make a matrix with
category and we get to fill in this
space with our
visualizations so we're going to do
sales
and it's going to make these bar charts
so we can see for technology by consumer
by corporate by home office and that is
a matrix of bar charts but we also want
to be able to see profit
and right now it's making two sets of
visualizations but we want just one so
let's dual axis
and it's automatically changed it to
circles also it is not
synchronizing the axis now because
profit is blue and these profit is not
anywhere near the same amount as sales
which makes sense you shouldn't have
profit that's higher than sales so let's
synchronize our axis
and let's change our sales our marks
card over here is associated with sales
it's nice and easy when the two marks
cards are based on a different measure
to let you know which one you're
affecting and we'll change that to a bar
and now we have a circle on
a bar chart now if we had profit in
front of sales
you can see how it's behind and you can
fix that by taking it to the back of
sales
another way you can fix it
say you wanted the profit axis here over
here for some reason you can right click
on the axis and put mark type or oh move
marks to front
another way to change it we don't need
both of these
so let's not show that header and we
don't need this to be labeled profit
because it's for both of them so the way
you get rid of that is actually you
click edit axis
and then you just erase the title
oh and you don't hit reset you just
erase the title
and then you close it
so now no title here but we still have
the axes
and we have three sets of bar charts
across excellent the next chart we're
going to build oh so right now they are
it automatically added the colors based
on measure names measure names is a
dimension that is created by tableau and
it's just what it sounds like we're
coloring it based on the different
measure names one of them's named profit
one of them's named sales and we know
that you can come here click color and
hit edit colors and it will open this
dialog box but you can also come here
and double click on a color pops open
that dialog box let's
pick a palette
let's see
there's a lot of different ones of these
tableau 20 let's pick colors from this
palette
profit can be
so you click here make sure it's
highlighted click the color you want
click here make sure it's highlighted
click the color you want
hit
apply and then you can come to color and
make it a little more opaque
whatever when you make it more opaque
you start to be able to see through your
circles there are benefits but also
drawbacks to doing that
anyway so stick with the tableau orange
blue great we have our first chart our
next chart is going to be called
top
customers
by sales and this is where we're going
to use our parameter where we made our
top end customers so
let's bring in
our sum of sales make a bar chart for
that and then we're also going to we're
bringing in our set now so we have our
in and our out we're going to break up
our set
by our segment as it's part of our
segment analysis and we'll bring in our
customer names
and let's sort it excellent now you can
see that when we sorted it it didn't
take this big guy and put it all the way
at the top it just sorted it each within
its own section great and so here we
have our in and out and that's not a
super user-friendly title for
our users of this dashboard they're like
in and out
of top end customers by sales maybe we
want this to say something a little bit
more user-friendly so let's make a
calculated field and we're going to call
it the top and customers
label
and we're gonna go and say if
and we're gonna use our set top end
customers by sales and since it's an in
their outset it treats this like
if it's in top end customers by sales
then
top
we're gonna
um do with string so it's gonna be top
and then we wanna use the number that's
in our parameter so we have to convert
it from a number to a string and we have
to concatenate them together in tableau
you can use a plus sign top and always
make sure you have space between what
you're concatenating together that's
something that i tend to forget
top space customers so if they pick 20
it'll say top 20 customers
so if it's in the set then top blank
customers
else if it's not in the set we will just
call it other and in tableau you always
need to end your if statement with an
end here it tells us our calculation is
valid while we're here i want to show
you a little trick there's this arrow
button here
that can give you all of the different
functions that are available within
tableau
and it even sorts it out by different
categories so if we didn't know how to
make this into a string we could go to
type conversion we could click on string
and it gives you an example also when
you click on
a function in here did you see how it's
on date and then i clicked on string and
i'm like what does this do click on it
and it tells me so this makes it really
useful inside of tableau also in tableau
you can make a comment in here so if
somebody's like what's going on here you
can press dash dash or
slash slash and type in
this is a more user-friendly
title hit okay and there we go we have
our more user-friendly title we drag it
here we see our top 20 customers and
other and we don't want to show this
anymore but we still want it in place
you can click right click on it up here
and click show header and it hides it so
that in out is still happening there and
let's drag it to our filters and there
we have it we have our top link
customers and it tells you right there
how many and we need to come here to
parameter right click and click show
parameter control and that's how we can
control
these changes so let's set it to 10 at
first and we have it
our top customers by sales but it's
interesting to know profit as well so we
have really big sales but how is their
profit doing so let's draw profit on
color and you can see this person has a
negative amount of profit despite their
big sales so that's important for us to
know and we can change our color like we
did previously to go from red to blue
and we can
change our center to zero
and now we can see the negatives really
quickly
now they're not the only one either have
a negative profit but some of our
highest sales that's great to know
excellent those are our visualizations
for the segment dashboard so let's talk
about filters really quick we have this
filter we won't show the filter itself
we don't want to allow them to
show in or out we just are going to
allow them to show how many but we do
want to be able to have them filter by
category so let's show that filter and
by segment
show that filter and and then we'll have
our parameter great let's make our
dashboard
um automatic as you probably read right
there the dashboard will resize to fit
any screen it is displayed on that can
be really handy especially if your
visualization is really dynamic and can
change however some visualizations like
this visualization for example if it
gets too squished you stop being able to
read things very well so automatic has
its definite pros and cons
so we're gonna bring on our profit and
sales by segment and it already pops up
with its legend and total customers
by sale and it pops up with its legends
and filters and it pops up with its
parameter now i'm going to close that
and be like if you don't see your
parameter when you first bring it in the
parameter is affecting this sheet and
you can go to parameters and find it but
parameters are
workbook wide meaning that it's going to
exist over here too
it doesn't affect this sheet however
it's still going to show up there
because it could affect it is available
for any sheet and it's the same there is
no determining what worksheets this
affects this will affect any sheet that
it is on so if i i've changed it to 10
and if i come down here and go back to
the other visualization that uses it
this is why i should name my sheets
let's see if i can find it
nope
here we are sheet 13. in sheet 13
we have our top 10. so i've got a 10 and
i've got a 10 over there and if i change
it to 20
and i go back to my segment dashboard
it is also changed to 20. so it will
affect all sheets always very important
to know great so here's our
visualization
here
are some of the more useful legends so
let's
make this floating and put it over by
the visualization it matters for we can
do the same thing here floating right up
here floating
does not work very well
for if you were to make this an
automatic dashboard so that the size
changes all the time because floating
could end up right on top of your
visualization and keep you from being
able to see what you need to see and
let's make these affect
all the dashboards in the workbook
again we don't have to do this for our
parameter
it will already affect all the
dashboards in the whole
workbook
and
format these
another thing you should know is that
there are more formatting options for
these
including edit title so it's already
named it category automatically but if
you had
like here oh this is a great example
edit title top end customers and you
could change it to
select
number of top customers
or something like that give it a little
more space
and yeah these floating ones do not
shift when you shift things so it's
always good to double check your
floating legends
and this is a little bit more
user-friendly
than the title we made for the
developers
and that's using parameters in a
dashboard
today in this video we learned about an
overview of business intelligence on
tableau we talked about how to install
tableau public and how to connect to a
data source
we also talked about creating calculated
fields
like this one
we talked about making sets and
parameters
we learned how to make a donut chart
and a 2d donut chart we learned about
making dashboards
and adding filters to those dashboards
and we also learned about connecting
between dashboards today we will be
learning about the topics we discussed
in part one live versus extract data
sources we'll talk about joins and
unions and we'll look at table
calculations we'll look at the rank
functions and we'll look at actions
specifically url actions we'll talk
about reference lines and bands we'll
look into some insights in the data such
as delay analysis also we'll learn how
to build a waterfall chart and then
finally we will learn about level of
detail calculations while making two
different visualizations
in part one of this tableau training we
introduced tableau basics and we learned
how to create
donut charts and two-dimensional donut
charts and we learned about linking
between dashboards if you missed part
one please check out the link in the
description below
now let's discuss the difference between
a live connection and an extract
connection first it's important to note
that these different types of
connections are not available in tableau
public it's always a live connection and
a live connection is where the data will
update based on when the source of the
data updates so if any if you're
connected to a database and something in
the database changes
then you'll pick up those changes when
you open the report as it will query
that database when the report is opened
whereas an extract connection
is extracted into creates a subset of
the data that improves performance so
when you're looking at it locally on
your computer you have an extract of
that data set that subset of the data
right on your computer or up in tableau
server depending on where you're looking
at it and it does not update
when the database updates it only
updates when your refresh updates it so
without a refresh set for that extract
you won't get the new data as an example
of this let's say
that in our
sample superstore we have kelly williams
associated with the central region but
that's changed so let's go ahead and
change that
we will change it to
sarah smith
and
we'll save it
now let's go back to our tableau
workbooks
and you can see we can refresh it over
here and see sarah smith come in
over here in our extract
it sarah smith doesn't come in
if we click to refresh the extract it
doesn't refresh the extract until we
navigate to sheet 1
but when we go back to our data source
then we see sarah smith coming in so
that refresh can be scheduled and it
could run once a day
or once every several hours
but you would need to set up a refresh
or else you would never get sarah
smith's data coming in
next let's talk about joining data in
tableau so here we have the people table
but let's say we want to join it to our
orders information so i'm going to start
with our orders table
and then we're going to pull on people
and tableau is going to
create a join for us and it's going to
choose the column that we would like to
join on based on the names in the two
data sources so if these two data
sources didn't have a column that had
the same name then tableau wouldn't be
able to guess
what
two to join on
so we would have to come in and select
out of the order side
and the people side
what we'd like to join on and then we
have the options to do an inner join a
left join a right join and a full outer
join let's review quickly what these
look like so say we had two tables that
we wanted to join together one of them
was the student table that had the
student names and the key to their grade
and which we could use to look up their
grade over here in the grade table which
had the key to their grade and the
actual grade a b c d f and incomplete
we can see here that somebody has made a
mistake and put in a letter grade
instead of the key to the letter grade
and we'll see how that affects what
we're looking at
so if we were to do an inner join
that would only take
the rows where the join could complete
so
we have one that could join to one just
fine but we don't have two and we don't
have three a doesn't join to anything so
this row would be
not included and then four
five and six would all join so that
would look something like this where we
would see adam
um when we grab student from this table
and grade from this table we can see
adam had an a beverly had an a dale had
a d elizabeth had an f and frank is
incomplete and charles is missing also
you don't see
any b or c in this list of grades
for a left join
it's going to take everything
from the left table
and only the pieces from the right table
that apply to the left table so it looks
pretty similar to our inner join
only charles shows up so the join wasn't
able to complete since a doesn't exist
in grade but we include charles anyways
and grade
becomes null
for charles it won't put in the grade
key because it's we're not asking for
the grade key we're asking for grade
from the grade table so we try to look
up a inside of the grade table we can't
find it and never tolerance no we look
up a inside the great key perfect right
join is like a left join only it takes
everything from the right table instead
of the left table
so it grabs all the grades a b c d f and
incomplete and only the rows from the
left table that
join appropriately
so since charles isn't joined
appropriately he doesn't show up we also
have b and c showing up
even though it doesn't exist in the
student table
and it won't be tied to a student
because that join wasn't able to
complete as it didn't exist over there
and the last one is a full outer join
where it takes everything from both
tables
whether or not the join is complete so
we have all of the people where the join
completes we also have charles where the
join doesn't complete from the left to
the right and we have b and c where the
join doesn't complete from the right to
the left
so those are our options in tableau
here
in our sample superstore data set
you could look and see if there are any
regions in the orders table that don't
exist in the people table and that's how
you can know what kind of join you want
and so if you want those orders to still
show up even though they don't have a
region
or their region is
not in
the people table that's when you would
do a left join
for our purposes
we'll do an inner join
now let's say
we had a second
excel sheet here
that had more
orders and you can do a union
which is just adding more orders
by dragging that second orders table
right underneath the original orders
table you can see it says their drag
table to union and that's helpful for if
you have an excel sheet for maybe
different years so say you had a
separate excel sheet for the orders in
2015 and then another one for the orders
in 2016 you could pull on your 2015
orders and then drag your 2016 orders
right there to union and it would take
these orders and then
add the rows instead of the columns for
the 2016 orders
for example we've added people
but as a join and that will
first put in all of our orders
as columns and then add the columns for
our person
but if we were adding more data that
fell under the order
columns so it would have the same data
the same order id ship date but we
wanted to add more rows then that would
be when you union
now we're going to take a look at
calculations and which ones are
calculated on the database side versus
which are calculated on the table side
so here we have percentage of total
sales split up by subcategory and
category
we also have
percentage of total sales along table
down so the difference between these two
things are one of them is made using
a calculated field
which is where we do the sum of sales
divided by the sum of fixed sum of sales
this part is called a level of detail
calculation
and this calculation the sum of sales
and the sum of the level of detail of
sales
which basically makes
the database find the total
sum of sales regardless of
these dimensions we pulled on
so it gives us our total number so this
will be sum of sales for bookcases and
this will be sum of sales for everything
this calculation is done on the database
side whereas this one percentage of
total sales along table down is what's
called a table calculation
it's a quick table calculation of
percent of total and it is done
in tableau
it's processed locally right inside of
the table after the aggregations have
occurred
there are some pros and cons of doing it
this way
so
for
this percent of total sales
i had to create the table calculation
here and it does the fixed
sum of sales where it finds the sum of
sales for the entire database
and since it is fixed it will ignore
filters so for example
i took off both of the sales and i'm
just going to put on the percent sum of
sales and let's say we wanted to see
how office supplies and technology are
as percentages of sum of sales
and ignore furniture
so we can grab category and we'll
control
click and drag
and we're going to unselect furniture
and hit ok
now it's still
taking it out of the total sum of sales
including furniture and so our grand
total down here is only 67 instead of
100
whereas
if we take
sales
and double click it and it adds it over
here on the table then we right click
and do a quick table calculation
and click
percent of total
this one is doing it out of 100 and
these numbers don't match
and that's because it does take into
account the filter of category so let's
pull the filter of category off and we
can see that they're both out of 100 now
and each of these take into account
um
the same amount of data since we have no
filters here
so if you wanted to take into account
the filters on the table
then you need to use a table calculation
however when you push the information
back to the database to do the
calculation it's doing it as part of the
query to the data source and it can save
you some time and so which one of these
is faster sort of depends on
what data is available already when the
original query comes back
next we're going to discuss ranking in
tableau
first let's add a second data source so
we can do that by coming up to data and
clicking new data source
or you can just click this plus data
source right here and click microsoft
excel
we're going to use this rank example
worksheet
perfect and it's already pulled in the
sheet we want because there's only one
sheet
and we'll go to sheet2
pull on store
pull on sales
and we will rename sheet2
as
rank example
great so now we have here's all of our
stores and here are our sales and if we
wanted to rank them
based on who had the highest sales to
the lowest sales we could create a
calculated field
called ranked by sales
and we're going to use our rank
function
and we're going to put in sales now we
receive this error here so when we hover
we see what that arrow says oh you can
click and it says all fields must be
aggregate or constant when using table
calculation functions or fields from
multiple data sources so we learn
something unique here
that you might not know is that a rank
is a table calculation
and it requires it to be aggregated
so
we can make sum
and put the parentheses around sales
and our error goes away so now we know
rank is a table calculation
and we have our box here that expands
out and can teach us about what we're
using here so when i click on rank it
will tell us that it returns the
standard competition rank for the
current row
and it says identical values are
assigned an identical rank so let's see
what that looks like we'll hit okay
we'll double click on rank by sales
and we can see our ranks so e had the
highest sales so it's one
d is next and c and b are tied
20 and 20
and so they both share the rank of three
and then because they are two of them
that share the same rank we skip four
and the next one gets fifth place
but now this isn't the only way to rank
so let's make another one of these we'll
click duplicate
and edit
let's erase copy
and we're going to call this rank dense
by sales double click on rank start
typing rank again and we're going to
click rank dense
now the difference here is that
rankdents returns the rank
where identical values are assigned an
identical rank but no gaps are inserted
in the numbers
so click ok double click rank dense and
you can see instead of going one two
three five
it goes one two three four
so it doesn't include that gap now let's
give them a little bit more space here
and maybe i wanted to be in the order i
created it so these measure values are
defining what's going to happen up here
so we can take sales and put it at the
top
and that'll move sales to the front and
put ranked dents at the bottom so now we
can see sales we can see rank by sales
we rank dents by sales
now let's duplicate
and
look at the next one
we have rank
modified
next
and
change the name here you notice that i
receive an error
and that's because that name already
exists tableau won't allow you to use
the same name
and it will give you that error so those
errors can be pretty helpful in finding
out what's going on hit apply
and okay and then double click rank
modified by sales
and now we can see
the difference here
let's go back here and
look at what it says here click on rank
modified and it says it returns the
modified competition rank where
identical values are assigned an
identical rank
but
what happens instead
is instead of both receiving three
for third place
they both receive four
which is the lower of the options so if
we were going by rank and we just
arbitrarily decided that this one's
third place and this one's fourth place
then they both receive the same rank
here but they receive the higher of the
two options whereas this one receives
the lower of the two options
and let's do one more
duplicate
edit
erase copy
and we're going to do
rank
unique
and let's change the name
to rank unique
perfect and now this is going to give it
a unique
ranking even when they share the same
number so we'll hit apply
okay double click rank unique
and we have one two
three four and five
so what it's doing is
let's quickly
look here so
rank by sales
we haven't talked about this yet but you
can choose to rank it ascending or
descending that means that do we want to
rank it based on
whether you see here it says ascending
or descending and that's how you will
define so right it defaults to
descending and it's saying the biggest
is the best
so
in for sales that's accurate so what
it's doing is biggest down now here it
has to decide which one to give three
and which one to do for
and it's doing that based on the ascii
values
of the store
so it's looking at more information on
the row and since uppercase b comes
before lowercase c uppercase b is
getting the three
even though they both have 20 for sales
let's go back now to our orders data
and we'll make a new sheet
and now we're going to talk about
actions in tableau we've talked about
actions briefly before
in our tableau training video for
beginner so if you want to see the
introduction you can go and look there
also if you want to follow along with
our data sets you can comment below and
ask and the simply learn team will get
you that data set
so let's make a chart where we're going
to look at
category so we'll drag category onto
columns and then we're going to look at
sales so we'll drag sales onto rows and
it will create three bar charts for us
and we're going to
call this
sales by category
now let's make a second chart that we
will use together and we'll bring
category onto columns and we'll bring
subcategory onto columns
and let's bring sales
onto rows again
and let's
take
subcategory and bring it on to color and
that makes each sub category its own
color and we'll call this sheet
sales by subcategory
so now back to sales by category here
you can make a worksheet
action where we're going to
move from the sales by category sheet to
the sales by subcategory sheet and also
filter down that sheet to only the
category we want to see
so click filter
and we can name this filter
go to subcategory
and we're going to do this filter on
select so this name won't be seen except
for in our actions list
and what sheets do we want to affect
we're going to have
sales by category show up one thing to
note here it is only showing the sheets
for it to affect based on the ones that
are using this data source at this point
so you can see we have four sheets down
here but it's only showing three sheets
and that's because rank example if you
recall is using the rank example data
source so you can click here and you can
see all the sheets or you can see the
other
data source if we click rank example it
will show the rank example data source
so we just want sales by category to be
the source sheet
and the target sheet we want it to be
sales by subcategory
so on select we want it to be sales by
subcategory we're going to use all the
fields available
to create this filter and hit ok so now
we have our go to subcategory on select
we'll hit ok again and let's
make this a little wider so we can see
and so when we click on furniture it
will take us to only furniture of
the sales by subcategory we go back to
category we click on office supplies now
we just see office supplies
and this is
a way to make tableau drill to a lower
level
great so we have those
now let's
duplicate this sales by category sheet
and let's see if we go to worksheet and
we go to
actions
you can see that we have the action here
go to subcategory that still exists on
our duplicated sheet as well so you can
see it's affecting both sheets sales by
category and sales by category 2. let's
say we don't want that and we can
unselect sales by category
and hit okay
and hit okay
now when we go to worksheet actions
you can tell that it's not affecting
that sheet so if we come and click
technology nothing should happen but we
go to sales by category and click
technology it'll take you to the
technology subcategory
great so we have our sales by category
two let's bring it to the end
rename it
we're going to call it sales by category
stacked
because we're going to take subcategory
here and drag it onto color
and now we can see our different
subcategories
in the colors there
now we can take a look
here
and sort by
subcategory based on some of sales
and now you can see that
it is the biggest sales at the bottom
for each subcategory that's just
a way that i like to view it so
let's do a highlight action and we're
going to do it on a dashboard
so let's take
sales by
subcategory
and look at it over top of our sales by
category stacked over top of sales by
sap category so we want both of those
let's make our
dashboard automatic for
testing purposes
and we'll go to dashboard we'll click
create actions so we're going to add an
action it's going to be a highlight
action
highlight sales by
subcategory
and we are going to have the sales by
category stacked be the source sheet and
the sales by subcategory be the target
sheet for all fields okay
okay and on select you can highlight
your chart there
and see where it falls inside of the
other visualization
a cool thing you can do is you could
select office supplies here and it will
highlight all of office supplies or if
you drag and select a couple of them it
will show you those so you're just like
i want to see all these small ones or i
want to see
this one and these small ones or
whatever then it will highlight the ones
that you drag and select now this is
also true of our sales by subcategory
and sales by category so when we clicked
on technology it filtered to just
technology
and we'll undo that and when we drag and
click
office supplies and technology we get
office supplies and technology now if we
go back to the dashboard we can see that
this dashboard is now filtered also to
office supplies and technology and
that's because we're using the same
sheet
and when you navigate away from that
sheet it doesn't mean that your filter
goes away
so when i clicked undo that's when it
caused the filter to go away so
if you're going to have two
things affect that sheet
just remember that just because you
navigated away from what you selected
doesn't mean that what you selected goes
away that filter will stay there it
shows up right here
and if we pull it off everything goes
back to normal however the action is
still there so when you click on it it
comes back
now let's take a look at the last kind
of action which is a url action
so we're going to make a map based on
state so i'm going to double click state
and it's going to build out my map let's
change it to a field
map
by clicking map up here
and we're going to take sales and put it
onto color
so now it's colored based on the darkest
is the highest sales
we're going to put state onto label so
you can see the state name and we're
going to put sales on to label
so we can see the sales amount let's
quickly change our default property for
sales
so that it always shows up as currency
and we're gonna
lose the decimal places
so it'll by default show up with a
dollar sign and
so on
great so now we have our sales map and
we're going to create
a worksheet action now the difference
between a worksheet action and a
dashboard action is that a worksheet
will only affect the worksheet and
dashboard will only affect the dashboard
and so when we created our worksheet
action on sales by category if we were
to pull sales by category onto the
dashboard that action won't transfer
over you'll need to make a dashboard
action
so we're going to make a go to url
action we're going to have it on menu
we're going to call it wiki
and it's going to only affect
our new sheet
sheet 6 which we should rename and we're
going to have a url in here so this will
take us to wikipedia and then whatever
you put at the end of the wikipedia link
it will take you to that page on
wikipedia so
we're going to take state and add it to
the end of that link
and now to test the link you can just
click test link
and it will take a random value and show
you what it will look like
so now that's how we know that we have
our link set up
okay
let's rename our sheet to
[Music]
url
filter by state
and so when we click on texas
okay back to url filter by state let's
go to our worksheets
and go to our actions and on the go to
subcategory
it is also affecting this url filter by
state because we didn't unselect it now
to keep that from being a problem we're
going to just come here and sales by
category be the only sheet and that way
it won't auto select no sheets as you
create them
so we'll no longer have that problem you
click on texas and nothing happens
except for it highlights that one only
that's how it should be but when we
hover on texas and wait long enough oh
yeah on click sometimes you just have to
hold still it'll come up with our little
link here and we click on wiki and it
will open up
our browser with the wikipedia page for
texas this can become really handy in
the event that you have data that maybe
has an order id and you can take that
order id and insert it into a url in
your system so that it can take you to
your web interface page for that order
here it's helpful for if we wanted to
learn more about the state of california
which
it can have information about the
languages spoken
and population
which can be helpful when we're looking
into our sales information
another way this can be useful is by
showing the web page right inside of
tableau so let's make a dashboard
change our size to automatic and let's
pull in url filter by state
if we go to dashboard actions you can
see there are no actions for this
dashboard yet so we're going to add a go
to url action on select
and since it's on select the name of
this url
won't
show up
but it will show up in our list here so
it's nice to name it something unique
let's put in our wikipedia page and
it'll take us to state so we'll hit okay
okay and now when we click on oklahoma
it'll open up a page for oklahoma
but let's unselect oklahoma if we drag
on web page from the objects here
you don't even have to enter anything
for your url you just hit ok and now we
have the bottom half of the screen is a
web page and when we click on oklahoma
instead of taking us to oklahoma in a
separate thing it'll take us to oklahoma
right here
in the visualization so we'll change it
to texas and this will change to texas
if you unselect it leaves the page there
based on the one that you had just
selected
next we're going to take a look at
reference bands and lines so let's make
a new sheet
and we're going to call it
reference
lines
and so a reference line is found on the
analytics pane
and it is something that comes and draws
a line on your visualization based on
the data on the screen so
let's make
our visualization we'll do our category
and subcategory again
and we'll double click on sales
and it brings it onto text that's not
what i want so let's do sales onto rows
and we have our bar charts
and
we'll talk about the difference between
a cell a pane and the table so when we
go to analytics
and we code to drag our reference line
onto
our visualization it says you can add
the reference line for the whole table
for a pain or for a cell
so
[Music]
if we
take our subcategory and drag it onto
color
since the subcategory is our lowest
level it's going to define our cell
so each one of these if we drag our
reference line onto
cell
each one of them gets a reference line
you see how it added those on this is
our dialog box we will look at that in
just a moment
so let's remove that if we take
reference line and put it onto pane
that's going to be similar to having
category on a color so each of these
different colors
is now a pane
reference line onto pane and you see how
we get reference lines
based on each pane
so let's undo that
and now if we take category off and
everything is all one color and we take
reference line and put it onto table
now we have our reference line for the
whole table
great so we're going to do
find out the average for each
section
so i'm going to take category put it
back onto color and we'll take reference
line and put it onto pain
now we have our reference line it's
based on the computation of average
and it's using the value of sum of sales
so since it says sum of sales here you
might think that it was taking the cut
reference line and putting it at the sum
of the sales but that's not what's
happening it's just using our aggregated
version of sales to figure out the
average so instead of taking each
individual sale that makes up the
bookcase section it's taking the sum of
sales for the bookcase section and
comparing it to the sum of sales for
chairs
so it's taking an average across these
added up sections
we could also have it be
total
where it's adding all of these up and it
makes that total line
the sum line is the same as total in
this case
a constant which is where you get to
define the value and so if we wanted it
to be 200
thousand there it is
let's go back
there we are back to where we were
constant minimum which shows you the
minimum for each section
the maximum for each section
or the average
or the median so let's stick with
average and now you can see it's
labeling the line as average we could
also have it label the line as the value
so now we can see that the average is
this amount of dollars
or you can choose custom and then you
can put something in here
like maybe we wanted the computation a
colon
and then the value average this amount
you can also have a show recalculated
line for highlighted or selected data
points that means when you click on a
section it will recalculate the average
just for what you've selected we'll hit
ok
and so in that case when we click on
tables
you can see our
recalculated
average line
so the average for tables for just
tables
is the sum divided by the number so the
sum of tables is 206 96 divided by 1 is
still 2 6 9 66 so selecting just tables
is really helpful but if we wanted to
know the average of
tables and we'll control click
appliances
and we'll control click binders oh there
we go
all three of those are selected we can
see the average of those three which is
this line
you could also select like this
and see your new average oh and it's
doing the average independently so
select these guys and now we see the
average of just those
five categories
and those are reference lines
now let's duplicate this sheet
and i'll show you how to delete a
reference line
so we'll rename this to reference
bands
click on this reference line
right click and click remove and it
takes it off we have the same thing for
reference bands we had with reference
lines where you can have it be for the
whole table per pane or per cell so
let's do a reference band for the whole
table so it's doing entire table
and it's taking from the minimum to the
maximum now we could change the minimum
to be the average to the maximum and now
that will highlight the whole table
everything that's above the average
becomes highlighted
and if you wanted to change it you could
do the minimum to the average
but let's go to
average to
maximum and then you can change things
like you can add lines so we have a line
for the average of the maximum you can
make it thinner you can make it dotted
you can change your fill so maybe if you
don't want it to be quite that dark you
can change it to be a little bit of a
lighter color of gray
and you can have show recalculated band
for highlighted or you can remove that
and that way when we highlight stuff
everything just stays where it belongs
for the entire table
and that's how you create a reference
band
reference bands and reference lines can
be really handy in making
several different kinds of
visualizations such as bullet charts
if you have any questions about that
please comment below and the simply
learn team will get back to you now
let's do another analysis on average
days to ship
and for this one we're going to
look at it by state
and we're going to look at it by
ship mode
and so we'll take average stasis ship
and put it on columns
and now we can see
the average days to ship by first class
same day second class or standard class
and you can see
how they differ so let's
change the order of these really quick
if we come up here to ship mode and we
click sort and we click manual we can
have same day above first class so that
it kind of goes in order of priority so
same day first class second class
standard class
there we go and now we have it in
order of what you might expect and
priority and now we're going to create a
calculated field that we will use to do
a sort of conditional formatting
and we will name it delay analysis
great so let's do
if
the
average days ship
is less than or equal to two
then
we'll have it return the words
shipment early
so
if we want to press enter there that
won't cause any problems to our
calculation so you can press enter you
could have extra spaces and it won't uh
tableau will ignore those so this allows
us to format our calculated field in a
way that's easy to read so if it's less
than two then they're gonna call it an
early shipment
else if
average days to ship is greater than or
equal to five
then shipment
late
and
else if let's get the rest of them
and
average days to ship is
not less than two
greater than two
and less than
five
then
on time
two words
and now you can see we have an error
here
it says expected end to match if that
means that we don't have an end
at the end of our if statement
if statements always have to have an end
okay let's hit apply
and let's grab our delay analysis and
put it on to color
and it has on time as blue
early shipment
as orange
and shipment linked as red
we could double click on the color and
we can change shipment early to green
and now we can see
the best ones the on time ones and the
ones that stand out as late
and standard class happens late a lot
it's interesting to see that on average
the district of columbia
has second class as a legit late
shipment
you can see that all of these
share
the same axis size so they all go from
zero to six
even though this one never gets that
close to six
if we click edit axis
you can choose if you want that to be
the case so it's like right now all of
them use uniform access range for all
rows and columns and that's really nice
because it's easy to compare
colorado to colorado to colorado if you
change it to independent axis for each
rose you can see now this one only goes
from zero to not even one whereas this
one goes from zero to six
and you can compare it with color but
you can no longer compare it with size
across all of these different categories
so uniform access range is the default
in this
case and we will keep it that way
so now we have a quick analysis of our
delays
we're now going to build a waterfall
chart
based on profit
so we'll call this our profit
waterfall
and we'll take a look at what a
waterfall
looks like at the end and talk about how
it works
so after we build it we'll talk about
some of the benefits of having a
waterfall chart so what we're going to
do is build it over time for this
visualization we're just going to look
at the year of 2014 so i'm going to
filter it to the order dates for 2014
and then we're going to take our order
date and bring it onto columns and we're
going to look at it by month but we're
going to look at it by
our discrete month
so you can see that i chose the one that
has month and year
and then when i chose discrete
and then we're going to take profit and
put it onto rows and we're going to
change it from
profit
to
our running total of profit
so you can see that it takes january and
then it adds february to it
and so it's always getting bigger when
we undid it sometimes there's up and
down
so
back to
we only have our running total where it
will some january and february for the
february mark and then some january
february march for the march mark
if i take profit
and put it here you can see january is
negative three thousand and february is
positive two thousand but here it's the
sum of those which is negative 467.
take that back off we're gonna change
our marks to a gaunt
bar and now we're going to
duplicate profit
and edit what we have
we're going to call this negative
profit
and it's going to be just profit
with the negative sign in front
oh it looks like i've done this before
so
now we have a new name because i added a
space at the end so hit apply
and let's delete the old one
okay so now we have our negative profit
just to look at it it's just minus
profit i'm going to use that to
determine the size
of the gaunt bar
so
what it does
is it takes where the line was and it
adds the size of it to be the size of
profit but because the line was at the
top and we didn't want to build the
profit up we had to change it to
negative profit so it would build it
down
so here the line was down here because
it was so low negative and we added
negative profit and then let's take
profit and put it on color
and so you can see where profit is
negative it turns it orange
and my profit is positive it turns it
blue so what's happening here what we
can do now is we can see our total sales
at the end and how we got there so for
the first month we were at zero when we
started and we went down to negative
three thousand the next month we were at
negative 3000 when we started and it
grew up to be almost back to zero and
then we can see that from there on out
we grew up
each month and you can see how much each
month contributed
our biggest contributors are november
and march november being a little bit
bigger
and you can see where we started at the
beginning of that month and where we
ended and that's how a waterfall chart
works so it lets you go through over
time and see exactly where our problems
were
and exactly which months helped the most
where we started and where we ended for
each month
next we're going to talk about level of
detail calculation and we'll talk about
those first by showing an example
so i'm going to bring all my customers
on
by name and then i'm going to bring on
order id
and it's going to add all members but
then i'm going to change order id from a
dimension to
a measure and we have account distinct
so now we can see each customer and how
many
orders they have so let's sort it and we
can see
one person has 17 orders and we have
1 2
3 4
5 6 7
people have 13 orders
and it goes on from there
so what if we wanted to make a
visualization that would show
how many customers
had how many orders and what
number of orders was the most popular
we would need to do a level of detail
calculation so let's clear the workbook
a level of detail calculation allows you
to build a visualization
and bring on metrics that are at a level
that is different from what's shown on
the visualization
so
in order to do this
we need to
create a calculated field
that will show us
the number of orders per customer
even though we're not going to have our
visualization be per customer
so let's call this orders
per customer
and we'll come here and we're going to
use a level of detail calculation called
fixed
now there are
two other level of detail calculations
and they are called include
and exclude
and you can learn more about those
in
some of our simply learn classes and if
you have any questions please comment
below and we can answer them so we're
going to do it fixed
and you can choose
dimensions and it computes an
aggregation using only the specified
dimensions
so it will ignore all the other
dimensions and we're going to have it
based on customer name
so we're going to have fixed customer
name
and we're going to call
get account distinct
of order id
and make sure you close it with your
curly bracket and we have no errors and
we'll hit ok
and this allows us to see number of
orders per customer so
let's pull it out
first let's make it a dimension
and then pull it out onto our columns
and now we can see
one two three four five six seven eight
up to 17. so that means we had
some customers just order one and some
customers ordered 17 and we had them
order everything in between so if we'd
never had a customer that had nine
orders
then 9 wouldn't appear in this list now
we're going to take customer
id or name
let's do id because it should be unique
and we'll pull it onto rows and we're
going to change it to a measure
and it's going to be
account distinct
and so now we can see
how many customers ordered
how many items
so
we have our number of orders per
customer which is at the per customer
level even though this visualization is
not at the per customer level
there's nowhere in this visualization
where we pull on the customer
item as a dimension
so let's sort it biggest smallest
and we can see that 134 of our customers
ordered five items or had five orders
and so it just five is the most popular
seven is the next most popular 17 is the
least popular one is relatively
unpopular which is interesting to know
and so you can use this to analyze how
many items your customers generally
order
and maybe if they have four items
that they are going to order that
perhaps if you made good suggestions you
could get them to go up to five
and that's an introduction to level of
detail
so let's name this sheet
level of detail lod
orders per
customer
perfect
now let's make a new sheet
and we are going to
do an analysis about new customers
so we'll call this level of detail new
customer
analysis
so this visualization is going to be
about customer acquisition over time so
when we do things over time we grab our
date and pull it up here and for a line
chart or anything over time
we're going to
use these
so that it makes an axis
instead of just
change to line
instead of dimensions or something that
is not continuous and then we're going
to take our customer id
pull it onto rows but let's change it to
account distinct customer id and now we
can see our count of customers on every
day i think day is too low of a level
let's go ahead and month
so now we can see how many customers
made an order during one month
let's take region
and split it out by region
when we click on central we can see
central now this is including all
customers
but say we only wanted to include a
customer when they're making their very
first order
so we're only going to include their
first order so we need to create a
calculated field
and we want to compare
we'll call it new or existing
and we want to compare their order date
per customer
to their first order date the min
order date
nope
order date
and we're going to get this error it
says cannot mix aggregate which is min
and non-aggregate functions and what
it's saying here is that
this order date is at a per row level
since we don't have any aggregation on
it and this order date is at a per
visualization level so it's only going
to split up based on
the visualization and it won't let you
put those two things together so we're
going to
use our level of detail calculation
again
and we're going to make this fixed per
customer id
and then we'll do our min
order date
so now instead of
trying to return something different
based on the visualization it will
always return the min for each customer
id
so if the order date on the
visualization is equal to this order
date
if the order date on the visualization
is equal to the first order date for
that customer
then
new
else
existing
end
so
when the order date equals the very
first order date that means that it's a
new
customer making their first order
otherwise it's an existing customer
because it's no longer their earliest
date
apply
okay and now we can take our new field
which is new or existing and drag it
onto filters and we only want new
we'll hit apply
and we can see that we have new
customers
but
less over time
so
so now we're going to change this
count distinct
to be a running total and we can see
over time
how
our new customers are adding up so it's
taking the prior value and adding our
new customers and then at the end we get
our total customers for each
and we can now make this a more
the lowest level which is day
and you can see
places where it like levels out so we
can see we have a lot of new customers
and it's increasing but then here for
the region of east there kind of is a
level spot where we're not getting new
orders
and that seems to be the same for each
of them so for february of 2014 why were
we not getting any new orders and how
come the west region is getting new
customers how come the west region is
getting new customers faster here
while it's leveling out in the red
it looks like the west region
leveled out as well but picked up sooner
and started getting new customers
so this type of analysis will help you
view
new customers over time and it's only
possible because we were able to do a
level of detail calculation
here on new or existing
that would compare
this data at
only aggregating the data for the
specified dimension so we were able to
grab their minimum order date here so
those are a couple of ways that level of
detail calculations can be very helpful
in summary today we learned about
live versus extract tableau
data sources we learned about joins and
unions in the data sources we also
looked at table versus database
calculations we looked at how the
different ranks compare
we built some actions into our
dashboards filter actions and
highlighting actions we also looked at
url actions we built dashboards that
used reference lines and ones that used
reference bands we did analyzing of
average days to ship
and delay analysis
we build a waterfall chart
and we also looked into some level of
detail calculations and that brings us
to the end of our video on business
analytics and intelligence full course
2022 by simply loan i hope it was useful
and informative
if you have any queries please feel free
to put them in the comments section of
the video we'll be happy to help you
thanks again stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you